ALRIGHT GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
WELCOME TO OUR.
HEARING OF THE JOINT WAS HEAD OF
AUDIT COMMITTEE.
.
THIS IS OUR COMMITTEE SECOND
HEARING OF THIS YEAR ON AUDIT
REQUESTS.
AND.
.
WELCOME SENATORS I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THE POLICE REPORT TO ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX. WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE
A.
.
EFFICIENT.
AND THAT PRODUCTIVE HEARING SO
WE CAN TAKE CARE BUSINESS.
SAYING THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM WILL BE OPERATING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
AT C. BEFORE GOING FURTHER I
LIKE TO A QUICKLY MENTIONED THAT
WE HAD A VERY.
INFORMATIVE AND PRODUCTIVE.
WELL OVERSIGHT HEARING A LAST
MONTH.
A SET THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR BELL. ó AS WELL AS
SENATOR ALAN FOR THE.
.
BEING THE REQUEST YEARS OF THE.
IMPORTANT AUDIT.
AND OVERSIGHT HEARING ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
ALRIGHT I LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
STATE AUDITOR MS ELAINE HOW. AND.
WE.
WOULD APPRECIATE A STATUS
REPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NOW FOR THE RECORD
ELAINE HOW CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR.
AS THE MEMBER INDICATED WE HAVE
ONE J. LACK HEARING.
THUS FAR THIS YEAR.
WE DO HAVE QUITE A FEW
RESOURCES AVAILABLE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TEN AUDITS IN PROGRESS
WE'VE STARTED ALL OF THE AUDITS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED AT
THE LAST HEARING SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING.
WAITING FOR STAFF WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NINE J. LACK AUDITS IN ONE
STATUTORY AUDIT WERE AUDITING
I'M HOUSING BONDS WERE REQUIRED
TO DO THAT PERIODICALLY.
WE HAVE SOME OTHER WORK IN
PROGRESS YOU DOING SOME FOLLOW
UP WORK ON A CUP ON ONE AUDIT
AND THEN I'M.
SOME HIGH RISK WORK OUR ART OUR
IT AUDIT GROUP IS DOING SOME
WORK OUT IT TO PARTNER HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. THERE ARE TWELVE
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE CONSIDERING TODAY WE HAVE
STAFF TO COMMENCE ALL OF THOSE
AUDITS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS. MOST OF THE
STAFF ARE AVAILABLE LATER THIS
MONTH IN EARLY IN JUNE SO WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO START. OUT AS
MANY AS TEN AUDITS BETWEEN.
THIS MONTH AND NEXT AND THEN
AND IN JULY.
.
COMMENTS ANY OTHER AUDITS THAT
ARE ARE APPROVED BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. GIVEN THAT WE
STILL WILL HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE ON TO MY UNDERSTANDING
WE WILL HAVE ONE MORE HEARING IN
AUGUST AS THIS COMMITTEE
TRADITIONALLY MEETS. AT THE END
OF SESSION TO TO.
APPROVE AUDITS FOR US TO WORK
ON THROUGH THE FALL AND
HOPEFULLY TO ISSUE MOST OF THOSE
EARLY NEXT YEAR WHEN MEMBERS
RETURN. SO WE WILL HAVE AT LEAST
TEN OR ELEVEN TEAMS AVAILABLE
FOR FUTURE AUDITS THAT MAY BE
REQUESTED BY MEMBERS OFF FOR THE
AUGUST HEARING.
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO OUR.
.
HEARINGS ON THE AUDIT REQUESTS
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION.
WE WILL HEAR IT.
THE ITEMS IN SIGN IN ORDER.
WE HAVE TWELVE AUDIT REQUESTS
TO CONSIDER THIS MORNING.
SIX OF THE AUDIT REQUESTS ARE
BEING PROPOSED FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND THAT LEAVES SIX AUDITS FOR
PRESENTATION TODAY.
I SEE.
.
SOMEONE MEMBERS JONES SAWYER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
.
AND.
THAT IS THE FIRST ITEM SO WHY
DON'T WE TAKE THAT UP THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER NINE ON THE REGULAR
CALENDAR.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
THIRTEEN.
I THE AUDIT REQUEST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS.
AND REHABILITATION.
NOBODY WANTED TO SIT NEXT TO ME
WHAT WAS WRONG MORE PHOTOGENIC.
NO NO.
I WARNINGS CHAIR MEMBERS HARDING.
MY COLLEAGUE AND I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IAN CALDERON UMP
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT THE
STATE AUDITOR CONDUCT AN AUDIT
TO EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE IN PRISON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS. AND
REBUILT REHABILITATION'S
CDC ARE.
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS HOUSE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND INMATES ANNUALLY.
AND RELEASES TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF OFFENDERS BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES EACH YEAR.
VARIOUS IMPRISONED
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS OFFERED
TO INMATES TO IMPROVE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL LEAD A
PRODUCTIVE CRIME FREE LIFE UPON
RELEASE OR. READ BRICK BUT
AREN'T AND NOT TO RECEIVE A. AS
CHAIR OF SUB FIVE FROM TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FOURTEEN.
I'M I WAS ABLE TO PUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
FOR REHABILITATION AND REENTRY
PROGRAMS.
SINCE THAT TIME I'VE ASKED FOR A
REPORT ON HOW THE MONEY WAS USED.
I'M YET TO RECEIVE.
A REPORT.
GIVEN THE KIND OF INVESTMENT
THAT WE WILL BE MAKING THROUGH
TO VARIOUS PROPOSITIONS ON 47-57
AND OTHERS WHICH COULD LEAD INTO
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ARM.
DISCOUNT OF INVESTMENT THAT
WE'RE MAKING IN HIS PROGRAM IT
IS NATURAL THAT WE IT'S A STATE
NEED TO EXAMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ACHIEVING
THEIR GOALS. AND OF PUBLIC FUNDS
ARE BEING USED EFFECTIVELY.
BOB I AM A BIG BIG PROPONENT OF
EVIDENCE BASED REHABILITATION.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS AUDIT IS
NOT ONLY PROVE THAT IT WORKS BUT
ALSO TO SHOW HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
AND MAKE SURE. THAT THE MONIES
THAT WE SPEND ON IN THE NEXT.
OUR HOPE THE NEXT DECADE.
ARE SPENT EFFICIENTLY
EFFECTIVELY I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER DONE
BEFORE.
WE USUALLY SPEND THE MONEY.
AND THAT WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE SUBMITTED
THIS IS GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
TERM IN THE BEST WAY TO PROCEED
SO THAT WE GET THE MOST THE BEST
OUTCOME.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK A
GUY VOTE.
AND MY COLLEAGUE IS HERE WITH ME
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION OFFERS INMATES
VARIOUS REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON.
INCLUDING EDUCATION AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROGRAMS THE PRIMARY GOAL OF
THESE PROGRAMS IS TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. TO EXTEND OUR TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE THE PROGRAMS
HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM THE CDC ARE SHOULD BE
COMMENDED HOWEVER IN DECEMBER
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO LA AND
REPORT THE ALEJO IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL. SHORTCOMINGS IN IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CDC OURS
VARIOUS REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
THAT COULD LIMIT THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAM SUCCESS.
FIRST IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER EACH
PROGRAM IS READ RESEARCH BASED
AND IMPLEMENTED IN THE SAME
MANNER AS THE MODEL PROGRAM
SECOND REHABILITATION SLOT TO DO
NOT APPEAR TO BE ALLOCATED OR
USED EFFECTIVELY. TO MEET IN MAY
NEEDS FINALLY THE REPORT NOTES
THAT CDC ARE USES.
LOTT APPROACHES FOR MEASURING
PROGRAM PERFORMANCE THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHETHER
EXISTING PROGRAM RESOURCES ARE
BEING USED EFFECTIVELY PRIOR TO
PURSUING ANY LEGISLATION
RECOMMENDING CHANGES. TO ANY IN
PRISON REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WE BELIEVE AN AUDIT IS NECESSARY
TO UNDERSTAND CDC OURS.
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS AS THE STATE PRIORITIZE
AND INCREASES FUNDING FOR
REPLAYABILITY ASIAN PROGRAMS
BECOMES EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT STATE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED. AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE WE SIMPLY NEED MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE DISCUSSING
FUNDING LEVELS OR ANY
LEGISLATIVE FIXES TO SEE YOU SEE
OURS INCREASE PRISON
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS WE
BELIEVE THIS AUDIT WILL PROVIDE
ENOUGH. INFORMATION TO MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS ON THESE
PROGRAMS ESSENTIALLY WE SPENT
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS WORKING AND WHAT ISN'T
WORKING. I BELIEVE IN EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS ARE ALSO THE SAME
TIME THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT
THERE ARE NOT PROGRAMS FOCUSED.
WITH ARTS THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
HELP OTHERS.
WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
REHABILITATING KEEP THEM FROM
RECEIPT OF AIDING A BUT THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE OUR MONEY.
AYE EFFECTIVELY ARE MONIES BEING
USED IN THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM WHICH IS IMPORTANT
FOR US.
THEN WE NEED TO TAKE THE TIME.
TO DO THAT AND TO LEARN THAT AND
UNDERSTAND IT SO THAT IS WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY AND WE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
STATE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS AS A
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS INDICATED THIS
WOULD BE IN OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
STARTING OUT BY LOOKING AT THEIR
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES THEIR
OVERSIGHT OVER THESE PAST STATE
FUNDED REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
ARE REALLY LOOKING AT THAT A FEW
KEY ISSUES AS THE MEMBERS
INDICATED IN THERE AND THEY'RE
OPENING COMMENTS AS. HAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS REALLY
DETERMINE THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO MEET THE
REHABILITATION NEEDS OF INMATES
STARTING SPECIFICALLY WITH HOW
DID THEY ESTABLISH THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS ARE THE PROGRAMS
EVIDENCE BASED. WHAT'S THEIR
JUSTIFICATION FOR THOSE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS HOW'RE THEY EVALUATING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THOSE
PROGRAMS MONITORING AND PROGRESS.
AND ARE WORKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH PROGRAMS WHAT TYPE OF
DATA ARE THEY MAINTAINING OR
COLLECTING WITH RESPECT TO
ENROLLMENT OF PROGRAMS
ATTENDANCE.
OUTCOMES SUCCESS.
FOR THE INMATES.
WHETHER OR NOT THE INMATES RISK
IN THE REHABILITATIVE NEEDS ARE
BEING MET HOW WHAT TOOLS ARE
THEY USING TO FIRST IDENTIFY
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL INMATES HAVE. AND HOW
DO THEY DETERMINE WHICH PROGRAMS
TO ENROLL THOSE INMATES AND AND
THEN TO ISSUES RELATED TO
PERFORMANCE METRICS HOW'RE THEY
ASSESSING WHAT METRICS ARE THEY
USING TO ASSESS. AND EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAMS AND THEN PERHAPS MAKE
SOME. CHANGES TO A PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
THEY'VE ASKED US TO LOOK AT THEY
DIDN'T MENTION IN THEIR COMMENTS
IS DETERMINING WHETHER THERE'S A
WAITLIST.
IF THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS ON A
WAITING LIST HOW HOW MANY HOW
LONG HAVE THEY BEEN ON THAT LIST
WHAT IT NEEDS OF THOSE
PARTICULAR INMATES ONE OF THE
ISSUES.
THAT LA O. MENTIONED WAS.
WHERE THEY HAVE THAT?
EFFECTIVENESS OF PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS IS MEETING THE NEEDS OF
INMATES THAT ARE HIGH VERY HIGH
RISK AND HAVE VERY VERY HIGH
NEED SO IN LOOKING AT THAT
WAITING LIST ARE ARE WE SEEING
INMATES ON THAT LIST. THAT
PERHAPS SHOULD BE PLACED INTO
PROGRAMS SO.
THE AUDIT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
HOURS WILL BE PRIMARILY FOCUSED
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
AS WITH ANY AUDIT IF WE FEEL WE
NEED TO BRING IN EXPERTISE TO
ASSIST US WE WILL WE WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. WE THINK WE CAN
HANDLE MOST OF THESE.
REQUESTS THAT ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS MEMBERS ASKED OUT WITH
OUR OWN STAFF A TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED OUR AUDIT WILL TAKE US
ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS OF STAFF TIME
TO COMPLETE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BACK VERY MUCH.
THE AUTHORS OR THE REQUEST
YEARS OF THE AUDIT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR PRESENTATION.
NO OKAY LARRY.
LIKE TO INVITE THEN.
THE.
RESPONDING AGENCY.
BELIEVE WE HAVE CHRIS APPLEGATE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY.
ALSO LEGISLATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION.
GOOD MORNING HERE IN MEMBERS
ABOUT CHRIS APPLEGATE ON THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
AS I REQUEST NOTES AND BOTH
MEMBERS OF NOTED THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
HAVE I MADE SOME SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING SO OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THIS VARIES FROM COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY CT
PROGRAMS LONG TERM OFFENDER
PROGRAMS THAT THREE TWO
INNOVATIVE GRANT PROGRAMS NOT
SOME CORRECTIONS PROGRAMS.
THESE HAVE BEEN SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS.
WE THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD OF AND
I WERE HAPPY TO COOPERATE WITH
THE ON IT.
HOWEVER WE. THINK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
ARE YOU BY ANY CHANCE RELATED TO
BILL APPLEGATE OF TORRANCE I AM
NOT.
YEAH.
YOU KNOW THAT'S A GOOD OR BAD
OKAY. MIGHT BE A VOTE.
ALL RIGHT.
OUR.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT THIS THOUGH. AS.
.
AS A MEMBER OF THE SENATE.
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THEIR
AUDIT I'M.
HAPPY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TOOK
THE INITIATIVE TO.
PRESENTERS TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND.
I HOPE THAT.
.
PRODUCTIVE.
IMPROVEMENTS CAN RESULT FROM
THAT SO.
.
I THINK THAT.
ONE AREA WHICH SUGGESTS THE
JUSTICE THAT GO INTO IT DESERVE
THE INTERRELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
PAROLE PROGRAMS AND. WHAT
HAPPENS TO HIM AFTER? THEY LEAVE
PAROLE AND ARE.
HEADED OFF TO YOUR COUNTY.
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. AND THEN THE ISSUE OF
WHERE THEY GO OR THEY HOME
BECOME HOMELESS HOUSING.
SERVE THE.
SIR THE HANDOFF BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
AND.
.
THE.
COUNTY I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT.
AREA.
.
I WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION OR
DOES THIS INCLUDE.
.
THE.
YOUTH. A JUVENILE PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT CORRECTION RESISTANT
DOOR.
IT'S ONLY.
IT'S ONLY BE ADULT BY COULD. WE
JUST PAYS ONLY TELLS YOU ALL
OKAY SO I JUST WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR BECAUSE I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING ONE OR THE OTHER.
SO IT'S WE'RE TALKING TO DOLE.
OKAY OKAY THAT'S GOOD OKAY.
.
I.
I THINK DID DO.
.
YOU KNOW THE RECEIVER.
HAS MANAGED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS YOU KNOW WITH A
COURT ORDER.
THE RECEIVER HAS.
DONE SOME THINGS THAT.
NONE OF US WOULD HAVE DONE.
IN TERMS OF DIRECTING LIKE THE
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND OTHER ASPECTS AND I THINK.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
WE'RE TRANSFERRING?
THE RESPONSIBILITY BACK.
TO.
THE DEPARTMENT THE LEGISLATURE
AWAY FROM THE RECEIVER. AND SOME
OF THOSE I JUST POINT OUT ONE
THING THAT I'VE ALWAYS BROUGHT
UP.
THE RECEIVER THE MENTAL HEALTH.
.
COURT CASE.
THE CLIENT TO INCLUDE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT.
AND THEN THEN AND THE RECEIVERS
OF RESPONSIBILITIES.
THE OTHER WORDS THEY. HOODED
MENTAL HEALTH.
BUT THE CLIENT TO INCLUDE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
TREATMENT.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED IS THEY HAD
MENTAL HEALTH. WITHOUT SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT WHICH IS
ILLOGICAL. YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
THAT HUESO NOW THE DEPARTMENT'S
TRYING TO.
CATCH UP TO THE BUDGET.
REDUCTIONS.
IN ALL OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
HAPPENED AND.
.
FIVE SIX YEARS AGO.
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO CATCH UP.
WE HAVE A SEVERE EGGMAN PROBLEM
OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
WERE. THE DEATHS IN THE PRISON
FROM FENTON ALL AND OTHER DRUG
ABUSE PROBLEMS.
SO IT'S BECOME A MAJOR. ISSUE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS SO APPRECIATE THAT I
JUST HAD THOSE COMMENTS TO MAKE.
YOU KNOW IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT SUBSTANCE ABUSE WAS NOT.
EMPHASIZED BY THE FEDERAL COURT
RECEIVER.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE.
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE AT THIS TIME I.
SEE WE HAVE A QUORUM OF SENATORS
WE NOW NEED A QUORUM OF SOME OF
THE MEMBERS WELCOME
REMEMBER BAKER.
.
YEAH.
PUBLIC COMMENTS ANY COMMENTS ON
THIS AUDIT REQUEST PLEASE COME
FOR.
I'M TELLING ROTH AUDEN FROM SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND. IN USUALLY
WITH A C. S. SUPPORTING ON US
LIKE THIS BECAUSE IN THE PAST
WE'VE HAD A FAIRLY ROCKY
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT I'M HERE WITHOUT GUILE TO
BASICALLY SAY THAT IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. AYE THIS
DEPARTMENT HAS REALLY STEPPED
FORWARD PARTICULARLY THEIR
REHABILITATION SECTION. THEY'VE
REHIRED MANY OF THE TEACHERS
THEY'VE TAKEN MANY OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT THE UNION PUT
FORWARD AND DR CHOATE WHO'S
RUNNING THE REHABILITATION IS
REALLY UNINSPIRED LEADER. IN SO
IT'S NOT SO MUCH THAT WE OPPOSE
THE IDEA THAT WE THINK THAT WE
NEED TO REWARD.
PEOPLE OVER AND CDC ARE THAT ARE
REALLY TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND HAVE MADE A GREAT DEAL
OF PROGRESS.
WE'VE SEEN AND IT'S NOT JUST.
RECIDIVISM WILL NOT JUST BE.
WHAT HAPPENS IN REHABILITATION
WILL NOT BE THE ONLY INPUT TO
REDUCING RECIDIVISM? WE'VE SEEN
THE RATE OF RETURN TO PRISON GO
FROM SIXTY SIX TO PERCENT TO
TWENTY TWO PERCENT.
WE THINK THAT'S AWESOME WE THINK
THAT THERE THE FORTY SIX PERCENT.
IS MUCH LOWER THAN THE OVER
SIXTY PERCENT RATE THAT WE HAD
BEFORE IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM SO
THEY ARE DOING A DECENT JOB
THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TO SAY WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS AUDIT
BECAUSE WE THINK WE NEED TO READ
MORE THOSE PUBLIC SERVANTS THAT
ARE REALLY TRYING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE OVER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTION.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL GO WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION I JUST LIKE TO ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF A IT'S
YEAH LOOK ONE THOUSAND WE ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS BUT. ALSO SEE MY
HANDS THERE'S.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER.
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
I'D LIKE TO.
DRIVE FIRST ADDRESS THE
QUESTION WELL WHAT WHEN WE GIVE
THE RIGHT WILL REQUEST AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO.
CONCERNS RIGHT REYES BY ASCII.
SO.
BUT THAT SOMEONE.
WHOSE JOB BEEN TO A LOT OF ROCKY.
ON AUDITS Y. WERE FOR THE CITY
OF INTO SEVERAL.
ON I'VE BEEN IN SOMEWHERE.
DURING THE REVIEW PROCESS DD
AUDITOR LEFT CRYING.
AND I.
I WHEN I SEE CONTENTIOUS VERY
CONTENTIOUS SADDAM.
SO NUMBER ONE I'M GLAD THAT CDC
ARE IS WILLING PARTICIPANT IN
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS RE IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT. FOR
THEM ARM FOR BOTH PARTIES TO
WORK TOGETHER TO GET THE ANSWERS.
MY COLLEAGUE AND I WILL BE ONE
OF THE MAIN REASONS WHAT WE'RE
DOING THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT MY
UNION SEIU IS TALKING ABOUT.
WHENEVER WE ASK WHENEVER PEOPLE
WHO DON'T BELIEVE IN THIS.
ASK ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS.
I'M WE SOMETIMES WE DON'T GET
NUMBERS WE DON'T TALK ABOUT A
RETURN ON INVESTMENT WE DON'T
GIVE THOSE.
I BELIEVE THIS AUDIT WILL NOT
ONLY HIGHLIGHT ON HIM SOME AREAS
WE CAN IMPROVE.
AND I DON'T USE THE WORD WRONG
OR PROBLEMS BUT AREAS WE CAN
IMPROVE.
BUT I ALSO THINK WILL HIGHLIGHT
UNBELIEVABLE SUCCESSES IN AREAS
THAT WE NEVER EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT.
LIKE I THINK YOU MENTIONED.
WAS THE ACTORS GANG I'M I DON'T
KNOW OF ROCK CLIMBING WORKS AND
IMPRISONS BUT WHAT IF IT DOES.
HOPEFULLY THIS AUDIT WAS SHED
SOME LIGHT ON THAT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY SHOW HOW WE CAN. WE
CAN DOCUMENT.
BOMB THEM. EFFECTIVENESS OF IT I
AM I ASKED ABOUT A JOB PROGRAM
WHEN SOMEONE GETS A JOB LEAD TO
TRADE AND THEN LEAVES I ASKED
WHETHER NOT THEY KEPT. ON THE
JOB FOR A LONG TIME AND MOST OF
THESE PROGRAMS SAY THEY DON'T
HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF GETTING
THAT DATA.
I DON'T THINK THEY.
THEY WORKED HARD ENOUGH TO GET
THAT DATA BECAUSE DETAILS SAFE
YOU IF YOU WOULD CALL.
.
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE A
TREASURE LAW OFFICERS IN THE
STATE AND GET THEIR THAT THEY
PAID STATE TAXES FOR THE LAST.
FIVE YEARS WELL GUESS WHAT I'M
PRETTY SURE GOING TO WORK NINE
TO FIVE EVERYDAY DONE LEGAL
WHOLE LOTTA ROOM ROOM FOR HIM TO
RECEIVE A. AND SO YOU HAVE A
SUCCESS STORY RIGHT THERE BUT
WE'RE NOT DOCUMENTED. AND AND I
LOOK AT THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW HOW NOT ONLY
HOW EFFECTIVE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
BUT I'M HOPING THAT ALSO SHOWED.
NADIA DEDICATED EMPLOYEES THAT
WORK ON THIS EVERY DAY. ON THAT
THAT THAT WOULD WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT AND AND FINALLY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THE AUDITOR KNOWS I WANTED. HER
TO LOOK AT AND UP WHO IF YOU
HIRE SOMEBODY FROM THE OUTSIDE
THAT THIS IS A UNIQUE SITUATION
A UNIQUE. PLACE TO WORK
WHERE YOU COULD HAVE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL REHABILITATION CALL
UP PROGRAM. AND SOMEONE.
MY DISTRICT PRISON GANG LEADER
OR SHOCK COLLAR MAY WANT TO BE
SHUT DOWN AND ALL OF A SUDDEN TO
FIGHT.
THERE'S PROBLEMS AND ALISON THE
NUMBERS WHO ARE DOING VERY WELL
GOAL DRAMATICALLY DOWN. BUT IT'S
NOT.
SHOULD NOT BE A REFLECTION ON
THE PROGRAM SHABBY REFLECTION ON
ON VIA THE DIRECTOR WHO'S DOING
IT SHOULD BE IN A BAD REFLECTION
ON CD IT SEE OUR AND WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DOCUMENT THAT. THESE
OUTSIDE INFLUENCE THAT WE WHO'VE
NEVER BEEN IN THANK GOD WOULD
NEVER BEEN IN THAT SITUATION. ON
BAKED A DAY EXPERIENCING
CHALLENGES THAT HOPEFULLY WE
NEVER WILL BE ABLE TO EXPERIENCE
AND THAT THEY INCORPORATE THAT.
IN THE AUDIT AND I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
THAT THE CI USE IS IS SAYING
THAT WE MAKE SURE ON THIS IS
ACCURATE AS POSSIBLE AND AGAIN.
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUE WILL
AGREE. I LOOK AT THIS IS A WAY
TO HIGHLIGHTED SUCCESSES NOT TO
BE DEPARTMENT UP.
AND AND AND AGAIN WHEN WE FINISH.
GET FINALLY GET THE ACCOLADES
THAT THEY NEVER GET.
AND AND I'LL JUST HAVE MYSELF IS
THAT IT IS OUR JOB AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT I MEAN
THAT IS A HUGE PART OF OUR ROLE
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING MONEY AND. HOW WE SPEND
A LOT OF MONEY?
?
FOR REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
AND THE IMPORTANCE AND I THINK
IT'S ONLY.
CORRECT OF THIS BODY TO TAKE
ACTION TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE
ARE SPENDING MONEY ON IS.
IS OPERATING IN THE WAY THAT WE
UNDER THE UNDER THE PRETENSE
THAT WE HAVE FUNDED THESE
PROGRAMS ARE AND AND THIS IS IN
NO WAY. ARMS WE ARE BOTH MYSELF
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE CONCERNS
OF SEIU BUT THIS IS IN NO WAY
MEANT TO BE.
TAKEN AS SOMETHING THAT'S.
.
CHALLENGING OR.
AGGRESSIVE AGGRESSIVE TOWARDS
THE DEPARTMENT IT'S MORE ABOUT
JUST WHAT WHAT. WHERE'S OUR
MONEY GOING.
YOU KNOW I I'VE HAD OPPORTUNITY
KNOCKED A LOT OF FOLKS AROUND
PUBLIC SAFETY FORMALLY
INCARCERATED THOSE ON THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE BECAUSE I LOST
AN OFFICER IN MY DISTRICT I
AUTHORED AB FORTUNE AWAIT THAT
DEALT WITH. A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES OF FLASH INCARCERATIONS
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I DID I WOULD
APPRECIATE SENATOR BELL'S
COMMENTS BECAUSE THEY ARE THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT.
I SPECIFICALLY HAVE DOWN AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
BUT I'M I I KNOW THAT THEIR
OUTSIDE GROUPS TO COME IN AND
PROVIDE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WHERE ALL YOU DO IS IF YOU'RE AN
INMATE YOU SIGNED INTO ON.
THERE'S NO REAL.
REQUIREMENT OR THERE'S THE
THERE'S THE OVERALL REQUIREMENT
THAT YOU STAY AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM HOWEVER THEY'RE
GETTING PAID FOR ANY EVERY
INMATE THAT SIGNS UP FOR THAT
PROGRAM.
WHETHER THEY ACTUALLY DO THE
PROGRAM OR NOT OR WHETHER THEY
ACTUALLY STAY IN IT OR NOT I AND
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT IF THAT'S
HAPPENING AND SO THAT'S WHAT THE
POINT OF THIS. AUDIT IS AND IT'S
NOT TO MEANT TO BE ADDED TO BE
AGGRESSIVE OR. OR AGAINST ANY
WAY THE DEPARTMENT AYE BUT WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT AUDIT AYE AND AND IT'S
JUST PROVIDING THE BASIC.
OVERSIGHT ROLE AYE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE.
.
ANSWER.
OVERDOSE.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT.
.
APPRECIATE THE THAT THE REQUEST
WE WE STILL DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AND SO
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PLEASE COME TO.
DO YOUR DUTY.
BUT.
.
I I.
HAD A CHANCE TO MEET WITH THE
SEIU.
LOOK ONE THOUSAND YESTERDAY AND.
.
AND WHILE I.
APPRECIATED THEIR THEIR CONCERNS
ALSO IN THE LABOR FEDERATION'S
CONCERNS ALSO.
.
I TOLD SEIU.
I RESPECT THE THE REQUESTER IS
HERE MAIN.
.
NOW NOT ONLY AS A AS A ADVOCATES
FOR.
PROPER OVERSIGHT FOR FOR.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
EFFECTIVE.
DATA BASED.
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS MAKE
SURE THAT WHERE WHERE AN
INVESTING OUR STATE DOLLARS AND
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS.
.
BUT ALSO THAT.
YOU.
ARE VERY RESPECTFUL OF THEIR
WORKERS RIGHTS DE LA WORKERS
ISSUES THAT MAY BE AFFECTED.
INCLUDING THAT MEMBERSHIP OF
SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND.
SO.
I FULLY SUPPORT YOUR AUDIT
REQUEST.
.
WE AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM
WHO WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND
A SECOND AND ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SCENE AND
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESIDENT GERMANY BICU
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT NEXT AYE SALSA REGAINS
LE.
A MAN IS CENTER AGAIN YES.
THIS IS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ON THE REGULAR
CALENDAR.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
ONE ZERO.
I REQUEST FOR THIS CITY OF
LINCOLN.
SUBMITTED BY SARAH GAINES AND
BEFORE I. TURN IT OVER.
.
AS A PROCEDURAL MATTER.
SOME LIMERICK COSTA DID YOU HAVE
A REQUEST FOR. REMOVING ANY
ITEMS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NOT AT THIS TIME.
ETCETERA.
SURE I THINK THE FOLKS FROM THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHICH I.
UNDERSTOOD TO BE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THAT'S NOT ITEMS THREE.
OKAY IT'S THE CIVIC SITTING
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO MY NUMBERS
ARE LINING UP BUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SO AT.
THE VICE CHAIRS REQUEST.
WE WILL BE REMOVING ITEM NUMBER
THREE TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
SIXTEEN.
THE ART A REQUEST BY SOMEONE
MARIE GLORIA FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND SO WE WILL HAVE.
IRREGULAR HEARING ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SARAH GAINS
RATE WONDER FULL THANK YOU.
CHAIR MURATSUCHI APPRECIATE IT
MEMBERS.
.
I'M HERE TO ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE APPROVE AN AUDIT.
OF THE CITY OF LINCOLN.
CONDUCT A COMPLETE AUDIT AND
REVIEW OF PUBLIC FUNDS AND
ASSETS
CONTROLLED BY THE CITY OF
LINCOLN INCLUDING THE CITY'S
ADMINISTRATION.
OF THOSE FUNDS AND ASSETS.
THE CITY OF LINCOLN'S FISCAL
YEAR BUDGET FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
WILL EXCEED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE CITY MAINTAINS A MINIMUM OF.
FORTY SEVEN SEPARATE FUNDS.
RECENTLY CITIZENS CHALLENGED
CITY BASED ON WATER RATES.
AND MADE SOME DISTURBING
FINDINGS.
LEADING TO A BROADER CONCERNS
OVER FAILURE TO COMPLY.
WITH REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
UNDER STATE LAW. AND A PATTERN
SHOWING POOR INTERNAL CONTROLS
AND FUND MANAGEMENT ABILITIES.
THIS PATTERN COULD POINT
TENCHI OFFER A HIGH RISK CITY.
WHICH SHOULD IT FAIL.
COULD REQUIRE THE STATE TO STEP
IN WITH FUNDS TO BOLSTER THE
CITY'S BUDGET.
IN LATE TWENTY SIXTEEN THE CITY
OF LINCOLN WAS* CLOSER.
FINANCIAL RECORDS REGARDING
THEIR WATER SYSTEMS.
RECORDS THEY CLAIM TO HAVE
UTILIZED
TO IMPOSE NEW WATER RATES UPON
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS.
THE FINANCIALS PER DAY PRODUCED
FAILED TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
IMPOSED BY PROP TWO EIGHTEEN.
THERE IS NO CORRELATION BETWEEN
RATES AND COSTS.
ATTEMPTS BY TAXPAYERS TO COME.
TWO ACCOMMODATION WITH THE CITY
FOLLOWED.
ULTIMATELY THE TAXPAYERS FOR
FORCE TO FILE SUIT THE CITY IN A
MEDIATED SETTLEMENT AGREED TO
REFUND.
RATE FEES BACK TO THE
RESIDENTIAL TAXPAYERS.
FOLLOWING THEIR SUCCESS WITH
RESIDENTIAL RATES THE SAME
CITIZEN GROUP PASSED THE CITY.
WHAT THEY WERE INTENDED DO ABOUT
COMMERCIAL RATES WHICH HAD NOT
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE ORIGINAL
AWARD?
THE CITY MANAGER IS NOT INCLINED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE A LINK TO
COMMERCIAL RATE PAYERS.
THE ISSUE WAS BROUGHT TO THE
CITY COUNCIL.
IN MARCH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CITY COUNCIL RECONSIDER THE
CITY'S ACTIONS AFTER RECEIVING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION REGARDING
THE POTENTIAL CITY LIABILITY.
THE CITY COUNCIL OVERTURNED THE
CITY MANAGER'S POSITION.
AND VOTED AN ADDITIONAL THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN REFUNDS
DATING BACK TO JANUARY TWENTY
FOURTEEN.
TOTAL REFUNDS CURRENTLY DO
TAXPAYERS NOW STAND AT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
IT IS ANTICIPATED THAT WITH
FURTHER EXAMINATION SUPPLE MORE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN REFUNDS
MAYBE DO RATE PAYERS THROUGH
OTHER FUNDS.
IN THE MEANTIME LIKE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
THE RATE PAYER GROUP STUMBLED.
ONTO THE FACT THAT THE CITY WAS
USING WATER FOR FREE.
APPROXIMATELY. AT THE RATE OF A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
THROUGH HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
CITY OWN METERS.
IT HAS BEEN SUGGESTED. THAT
SENIOR STAFF AND SOME CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS HAD KNOWN ABOUT
THIS WATER ASSET JUGGLING. FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME.
THE CITY HAD ALSO GONE SO FAR AS
TO CALL SUPPLY REPORTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO COVER UP THEIR
PRESUMED ILLEGAL USAGES.
WHILE IN DISCOVERY CITIZENS
DISCOVERED A PARENT MIS USES OF
PUBLIC FUNDS
FOR INSTANCE THE CITY ISSUE
LOANS FOR REHABILITATION AND
REDEVELOPMENT AREAS. WHICH ARE
NEVER REPAID.
FOLLOWING THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES.
THE CITY PAID THEY SUCCESSOR
FUNDS DEBT WITH MONIES
FROM THE PLASTER COUNTY WATER
AGENCY WHEN THERE WAS NO NEXUS
BETWEEN WATER AND REHABILITATION.
THESE PAYMENTS
THAT WERE NOT DISCLOSED UNTIL
FIVE YEARS LATER WHEN I REVISED
REPORT WAS MADE TO THE STATE.
I'M MORE DISTURBING EVENT
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN WHEN THE
CITY.
CHARGED OFF ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN DEVELOPER FEES A
CIRCUMSTANCE ARISING WHEN
DEVELOPERS DO NOT BUILD THEIR
INTENDED PROJECT.
THOUGH IN THIS CASE THE
DEVELOPERS WERE ALLOWED TO
PROCEED WITH THEIR PROJECTS THIS
ACTION APPEARS TO BE A GIFT OF
PUBLIC FUNDS.
THESE FACTS SHOW OF POTENTIAL
PATTERN OF MISMANAGEMENT AMONGST.
SOME OF THE UPPER ECHELONS OF
CITY GOVERNMENT IN LINCOLN.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN IMPORTANT
LEADERSHIP ROLE TO ENSURE THAT
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
RESPECTED AND RELIABLE STEWARDS
OF THE PUBLIC TRUST AND ASSETS.
BY CONDUCTING THIS AUDIT SEVERAL
QUESTIONS
CAN'T BE ANSWERED WITH REGARD TO
THIS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
STEWARDSHIP.
OF THEIR FUNCTIONS.
FINANCES
ARE.
SO.
.
AT THIS POINT.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO REQUEST.
THAT JAY LACKEY AND THE STATE
AUDITOR.
ENGAGE IN AN AUDIT REVIEW OF
THE MOST RECENT FIVE FISCAL
YEARS THE CITY OF LINCOLN.
AND.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE.
SOME.
WITNESSES.
DOTTED DOT HODGKIN AND TED JONES.
OKAY WITH WHATEVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE REGAINS
UP BEFORE WE PROCEED THERE WHERE
RICH TRYING TO JUGGLE A.
MULTIPLE THE COMMITTEE SCHEDULES
HERE TODAY I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND SO I'D LIKE TO. ASK A
MADAM SECTOR FOR ROLL CALL.
DO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
CG HERE ACOSTA. HERE ACOSTA HERE
BAKER.
HERE WITH VARYING.
OBERNOLTE HERE.
OBERNOLTE HERE RUBIO.
WAIT FOR.
SENATOR ROTH HERE.
LARA HERE ALLEN.
BELL.
HERE CANNELLA.
FULLER.
NATURALLY. LARA.
HER HERE AND ALLEN'S ALSO HERE.
ASSEMBLY THERE WOULD IS ALSO
HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH IS HERE.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A QUORUM I
I'D LIKE TO.
AT THIS TIME TAKE UP OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MAR ACOSTA.
A YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE CITY OF
ATWATER THERE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THEIR CITY MANAGERS
HERE AND WOULD LIKE TO YOU KNOW
MAKE SOME COMMENTS I THINK IT'S
RESPECTFUL THAT SINCE THEY COME
OUT CAME UP WE SHOULD ALL LIVE
UNDER HER TO LIKE TO. PULL ITEM
NUMBER SIX ALRIGHT I THINK I
AGREE AND SO THAT SOMEONE A
RECALLS HIS REQUEST. WE ARE
PULLING ITEM NUMBER SIX FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT LEAVES
ITEMS ONE.
A TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
TWELVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN'S.
I REQUEST FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
ITEM NUMBER TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DEATHS ONE FOURTEEN DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES.
AND DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS AUDIT REQUESTS BY
SENATOR NEWMAN.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR I'D AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE EIGHTEEN.
ITEM.
AUDIT REQUEST BY SIMPLY MEMBERS
LACKEY AND AND SENATOR WELK. OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
THE HIGH RISK AUDIT.
REQUEST BY THE STATE AUDITOR
FOR ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DASH EIGHT ZERO THREE FOR THE
CITY OF LONDON WHAT. THOSE FOUR
ITEMS ARE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CAN I GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE MISTER AND MISTER I'LL
I'LL MOVE.
BUT ALSO JUST WANNA JUST NOTE
AS THE CITY OF LYNNWOOD IS ALSO.
UNDER. CONSIDERATION FOR THE
CONSENT JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT THE CITY IS
WORKING WITH THE AUDITOR THEY
WELCOME THE AUDIT AND FEEL THAT
THIS CAN. LEAD TO A BETTER
MANAGEMENT PRACTICE IN THE CITY
SO JUST WENT UP PUT THAT OUT
THERE THAT. ARE LOOKING FOR
WORKING WITH THE OTTER DURING
THE PROCESS THANK YOU AND I'M
AND MAKE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
COUNT YET. MOTIONS MADE BY
CENTER LARA SECONDED BY MISTER
CLOSE TO.
AND ANY.
MADAM SECRETARY SCHOOL.
MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI WHERE SUCI AYE ACOSTA
AYE AYE ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I IS ARYAN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I RUBIO.
WAY.
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
BELL.
BELL AYE CANNELLA.
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
I.
I RATES.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS.
ARE OUT AND MOVED MOVED TO
PROVE THE PENNY NOT.
MUCH IS MADE.
SECOND BY.
MOTION BY MS BAKER SECOND BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR PATIENTS
OUR GAINES HERE WITNESSES.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
I HAVE OVER THIRTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE AS A BANK EXECUTIVE
IN GOVERNMENT FINANCE.
MIKE.
AND THE MODEL MIGHT.
MY NAME IS DONNA HIDE SAN AND I
AM A RESIDENT OF LINK IN
CALIFORNIA.
PAVE OVER THIRTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE AS A BANKING
EXECUTIVE IN GOVERNMENT FINANCE
CASH MANAGEMENT AND INVESTMENTS.
FOR STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
HAVE ALSO SERVEDAS CHAIR FOR
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
I AM TERMED AN EXPERT WITNESS.
I WAS APPOINTED BY THE
BANKRUPTCY TRUSTEE HAS THE
BANKER FOR THAT ORANGE COUNTY
BANKRUPTCY. AND THEN CONTINUED
TO BANK ORANGE COUNTY POST
BANKRUPTCY UNTIL I RETIRED.
MY ASSESSMENT OF THE ACTIONS
THAT THE CITY OF LINCOLN HAS
TAKEN OR NOT TAKEN.
COULD LEAD THEM DOWN THAT SAME
PATH AS ORANGE COUNTY.
ALTHOUGH ALMOST SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS BEING RETURNED TO
RATE PAYERS FOR PROP TWO
EIGHTEEN WATER RATE DILATION.
THERE'S ADDITIONAL VIOLATIONS
DISCOVERED OVER SIX MONTHS AGO.
WHERE WE HAVE YET TO HAVE HERE
FROM THE CITY WIN THEY WILL
RETURN RATEPAYERS MONIES?
THE CITY'S LACK OF ACTION ON
COLLECTION OF DEBTS FROM LOANS
AND LEASES ALONG WITH CHARGING
OFF DEVELOPER FEES HAS COST THE
CITY OVER FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYERS' MONEY.
OVER THE YEARS.
THIS CERTAINLY COULD BE TERMED
AS ON AUTHORIZED PUBLIC GIFT OF
FUNDS.
GOVERNMENT CODES IS VERY
SPECIFIC ON TIMBER A SHORT TERM
BORROWINGS WHICH INCLUDE ENOUGH
INTER FUND BORROWINGS.
A PURPOSE FOR THESE TYPES OF
BAHRAIN'S IS FOR THE ANTICIPATED
INCOME WITHIN THAT FISCAL YEAR.
IT IS NOT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FINANCING TEN YEAR LONG TERM
DEBTS.
THE CITY CURRENTLY HAS NINETEEN
INTER FUND BAYERN'S DATING BACK
TO TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
FOURTEEN YEARS.
ALMOST EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
PLUS LOSS OF INCOME FROM
INVESTMENTS.
AND SUBSIDIZING OTHER FUNDS.
INDEPENDENT AUDITORS VALIDATE
THERE'S NO MATERIAL
MISSTATEMENTS.
ONLY THE STATE AUDITOR CAN
IDENTIFY ANY MISAPPROPRIATION OF
FUNDS WERE MISMANAGEMENT OF
FUNDS FROM THE GOVERNMENT CODE
OR CONSTITUTIONS PERSPECTIVE.
TO DATE
ELEVEN MONTHS AFTER FISCAL YEAR
IN CLOSE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE CITY STILL HAS NOT.
PROVED IN RELEASED THEY'RE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT.
CATHERINE.
IF THE FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS PUBLISHED FINANCIALS
WITHIN NINETY DAYS OF THEIR YEAR
END. ELEVEN MONTHS SHOULD BE
VERY ALARMING TO ALL OF YOU.
MA'AM I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
TREASURER UP WE THE CITIZENS
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE THE ONES TO
TELL THE CITY. THAT THEY'VE OVER
CHARGES FOR SERVICES OR TELL
THEM TO USE GOVERNMENT FINANCE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION BEST
PRODUCT PRACTICES.
YET THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED.
I THINK YOU THE AUDIT IS
NECESSARY
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
TED JONES I'M A RESIDENT OF
LINCOLN.
I'M ONE OF THE NINE CITIZENS
THAT.
CAME TOGETHER.
.
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
AND.
.
ASK THE CITY IF THEY COULD
REDUCE HER HIGH WATER RATES.
WHAT BEGAN AS A REQUEST AND
BECAME A YEAR LONG BATTLE WHERE
WE? CHALLENGED ARE CITY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. RELUCTANTLY
THEY FINALLY AGREED TO RETURN
OVER SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROP TWO EIGHTEEN OVER CHARGES.
DURING THIS TIME WE UNCOVERED
THAT THE CITY WAS HIDING THEIR
OWN WATER USAGE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN INDIVIDUAL METERS
IN DOZENS OF LIGHTING AND
LANDSCAPING DISTRICTS.
IN ALL THE CITY PARKS AND AND
ALL THE CITY FACILITIES.
CLAIMING WATER LOSS.
THIS RESULTED.
.
IN AN INTERNAL INVESTIGATION
CALLED THE MYERS NAY REPORT.
WHICH CONCLUSIVELY SHOWED THAT
MUCH OF THE SO CALLED WATER LOSS
WAS IN FACT CITY USAGE. AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE RATEPAYERS IN
TERMS OF HIGHER RATES.
THE CITY'S OWN WORDS THE
LIGHTING AND LANDSCAPING
DISTRICTS ALONG WITH THE GENERAL
FUND COULD NOT SUPPORT PAYING
THEIR OWN WAY.
OUR QUESTION IS.
WHAT ABOUT ALL THE RATE PAYERS
ON FIXED INCOMES?
ALL THE LIGHTING AND LANDSCAPING
DISTRICTS ARE IN TOTAL DISARRAY.
AND SHOW SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
COMPLIANCE AND ALLOCATION ISSUES.
THERE ARE EIGHT OTHER
ENTERPRISES FUNDS WHICH WE
BELIEVE CLEARLY SHOW.
OVER COLLECTION AND ADDITIONAL
REFUNDS DO WHICH COULD TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS WITHOUT
EXCEPTION.
EVERYWHERE WE LOOK WE FIND
SIGNIFICANT AND SHOES AND A
HIGHLY QUESTIONABLE PRACTICES
WHICH ARE ALWAYS MET WITH THE
SAME STRATEGY.
OF DENIAL AND PUSH BACK THIS IS
WHY WE TURNED TO OUR SENATOR FOR
HELP.
IN CLOSING.
OUR CITY SHOULD WELCOME AN AUDIT.
IF IT IS IN FACT PROPERLY
MANAGING ITS FINANCES.
AND LIVING IN APPLYING THE
CONSTITUTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
STATE ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE.
AS AS CENTER GAINES INDICATED
THIS WOULD BE AN AUDIT OF THE
CITY LIKE AND WE WOULD START
LOOKING AT THEIR GOVERNANCE AND
AN OPERATIONAL STRUCTURE BUT
PRIMARILY REALLY LOOKING AT
THEIR FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITIES
AND HOW THEY ARE CARRYING OUT
THEIR FIDUCIARY DUTIES. ARE HE'S
ASKED US AS HE INDICATED TO LOOK
AT FIVE FISCAL YEARS ARE WORTH
OF FINANCIAL STATEMENTS LOOKING
AT INTERNAL CONTROLS ANY
DEFICIENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THOSE AUDITS.
DETERMINE WHAT ACTIONS OF
CITYLINK AND HAS TAKEN TO
CORRECT THOSE DEFICIENCIES BUT
AS THE WITNESSES INDICATED ALSO
LOOKING AT THE USE OF PUBLIC
FUNDS LOOKING AT ENTER ENTER
FUND LOANS. LOOKING AT ANY MONEY
TRANSFERS COLLATERAL STATION OF
CERTAIN PUBLIC MONIES.
ALSO LOOKING AT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE FOLLOWING REQUIRED LAWS
AND REGULATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
REPORTING INCOME SPENDING ASSETS
ABOUT THE.
USAGE ARE OF BOTH WATER SEWAGE
THE NUMBER OF CONNECTIONS RATE.
RATE RATES ARE ACQUISITIONS AT
CETERA ALSO ASSESSING THEIR
COLLECTION AND REPORTING PROCESS
IS FOR FEES NOT ONLY FOR
RESIDENTIAL BUT AS A SENATOR
INDICATED THE COMMERCIAL FEES AS
WELL. AND THEN FINALLY LOOKING
AT.
FIVE YEARS WORTH OF OF WATER
RATES AND DETERMINING WHETHER OR
NOT LINK AND REALLY HAS BEEN
CHARGING IN EXCESS OF WHAT THEIR
ACTUAL COSTS ARE.
FOR THE WATER RATES.
OBVIOUSLY DID THE CITIZENS
PROVES CERTAIN INFORMATION BUT
WILL BE LOOKING AT A FIVE YEAR
WINDOW AND THEN LOOKING AT THE
USE OF REDEVELOPMENT MONIES AND
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE READ.
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS WERE USED IN
DISTRIBUTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
OUR STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS ANY
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND THEN
FINALLY LOOKING AT WHAT THE CITY
OF LINCOLN IS DOING IS TO
COMMUNICATE TO. THE CITIZENS OF
LATE OF THE CITY OF LINCOLN.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
CHANGING RATES HOW ARE THEY
MAKING THOSE DETERMINATIONS WHAT
FACTORS INTO THEIR THEIR
DECISION TO EITHER.
INCREASE RATES LEAVE RATES AT
THE SAME LEVEL OF THE AUDIT IS
BUDGETED ABOUT TWO TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED HOURS RELATIVELY SMALL
AND AUDIT OF THAT SIZE WILL TAKE
US ABOUT FIVE. FIGHT BETWEEN
FIVE
IN SIX MONTHS TO COMPLETE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU.
I LIKE TO INVITE.
RIMS CENTER FOR THE CITY
LINCOLN IF ANYONE IS PRESENT
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I CAN ASK YOUR SUPPORTING
WITNESSES TO.
PROVIDE THE SEEDS.
THANK YOU
.
THAT ORDER IS NOT IN TWO MINUTES
EACH PLEASE. THANK HER BOY.
WHEN WE GO FOR A FULL FIVE.
SO SO IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY
IS FIVE MINUTES OF ONE OF A
SPEAKS.
IF WE DIVIDE ACTUALLY IT'S IS
TWO MINUTES A DAY BAG I I SHOULD
HAVE ASKED LAID OUT TO BUT
NORMALLY OUR GROUND RULES TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR EACH HAVE A
WITNESS DOWN.
WE WE DID GIVE US SOME.
EXTRA TIME FOR.
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
I REQUEST AND SO.
FIVE MINUTES TOGETHER FOR THE
TWO OF YOU ARE TRYING TO MOVE
THROUGH THIS VERY QUICKLY THANK
YOU MISTER SCHECK WHICH EIGHT
THAT. ARE GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
SENATOR GAINES AND STAB MY
NAME'S PAUL JOINER I AM A.
.
WE CAN CITY COUNCIL MEMBER I'VE
BEEN ON THE COUNCIL FOR TEN
YEARS TO THOSE YEARS AS MAYOR.
I'M JUST GOING TO JUMP TO THE
MIDDLE MATTERS TIME AS IS OF THE
ESSENCE. ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR GAINES CONCERNS.
HIS REQUEST IS PRIMARILY BASED
ON THE BELIEF THAT THERE'S A
POTENTIAL FOR THE CITY OF
LINCOLN TO BECOME IDENTIFIED AS
HIGH RISK CITY AND THEREFORE. BE
AT RISK OF BECOMING A BURDEN TO
THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
WEBSITE HIGH RISK CITIES USUALLY
EXHIBIT.
PACIFIC FINANCIAL INDICATORS
SUCH AS THE INABILITY TO PAY
SHORT TERM OBLIGATIONS LACK OF
CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO FINANCIAL
EMERGENCIES. POOR REVENUE GROWTH
A LACK OF ABILITY TO PAY RETIREE
OBLIGATIONS AND A POOR FISCAL
OUTLOOK OF THESE FIVE INDICATORS
THE CITY OF LINCOLN DOES NOT
ACCEPT IT A SINGLE ONE.
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ANNUAL
BUDGET INCLUDED TOTAL
EXPENDITURES OF ALMOST NINETY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
CITY'S CASH INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO
IS OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE CITY HAS
AMPLE ABILITY TO PAY ALL SHORT
TERM OBLIGATIONS.
THE CITY OF SEVERAL RESERVES IN
PLACE TO ALLOW FOR IT TO RESPOND
TO FINANCIAL EMERGENCY SHOULD
THEY ARISE.
OPERATING RESERVE EQUAL TO
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF GENERAL
FUND OUTFLOWS FULLY FUNDED THIS
FISCAL YEAR AND WILL BE FULLY
FUNDED IN FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AT OVER FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
CATASTROPHIC RESERVE SENATE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THE RESERVE IS
FULLY FUNDED ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
RESERVE FULLY FUNDED THIS FISCAL
YEAR AND WILL BE FULLY FUNDED IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AT A LITTLE
OVER TWO POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. CAPITAL RESERVE
REPLACEMENT FULLY FUNDED THIS
CURRENT YEAR AND WILL ALSO BE
FULLY FUNDED IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. OTHER POST EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS HELP HAVE RESERVE.
FULLY FUNDED THIS FISCAL YEAR
AND WILL BE FULLY FUNDED AS
INTENDED IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
EACH OF THE CITIES THREE MAJOR
ENTERPRISE FUNDS WATER SEWER AND
SOLID WASTE ALSO HAS SEPARATE
RESERVES FOR OPERATIONS IN
CAPITAL REPLACEMENT. THESE
RESERVES DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
CITY IS IN A GREAT POSITION TO
WITHSTAND A FINANCIAL EMERGENCY.
ANOTHER ONE OF THE FISCAL
INDICATORS IS WHETHER THE CITY
HAS AN ADEQUATE PROJECTED
REVENUE. GROWTH RATE THE CITY
CURRENTLY PROJECTS THE GENERAL
FUND FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WILL
INCREASE BY THREE POINT THREE
PERCENT.
NOW AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE NEARLY
ALL LOCAL AGENCIES IN THE STATE
ARE EXPERIENCING CHALLENGES
RELATED TO FUTURE RETIREE
OBLIGATIONS.
THE CITY CURRENTLY FULLY FUNDS.
THE CALPERS NORMAL COST WHICH IS
THE ANNUAL COST OF SERVICE OF
CRUEL. FOR THE UP FISCAL YEAR
THE CITY PAYS IT'S REQUIRED
ANNUAL PAYMENT FOR THE UNFUNDED
ACCRUED LIABILITY AT THE
BEGINNING THE FISCAL YEAR AND
THE CITY ALSO PAYS INTO THE OPEC
TRUSTS. TO ENSURE PAYMENT TO
FUTURE RETIREE HEALTH CARE
OBLIGATIONS THE OPEC TRUST
BALANCE AT THE END OF MARCH WAS
OVER THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS. AS SUCH THIS
DEMONSTRATES THE CITY IS ABLE TO
PAY ITS RETIREE OBLIGATIONS.
THE FINAL FINANCIAL INDICATOR IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE CITY HAS
SOUND FINANCIAL OUTLOOK.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT'S BEEN
DEMONSTRATED BY THE INFORMATION
I'VE ALREADY PROVIDED. IN THE
CITY. HAS THE ABILITY.
TO MEET OUR TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR MONTHLY
INVESTMENT GOAL.
FURTHER THE CITY HAS A NUMBER OF
CHECKS AND BALANCES IN PLACE TO
MONITOR THIS IS THE CITY'S
FISCAL OUTLOOK. NOT ONLY IS THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS VERY
TRANSPARENT.
AND PROVIDES FOR A NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE THE CITY ALSO HAS A
FISCAL INVESTMENT IN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE THAT IS COMPOSED OF
TWO CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS THE
ELECTED CITY TREASURER. TO STAFF
MEMBERS AND TO CITIZENS AT LARGE.
BASED ON THIS FACT.
BASED ON THE FACT THAT I'VE GONE
OVER.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT CITY
OF LINCOLN IS AT RISK OF
BECOMING AN AT RISK CITY.
NOW OTHER ISSUES THE SENATOR
GAMES.
.
REQUEST POINTS TO.
OUR CHALLENGES CITY IS ALREADY
TAKING CORRECTIVE ACTIONS TO
RESOLVE.
LIKE NUMBER CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THE CITY DID HAVE A LEGAL ISSUE
RELATED TO TIERED WATER RATES
STRUCTURE. TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THE CITY COUNCIL DIRECTED THE
ISSUANCE OF REFUNDS TO CUSTOMERS.
LIKE MANY OTHER CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE CITY WAS
HISTORICALLY NOT PAYING FOR MEN
IS MUNICIPAL UTILITIES THIS
ISSUE WAS RESOLVED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS FISCAL YEAR.
THE CITY EVEN WENT FURTHER AND
AUTHORIZED A FACT FINDING
INVESTIGATION. WHICH THE OTHER
WITNESSES SPOKE TO A ON THIS
ISSUE RESULTING IN A REPORT THAT
WAS RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
CAPPER REPORT THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT SUPPOSEDLY HAD NOT
COME FORWARD WAS APPROVED AT OUR
LAST COUNCIL MEETING.
SO AS I'VE DEMONSTRATED THE
CITY OF LINCOLN IS NOT ONLY
FISCALLY STABLE BUT ALSO TAKES
THE APPROPRIATE CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS.
WHEN AN ISSUE ARISES.
ALTHOUGH AN AUDIT CAN BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO IDENTIFY ISSUES
THE CITY OF LINCOLN SIMPLY DOES
NOT HAVE THE STAFF RESOURCES.
SUPPORT AND AUDIT OF THE TYPE
THAT SENATOR GAINES IS
REQUESTING DOING SO WOULD
PREVENT STAFF WORKING ON MUCH.
NEEDED PROJECTS THAT WILL
FOR TAXPAYERS.
AS SUCH.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ANY
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE CITY'S
FINANCIAL STABILITY REVIEW THE
FACTS PROVIDED IN OUR RESPONSE
LETTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SO THAT WAS A TOTAL SO I BELIEVE
YOU OF. THE GIVEN YOUR TIME TO
YOUR COLLEAGUE ON THE COUNCIL.
WE HAVE ANY REMAINING MISTER
CHAIRMAN I ACTUALLY IT WAS
PRETTY ALMOST PRECISELY FIVE
MINUTES IF YOU HAVE A FEW WORDS
TO JUST A FEW COMMENTS OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ALL I
TO HAVE.
SERVED AS MAYOR TWICE.
IN MY THIRTIES IN THE CITY OF
FOSTER CITY AND UP RECENTLY IN
THE CITY OF LINCOLN. AND I HAVE
TEN YEARS.
ON CITY COUNCILS AND THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AS A PUBLIC.
SERVE IT. AS A VOLUNTEER OR
APPOINTED OFFICIAL.
ARE NOT ONLY DO ENDORSE
EVERYTHING THAT MY COLLEAGUE
INDICATED.
BUT I.
I POSSESS A FORTY FIVE YEAR
FINANCIAL BACKGROUND IN SILICON
VALLEY WITH START UP COMPANIES.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS LINCOLN.
WITH A HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN RESERVE.
WITH A STATE LAW THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO BORROW FROM ONE.
I COVER IN ANOTHER.
ALWAYS GIVING THE INTENT AS TO
WHEN AND HOW YOU'LL PAY IT BACK.
I'D LOVE TO SEE.
THIS CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED
CITIES OF CALIFORNIA MATCH US UP
IN TERMS OF FINANCIAL STABILITY
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
NO SYSTEM MADE BY MS BAKER
SECONDED BY MONTHS SIR OBERNOLTE
THIRD BY MISTRESS CENTER ROTH.
.
A QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
YES ADEQUATE ARE LOWER UP THE
SCORES FOR THE AUDITOR I KNOW
THE OPPONENTS TALKED ABOUT THE
HIGH RISK AUDIT PROGRAM. AND
HIGHLIGHTED THE QUALIFICATIONS
THAT YOU HAVE TO MEET IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO FALL UNDER THAT.
BUT GIVEN THAT THIS AUDIT IS
BEING BROUGHT UP INDEPENDENTLY.
BOB NOT FROM YOUR OFFICE BUT
FROM THE AUTHOR THEREFORE IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO MEET THOSE
THRESHOLDS CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT.
OKAY PERFECT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I.
ALSO APPRECIATE TO SARAH
LAWRENCE A QUESTION BECAUSE THEY
AYE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
AND THE MAYOR AND THE COUNCIL
MEMBER OF. THE CITY OF LINCOLN
AND APPRECIATES THAT THIS IS NOT
A REQUEST UNDER THE AUDITOR'S.
A HIGH RISK AUDIT PROGRAM.
SO WHILE THERE WAS A REFERENCE
INSERTED REGAINS IS
REQUEST LETTER FOR THE POTENTIAL
FOR A HIGH RISK CITY.
.
THE NATURE OF THE REQUEST IS
FOCUSING ON ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT START DANCES
WELL AS A SUPPORTED WITNESSES
OCCLUDING ISSUES RELATED TO BE
THE WATER RATES AND AND AND AND
DID DISPUTES AND SO.
I'M SURE.
THE.
.
THE FACTS OF THE U. PRESENTED IN
TERMS OF YOUR RESERVES IN YOUR
YOUR.
FISCAL MANAGEMENT OVERALL THE
CITY THAT MAY NOT BE AN ISSUE OF
THE AUDIT SAID THE THE ISSUES
ARE AS.
NOT SPECIFIED IN CENTER AGAINST
THIS REQUEST.
.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WOULD
WITH ANY AUDIT REQUESTS
ESPECIALLY ON SMALLER CITIES
WITH.
THE GOOD OF THE DAY.
THE BURDEN AND THE DISRUPTION TO
NORMAL CITY OPERATIONS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT.
DEAR YOU DO NEED TO.
ADDRESS WITH YOUR SENATOR.
BUT.
AYE I THINK THE MOTION'S BEEN
MADE AND SECONDED THIRD IT.
.
AND.
WE.
I RESPECT THAT.
ARE THERE ANY. PUBLIC COMMENTS
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM.
FOR THE I REQUEST FROM REGARDING
THE CITY OF LINCOLN.
SEEING NONE.
SARAH GAINES WAS LIKE CLOSER
THANK YOU CARE WE'RE SUCI.
.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT A TO MY
COUNCIL MEMBERS IN THE CITY OF
LINCOLN.
THERE'VE BEEN ISSUES.
THAT HAVE ARISEN THAT FOR WHICH
CITIZENS OF THE CITY HAD TO COME
FORWARD.
AND.
WORK VERY HARD AND I WOULD SAY
EVEN BATTLE WITH THE CITY.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT REFUNDS
FOR MADE ON THE WATER ISSUE AND
THAT WAS JUST ON THE RESIDENTIAL
SIDE SO. OTHERS ISSUES ON THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE THERE'S ISSUES
WITH REDEVELOPMENT. THERE'S
ISSUES WITH SPECIAL FUNDS.
THAT IN MY VIEW WARRANT.
AND AUDIT AND IF THERE'S NOTHING
TO BE FOUND.
THAT'S GREAT AND.
YOU'VE GOTTA CLEAN BILL HEALTH
AND YOU CAN MOVE FORWARD BUT. I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT CLARITY
PROVIDED FOR THE CITIZENS SO
THEY CAN HAVE COMPLIMENTS THAT.
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS IS
RUNNING IN THE RIGHT FASHION AND
THEY CAN HAVE A FAITH AND TRUST.
IN THE SERVICES THEY'RE
PROVIDING.
SO I WOULD HAVE.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ATTACK YOU
MUCH ABOUT OF SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT WAS CLIENTS.
MOTION TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ONE LINES
HEN CITY OF LINCOLN
ADMINISTRATION OF PUBLIC FINANCE.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS AN
AYE VOTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. WHERE CITY I ACOSTA?
ACOSTA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE IS
ARYAN. NAZARIAN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO. WOULD.
SENATOR ROTH.
CENTER ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BELL.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
ALRIGHT THIS.
.
REQUEST IS ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR CAN MAKE YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
NEXT I BELIEVE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL LARA.
HE'S IN THE HALLWAY
.
OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE DO NOT HAVE
SENATOR LARA.
SO WE ARE AWAITING.
.
REQUEST YEARS.
OF AUDITS.
TO PLEASE COME TO THE HEARING
ROOM
.
CLICK GALLAGHER WHICH UNLIKELY.
NONE OF THEM NOW.
YEAH.
YEAH ACTUALLY ALRIGHT WHEN WE.
WE.
WHILE OR WAITING CA FOR REQUEST
YEARS TO COME BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE WE CAN TAKE A VOTE ON.
.
ITEM NUMBER NINE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ARE A REQUEST BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JONES SAWYER.
AND CALDERON.
KEN I ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
FOR.
MUCH HAS BEEN AND IT MADE BY
MISTER NAZARIAN IS OUR SECOND.
I'LL SECOND IT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TASH ONE ONE THREE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION
ADMINISTRATION OF THE IMPRISONED
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI WHERE
SU CHI AYE ACOSTA ACOSTA AYE
BAKER.
NOW THEREIN. THEREIN AYE
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO.
WOULD.
SENATOR RAW.
ALLEN.
BELL.
CANNELLA.
FULLER.
FULL NOT FULLER IS NOT VOTING.
LARA.
ALRIGHT THAT ITEM IS ON CALL
ALSO.
SEEING THAT WE DO NOT I SEE
SARAH LARA COMING.
SIR LARA WE.
BUSY DAY.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ON
THE REGULAR CALENDAR ITEM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE ONE SEVEN. A
REQUEST BY SARAH LAWYER A LARA.
TO.
OUT IT'S A CITY IN COUNTY JAILS.
ARE RELATED TO CONTRACTS WITH
THE UNITED STATES IMMIGRATION
AND CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT.
WELCOME SEVERAL ARE THANK YOU.
THINK IT WAS CHAIR MEMBERS IN
REQUESTING THE AUDITOR EXAMINED
CITY IN COUNTY JAILS A CONTRACT
WITH ICE TO DETAIN IMMIGRANTS
REFUGEES. UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
ON ASYLUM SEEKERS HELD IN CIVIL
IMMIGRATION CUSTODY RELATED TO
THEIR IMMIGRATION CASE.
THE BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS HAS OVERSIGHT
PURVIEW OF CITY AND COUNTY JAILS
AS YOU ON NO. BUT DOES NOT
MONITOR ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION DETENTION IN JAIL
THAT DOES NOT TRACK WHICH JAILS.
DETAIN IMMIGRANTS TYPE.
TYPES OF LENGTH AND CONTRACTS
REVENUES RECEIVED THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE DETAINED LENGTH OF
DETENTION DEMOGRAPHICS OF.
PERSONS DETAINED ARE OR THE
OUTCOMES OF THE DETENTION
INCLUDING DEPORTATIONS OR DEATHS
AMONG OTHER VALUABLE DATA.
NEARLY A DOZEN CITY IN COUNTY
JAILS ACROSS THE CITY ACROSS THE
STATE I'M SORRY CONTRACT
CONTRACT WITH ICE. TO DETAIN
IMMIGRANTS AND CIVIL IMMIGRATION
CUSTODY AND THE LEGISLATURE
KNOWS ALMOST NOTHING ABOUT THESE
ACTIVITIES THE IMMIGRATION
DETENTION SYSTEM IS A CLOSED
SYSTEM THAT LACKS TRANSPARENCY
OVERSIGHT. AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE TO
OUR POLICY AND BUDGET COMMITTEES
HAS HOW TO FISH FOR INFORMATION
COUNTY BY COUNTY CITY BY CITY.
AND OR RESORT TO WORK WITH
ADVOCATES TO OBTAIN DOCUMENTS
AND DATA SECURE TO THE FREEDOM
OF INFORMATION ACT REQUESTS. TO
GET PIECEMEAL INFORMATION ABOUT
ACTIVITIES IN OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
FACILITIES.
WHILE CONTRACTS OFTEN INCLUDE
PAYMENTS OR GRANTS TO THE CITY
OR COUNTY IN EXCHANGE FOR BADS
OR DETENTION SERVICES IT IS
UNCLEAR IF THE PAYMENT TO THE
COVERS. THE LOCAL COST OF HOW
MUCH IF AT ALL THE STATE IS
SUBSIDIZING THESE CONTRACTS WE
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE DETAILS
THAT CAN HELP PIECE TOGETHER THE
BIG PICTURE. OF THIS PRACTICE
HALL OF THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
KNOW HOW FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THIS
PRACTICE IS BEING UTILIZED OR
MANAGED SO AS TO INFORM THE
STATE PARK. OUR STATE POLICY AND
BUDGET DECISIONS.
THE AUDIT WILL IDENTIFY AND
EVALUATE THE FISCAL IMPACT ON
OUR LOCAL JAILS AS A RESULT OF
CONTRACTING WITH ICE. THE DATA
IS IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY CONSISTENT WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW. FOR
EXAMPLE THIS AUDIT CAN HELP
IDENTIFY WHETHER STATE FUNDS ARE
SUPPLANTING FEDERAL DOLLARS WHEN
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT RENTS PADS.
TO FADS BUT THEN COMES TO
REQUEST JOE CONSTRUCTION FUNDING
AIMED AT ADDRESSING OVERCROWDING.
ADDITIONALLY DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
WILL BE VALUABLE.
TO CLARIFY WHETHER OUR HOUSING
ARE WHETHER WE ARE HOUSING OR
HAVE HOUSED.
PASTE OR TRANSFERRED ANY OF THAT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN THAT ARE STILL MISSING.
ACCORDING TO TESTIMONY FOR THE
SENATE HOMELAND SECURITY
SUBCOMMITTEE ALMOST FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MIGRANT CHILDREN PLACED
IN HOMES OF ADULT SPONSORS BY
FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTY
WENT MISSING LAST YEAR. ARE THEY
IN CALIFORNIA HOW MANY ARE THERE
ARE THERE ARE GROUP HOMES FROM
FAMILY PLACEMENTS JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES. ARE THEIR
PARENTS ALSO DETENTION HAVE THEY
BEEN SEPARATED HAVE THESE
CHILDREN DIED OR HAVE THE BEEN
DEPORTED. WE HAVE NO IDEA OF
KNOWING WHERE THESE CHILDREN ARE.
THAT AND WHETHER YOU KNOW IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE WE'RE AT ON
THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE. WE SHOULD
BE ACCOUNTABLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THESE CHILDREN ARE WHERE
ARE THE BEING PLACED. AYE IF WE
DON'T KNOW IF THESE CHARGES HAVE
BEEN RELEASED IT TO COMMUNITIES.
WE SHOULD.
WE SHOULD KNOW SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE BEING
SUPPORTED INTEGRATED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AFFORDED DUE PROCESS.
AGAIN MEMBERS.
.
AT THE STATE IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO CARE AND ACCOUNT
FOR THE INNOCENT IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE CHILDREN THE CONTINUED
REMAIN MISSING TODAY. ARE
STRICTLY ASK FOR A VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU HAVE ANY OF
WITNESSES WHO PART OF YOUR
REQUESTS.
ANY WITNESSES OF YES.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT WE DON'T
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WERE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE.
ON A REQUEST BY THE SENATOR WE
THINK THAT WITH THE.
STEPS LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN TO
LAST FOR YEARS TO ENSURE THE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
IMMIGRANTS AND I IMMIGRANTS.
THAT THIS IS A TIMELY MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
TO ENSURE THAT.
OUR TAXPAYER FUNDS ARE BEING
SPENT WITH SHOULD BE SPENT
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE DATA. TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS IT
IMMIGRANTS AND I'M GOING TO GET
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
STATE AUDITOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AS SENATOR LARA INDICATED
THIS WOULD BE LOOKING AT.
STARTING AT THE STATE LEVEL
LOOKING UP CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
ANY OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT
ARE INVOLVED AND OVERSEEING
JAILS THAT CONTRACT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. UP
SPECIFICALLY HE'S ASKED US TO
LOOK AT A FIVE YEAR WINDOW AND
GET GATHERING SOME INFORMATION
AS FAR AS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS DETAINED IN THESE
CONTRACT DEALS FOR REASONS.
REGARDING IMMIGRATION STATUS THE
DURATION OF AMOUNT OF ANY STATE
OR LOCAL.
MONEY THAT'S BEING USED TO
SUPPORT.
PARTICULAR CONTRACTS OVER AND
ABOVE THE FEDERAL MONEY.
THAT THE AYE AYE SPACE TO TO
THESE CONTRACT JAILS HE'S ASKED
US TO LOOK AT A SELECTION OF
CONTRACT YELLS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE LOOKING AT BOTH OUR
CURRENT CONTRACT OR RECENT
CONTRACT. ALL THAT THEY'VE HAD
WITH WITH ICE AND AGAIN LOOKING
AT THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL MONEY
THAT IS COMING INTO THESE
FACILITIES POWER THE FACILITIES
USING THE FEDERAL MONEY AS A
SENATOR INDICATORS IT BEING USED
TO EXPAND. THE CAPACITY OF THESE
PARTICULAR FACILITIES ARE THERE
ANY LIMITS PLACED IN THOSE
CONTRACTS AS FAR AS MONETARY
CAPS ON THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
MONEY. THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED TO
THE CONTRACT JAILS IF THERE ARE
IF THE EXPENDITURES EXCEED THAT
WHAT'S THE SOURCE OF FUNDING
THAT THE JAILS ARE USING. OUGHT
TO PROVIDE.
NAM TOOK TO COVER THE EXCESSIVE
OUR EXPENSES RELATED TO THOSE.
TO THOSE DETAINEES ON IN
ADDITION LOOKING AT THE HOUSING
ARE THESE DETAINEES HOUSED IN A
A DIFFERENT. OUR ENVIRONMENT VAN
CRIMINAL DETAINEES ARE THEY
HOUSE TOGETHER WHAT KIND OF
REQUIREMENTS ARE THE JAILS
CONSIDERING WHAT'S INCLUDED IN
THE CONTRACTS WITH RESPECT TO.
DETAINING HER HOUSING THE THE
DETAINEES AS HE INDICATED HE IS
ASKING FOR SOME DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ABOUT A FIVE OR SIX
YEAR WINDOW FOR TWENTY THIRTEEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN. LOOKING AT
AGES NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS ARE
LOOKING TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT ANY CHILDREN BEING DETAINED.
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY DEATHS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED.
DURING THE TIME THE INDIVIDUALS
WERE DETAINED IF POSSIBLE TO
IDENTIFY THE CAUSE OF DEATH.
DECIDE IT'S BUDGETED AT A LITTLE
OVER THREE THOUSAND HOURS THE
REASON FOR THAT IS WE FEEL WE
NEED TO GO TO MULTIPLE LOCATIONS
ARE WILL DO SOME WORK AT THE
STATE LEVEL BUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE EFFORT WILL BE.
AT THESE CONTRACT JAILS.
THAT ARE ARE CONTRACTING WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DETAIN
HOT INDIVIDUALS FOR IMMIGRATION
RELATED REASONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY IDENTIFIED.
ARE RESPONDING AGENCIES BUT ARE
THERE ANY.
REPRESENT IS OF ANY.
CHRIS POTENTIAL RESPONDING
AGENCIES IN THE AUDIENCE.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SENATE.
SOME OF OUR BAKER THANK YOU AND
DAM.
I YEAH YOU MAY HAVE COVERED THIS
I APOLOGIZE FOR GETTING THEM
RIGHT AFTER.
BUT I FIRST WENT BEFORE WE. AND
SEND THE AUDITOR SOMEWHERE ADDS
IMPORTANT TO SEE THE EFFECT THAT
IT MAY WHERE. THE OUTER MAY END
UP IN THE AFFECT THAT MAY HAVE
ON EITHER EXISTING AUDITS ARE
OVERSIGHT IN REVIEW. SO HAVE
QUESTIONS TO THAT AND FOR BOTH
THE AUDITOR IN OUR AUTHOR. OF
THE AUDITOR THE ENTITIES.
THAT YOU WOULD BE LOOKING TO
AUDIT.
IN THE PAST YOU'VE MENTIONED
WHEN THE I DIDN'T SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFY PARTICULAR AGENCIES
WHERE THOSE MIGHT BE. CAN YOU
ADDRESS HOW YOU WILL CHOOSE
WHICH ENTITIES YOU WOULD GO TO
OR WOULD YOU GO TO THE WHOLE I
THINK THERE'S SOMETHING LIKE
FIVE.
WERE SIX IN THE STATE THAT WOULD
FALL WITHIN THE S..
REQUEST
YEAH AND THANK YOU MISS MS BAKER
I'M IN THE BACKGROUND MATERIALS
THAT I'VE LOOKED AT IT I'VE SEEN
A RANGE BETWEEN NINE AND TWELVE
DIFFERENT FACILITIES IN THE
STATE.
I ALSO LOOKED AT SOME
INFORMATION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE U. S. DEPARTMENT
HOMELAND SECURITY THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL DID SOME.
UNANNOUNCED VISITS AND THERE
WERE TWO FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY HAD SOME
VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS I THINK WE WOULD WANT
TO INCLUDE THOSE TWO FACILITIES.
AND THEN PICK.
A HANDFUL OF ADDITIONAL
FACILITIES TO GET REGIONAL AS WE
OFTEN DO NOW NORTH SOUTH.
AND ALSO TRY TO IDENTIFY THE
NUMBER OF DETAINEES IN THOSE
DIFFERENT FACILITY SO WE WOULD
TRY TO PICK A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE ACROSS THE STATE BUT.
THERE WERE TWO IN PARTICULAR
THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AGAIN DID AN UNANNOUNCED VISIT
AND REALLY WAS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CONDITION SO I THINK
WE WOULD WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT BECAUSE THE IG WAS IN THERE.
ABOUT THREE
AGO AND THOSE TWO WHERE.
I'D HAVE TO GRAB MY BACKGROUND
MATERIAL I THINK IT WAS.
.
THERE IS A.
WHAT IF ANOTHER MEMBER KNOWS? I
I'LL HAVE TO THINK YOU.
HIS I DID NOT SEE THAT TWO
MENTIONED.
SPECIFICALLY THE MATERIALS
SPECIFICALLY MENTION BUT.
HERE'S MY.
MY WEEKEND HOMEWORK.
WE'LL FIND IT FOR A VERY QUICK
THANK YOU.
AND.
AYE WELL THAT WELL AUDITOR AND
THANK YOU FOR LOOKING FOR THAT
MAYBE ADDRESS MY NEXT TO THE.
OUR AUTHOR IN THAT IS.
YOU KNOW THESE GOING INTO THESE.
AGENCIES DOES YOU KNOW. PICKED
STAFF TIME AND RESOURCES AWAY IN
THIS WOULD BE OF COURSE FOLKS
ARE OPERATING A JAILER LA
ENFORCEMENT FACILITY. AND SO
IT'S AYE WANNA AYE I'M USUALLY
RETICENT TO PROVIDE ITS THAT
EITHER THERE'S A PENDING AUDIT
ALREADY GOING ON OR WE CAN GET
THE INFORMATION WITHOUT THE
AUDIT. SO WITH RESPECT TO THE
FIRST QUESTION UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
WAS DIRECTED I BELIEVE LAST YEAR
TO HAVE BY.
BY MARCH OF TWENTY NINETEEN A
REVIEW OF THESE ENTITIES. IF I'M.
IF THERE IS AN INTEREST IN
TRYING I MEAN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
OUTCOME OF THAT IS. IF THAT
WOULD MAKE EITHER DUPLICATIVE
WORK FOR WHAT OUR AUDITOR WILL
BE DOING OR AND WE DO NEED TO
FIGHT FIND OUT WITH THE AG'S
GONNA DO WE ALREADY HAVE. SENT
THE AG INTO THIS I THINK THE
SAME ENTITIES.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT PLEASE
EARLY THIS IS A WEEK WEEKS WE
SEE THIS AUDIT OF COMPLIMENTARY
TO WHAT THE AG IS ALREADY DOING.
THE AG IN A SENSE IS LOOKING AT
OUR CURRENT CONDITIONS OF WHAT
IS OCCURRING AT SOME OF THE.
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT.
DETENTION CENTERS THIS IS
FOCUSING ON OUR PUBLIC
FACILITIES WHERE.
WE STILL LACK SO MUCH
INFORMATION ABOUT.
EVEN STATISTICAL DATA ON HOW
MANY.
DETAINEES WE HAVE ONE OF THE
CONDITIONS IN THESE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TRYING TO LOOK AT.
THE THE FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
COMING DOWN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND THEN HAVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COME TO US AND
SAYING WE WE NEED MORE MONEY FOR
JOE CONSTRUCTION. AND WE'RE
SAYING THAT THE MONEY IS A MONEY
OFFSETTING. THEN THE POSSIBILITY
OF ACTUALLY DETAINING PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTUAL CRIMINALS IN THE
SYSTEM SO IT WE FEAR OF
COMPLEMENTARY WE ACTUALLY.
REVIEW WOULD.
WE ACTUALLY HAD THE AG REPEALED
AUDIT REQUEST TO LOOK AT IT MAKE
SURE THAT WE WORK.
DUPLICATIVE IN THEIR WORK AND
SO THEY THEY FELT THAT THIS WAS
COMPLEMENT YOU TO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING GIVEN THAT
THIS IS FOCUSING ON THE THE
PUBLIC.
FACILITIES AND I I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S ANYONE FROM AGES
OFFICERS HERE IMAGINE THAT IF
THERE IS A BUT I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU REACHED OUT TO THE AG'S
OFFICE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT. WHAT WE DIRECTED THEM TO
DO JUST LAST YEAR IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET? WHICH I SUPPORTED WAS TO
HAVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
COMPLETE A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW
OF COUNTY.
JAIL FACILITIES AND PRIVATE SO
THAT IT IS.
A LOOKING AT THE VERY SAME
ENTITIES THAT COULD BE COVERED
BY THIS AND THAT THE AG ISN'T
JUST LOOKING AT PRIVATE RECENT
THAT YOU'RE UNDERSTAND IS THE
AGES LOOKING ONLY A PRIVATE WELL
WE. WE'VE FOUGHT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
GO INTO THE PRIVATE FACILITIES
WHICH THEY DIDN'T HAVE
NOW MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
AGE IS GOING TO GO IN AND LOOK
AT THE HONG GOING CURRENT
SITUATION OF. NOT ONLY WHAT THE
CONDITIONS ARE WHAT THE.
ICE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE WHEN
IT CAME TO ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ACCESS TO.
DUE PROCESS ACCESS TO SHELTER.
AND SO THOSE ARE KIND OF LIKE
THE HUMAN CONDITIONS AND WHAT
WE'RE ASKING THE AUDITOR'S TO GO
MUCH MORE BEYOND THAT IN TERMS
OF WHAT IS A TO STATISTICAL DATA.
THOUGH HISTORIC DATA OF HOW MANY
FOLKS ARE ARE BEING HELD HOW
MANY UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ARE
THERE AND ALSO THE FACT THAT
THERE'S FIFTEEN HUNDRED.
CHILDREN THAT ARE MISSING AND WE
HAVE AND THE US GOVERNMENT HAS
NO IDEA WHETHER AT WHERE THEIR
PLACE SO WE'RE ASKING WHERE.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE KNOW IF
THEY'RE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE ARE
THEY ARE THE BEING PLACED ON THE
WHAT THE DEPORTED. HAVE THE
PASSED AWAY WE DON'T THERE'S NO
DATA TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THAT SO WE'RE ASKING THE
AUDITOR TO GO IN AND HAVE A
DEEPER LOOK INTO A MORE
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE. AND
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OF WHERE
WE KNOW WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING
BECAUSE THAT'S. ALL THE
INFORMATION WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
GET.
BEFOREHAND HAVE BEEN EITHER TO
ADVOCATES OR TO THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT. SO THIS WILL
GIVE THEM A BETTER COMPREHENSIVE
LOOK AT ONLY THE FINANCING OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN TERMS OF.
THE FEDERAL FUNDS WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO ARE THEY ACTUALLY GOING
TO SERVICE THIS COMMUNITY.
OR ARE THE YOU KNOW BEING USED
TO SUPPLANT FUNDS FOR.
GROWING THAT THE PRISON THE
LOCAL PRESENTER JAILS OF SELF
THOSE OF THE THINGS THAT WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT ARE
DIFFERENT AND AGAIN THE AG DID
LOOK AT OUR LETTER. AND THOUGHT
IT WAS COMPLIMENTARY TO WHAT WE
WERE WHAT THEIR WORK TO DURING
THANK YOU AYE.
AYE I DO HAVE A CONCERN THAT WE
ARE WE HAVE A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW THAT WE HAVE ASKED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO DO
THAT THAT MAY BE COMPLEMENTARY
BUT ALSO DUPLICATIVE SINCE THE
RESOURCES TO BE GOING INTO THE
SAME. AND THEN IT GOES TO THE
THE WHERE YOU MENTION THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET.
INFORMATION FROM FOR FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT USUALLY AND I I
AT LEAST LOOK AT I LOOK AT IS
THIS WHEN CITY STATE AUDITOR IS
A CHOICE OF LAST RESORT BUT
WE'VE BEFORE WE SPEND FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THREE THOUSAND HOURS. FOR THE
AUDITOR LOOKING INTO THIS AND
THE DISRUPTION THAT IT HASN'T
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FACILITIES THAT WE MAKE SURE
THIS ISN'T DATA THAT CAN BE
ACQUIRED. ELSEWHERE.
HAVE YOU DONE OR HAVE YOU
MENTION FOR YOUR REQUESTS HAVE
THERE BEEN EFFORTS TO DO THAT
AND HAVE THEY NOT RESULTED IN
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE BEEN IT'S BEEN VERY
PATCHWORK AND IT'S BEEN VERY
PIECEMEAL WHICH TAKES A LOT OF
TIME FROM THE ADVOCATES AND.
WITH THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
WITH THEM.
DAVID HAD VERY LIMITED ACCESS
TO SOME OF THESE.
.
FACILITIES AND IN ONE OF THE
INSTANCES FOR EXAMPLE ON ONE OF
OUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA JAILS.
THEY WERE HOUSING HOW MANY
CHILDREN.
THEY WERE HOUSING TWENTY FOUR
CHILDREN THAT WE HAD NO IDEA I
MANY OF WHICH ALREADY HAD WANDER
ASYLUM CASE BUT WAS STILL BEING
HELD YOU KNOW IT LOCATION THAT
WAS IN THAT BOOK. OKAY NO.
I'M SORRY YOLO COUNTY YOLO
COUNTY.
A AND
SO THE FOYER RICK HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE I MEAN THEY ARE DIFFICULT
FOR FOR YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
EASY BUT THEY ARE ARE THEY ARE
PART OF THE PUBLIC INFORMATION.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING ALSO THAT.
MUCH OF THE INFORMATION MAY BE
REQUESTED IT LISTED SOME OF THE
LOCATIONS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
THEY TRACK IT SOMETHING THAT ICE
HOUSE.
HAVE YOU ARE OR THESE
ORGANIZATIONS REACHED OUT TO ICE
TO GET THAT INFORMATION AGAIN
IT'S BEEN THROUGH FOIA REQUEST
WHICH AGAIN TAKES TIME.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE HAVE BEEN OVER A HUNDRED
DEATHS.
OF OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DETAINED AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO
KNOW IS TRY TO FIGURE OUT OF
THEIR SOME TRENDS AND PATTERNS
IN WHERE.
WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING SO IT'S BEEN
IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT.
JOURNEY TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION AND GIVEN THAT THE
POPULATION FLUCTUATES AND OUR
CONCERT MOVING WE WERE TIME MAKE
SURE WE GET THE DATA AND THE
STATISTICS AGAIN. THE HG IS
LOOKING AT THE CURRENT. HEALTH
AND CONDITION OF OUR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION AND.
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ARE
REFUGEES THIS AUDIT WILL GO MORE
IN DEPTH THAN LOOKING AT.
STATISTICAL DATA ABOUT YOU KNOW
FOUGHT BACK FIVE YEARS THIS IS
WHY. THE THE THE HONORS THE
AUDITS LOW PRICEY BUT IT'S
INFORMATION WE DON'T HAVE NOW WE
HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY FOLKS ARE
BEING HELD WHAT THEIR STATUS IS
OF THEIR. THEIR IMMIGRANT CASE.
ARE THEY BEING.
ACASO BEFORE SOME OF THOSE
CHILDREN HAD REALLY WANT ASYLUM
CASE BUT WERE STILL BEING HELD
TO DRAW DOWN THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
SO THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO KNOW I MEAN DEPENDING ON
ONCE WE GET THAT INFORMATION
WILL BETTER KNOW AND DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO ACCORDINGLY. SO AGAIN
WE FEEL THAT THIS IS
COMPLIMENTARY BUT I I RETORTED
ASSIGN YOUR QUESTIONS AND WE
DON'T IF WE WANNA WE DON'T WANT
TO. REDUPLICATED WORKED AT THE
AGE IS DOING AGAIN THIS IS WHY
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE WE CHECK
WITH WITH THEIR OFFICE FIRST AND
THE THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS AND IS
MY AGE AND IT IS A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE TASK THAT THE AG'S
OFFICE HAS BEEN GIVEN. AND AN
AMOUNT OF TIME TO WHICH IS MARCH
OF TWENTY NINETEEN OR SPRING YOU
KNOW YEAR FROM NOW. TO TO GET
THAT AND IT DOES MAKE ME
HESITANT TO TO THEN HAVE ANOTHER
PROCESS WE'VE WE'VE APPROVED
DIES BEFORE MANY TIMES A
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WE END UP
WITH THEM SPENDING A WHOLE LOT
OF TIME. AND DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THE DELAY TO GET THE INFORMATION
THAT I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING SOMETHING FOR IT. LOOKS
INTO THIS AT IS THE AUDITOR HAVE
A CHANCE TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
TWO ENTITIES WERE.
RIGHT TO TO FACILITY SANTA ANA
CITY JAIL WAS ONE FACILITY
ACCORDING TO THE IG REPORT
THAT'S A MIXED GENDER FACILITY
SO HOUSING MALES AND FEMALES.
AND THEN THE OTHER FACILITY AS
THEO LACY WHICH IS AN ORANGE
COUNTY. SO THOSE ARE THE TWO
FACILITIES THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOR HOMELAND SECURITY A
CASE RECENTLY VISITED THANK YOU.
AYE YEAH AYE AGAIN I WAS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR INCLUDING THIS REQUEST. THE
THE THE REVIEW IN THE OVERSIGHT.
AND I DO KNOW THAT ICE ALSO
CONDUCTS TO SEPARATE. OVERSIGHT.
REPORTS AND FUNCTIONS
THEMSELVES INDEPENDENT FROM WHAT
THE AG'S OFFICE IS DOING.
I I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE US TO.
I I SUPPOSE IDEALLY I'D LIKE TO
SEE THIS HAPPEN AFTER THE AG'S
REPORT.
IS COMING FORWARD CERTAINLY THE
INFORMATION IS WORTH HAVING.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE LOOK AT
IT AND ALSO THAT THERE IS A
GEOGRAPHIC BALANCE POPULATION
BALANCE. AND.
YOU KNOW YOU'LL HAVE COUNTY
VERSES CITY AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
FIND A BALANCE FOR THAT AND HOW
IT MAY PRIORITIZE SO THANK YOU
FOR. THE ANSWER MAKE YOU
APPRECIATE QUESTIONS ARE ALL
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SORROWFUL.
SO I'M JUST A LITTLE CONFUSED ON.
WE ALREADY HAVE THIS.
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE BEING
INVESTIGATED.
AND OUR CALLING FOREIGN AUDIT
BUT THE AUDIT DESCRIPTION SOUNDS
LIKE AN INVESTIGATION MORE THAN
A NOT IT.
AND SO WOULD YOU CLARIFY THAT
DIFFERENCE TWO NECESSARILY SO
THE HG. AND I APOLOGIZE IF I
MISSPOKE THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
HAVING YOUR CHIEF OF STAFF NEXT
TO YOU. INTO.
THE EIGHTY G. OTHER LE ARE
LOOKING INTO PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
FACILITIES AND THEY'RE LOOKING
AT TWO BEINGS THE STANDARD OF
CONDUCT THE STANDARD OF CARING
CONDITION. OF THE CONFINEMENT.
SO THAT IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOU
WOULD CALL AN INVESTIGATION.
THE A PUBLIC ART IT IS MORE ON
DATA FISCAL ANALYSIS ON WHERE
THESE FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY BEING
USED.
FROM THE FEDERAL MONEY FOR THE
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE BEING DRAWN
DOWN ON THE ACTUALLY BEING USED
TO HOUSE IMMIGRANTS TO CARE FOR
THE IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING
DETAINED AND THE REFUGEES.
AND THEN THE DEMOGRAPHICS WHO
ARE THESE FOLKS WE HAVE NO IDEA.
WHETHER HOW MANY WHAT TYPE OF
IMMIGRANT THEY ARE WHAT WHETHER
CASES SO THAT THOSE ARE THE
DIFFERENCES THAT IS AN AUDIT.
WELL IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
.
GIVEN THE COST OF THIS AUDIT.
IT HAS SOME GOOD INTENTIONS BUT
IT WOULD BE BETTER LAYERED ON
TOP.
AFTER.
CURRENT INVESTIGATION IS
FINISHED
AND WHEN THERE WE COULD MAY BE.
A TIME LIMIT OR.
NARROWER FOCUS.
THE AUDIT REQUEST.
RIGHT NOW IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S REALLY A LOT OF OVERLAP.
AND.
I REALLY DON'T. HIT I DON'T
THINK IT'S.
WE DON'T WE RARELY HAVE ENOUGH
BY THE TIME FOR OUR AUDITOR TO
AUDIT EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED.
SAYS IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT.
IT WOULD BE BETTER TO STREAMLINE
THIS. AUDIT AT A LATER DATE
AFTER WE ALREADY HAVE.
A DONE THE INVESTIGATIVE WORK
AND WE KNOW SOME MORE THINGS
ABOUT WHAT IT IS WE WANT TO
TRACK.
.
AND ULTIMATELY I THINK THIS
QUESTION.
A LOT OF THIS QUESTION IS GOING
TO BE ANSWERED IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. A IN OTHER VENUES ANYWAY
AND SO MAYBE. WE WOULD GET DOWN
TO SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE MAY
BE MORE USEFUL FOR.
FOUR OR PAYING BUT I I DO.
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AND.
.
CERTAINLY I WILL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE RESULTS OF THAT
CURRENT INVESTIGATIVE OF REPORT
TO INFORM US OF WHAT OUR NEXT
STEP SHOULD BE.
RICHARD THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVIEW.
THANK YOU I'M I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS I THINK.
AND I SHARE YOUR CONCERN I READ
THE REPORTS ABOUT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED KIDS BEING GONE AYE IT'S
IT JUST TO ME NOT KNOWING.
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE IN THOSE
FACILITIES AND NOT KNOWING THE
NAMES ARE THAT'S THE CASE IS?
DISTURBING.
BECAUSE. I I WAS UNDER THE THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHEN SOMEBODY
WAS ADMITTED THAT THEY WOULD.
YOU KNOW DOCUMENT WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE AND IF WE CAN'T FIND
FIFTEEN HUNDRED CHILDREN I THINK
THAT THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE
RIGHT NOW JUST BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THAT AG IS DOING. A
SEPARATE AUDIT AND NOT ON
CONDITIONS AND THIS IS.
AT STATISTICS HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE THERE AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE HAVE BEEN TRANSFERRED TO
OTHER FACILITIES.
I HAVE A SITUATION IN MY CITY
WHERE WE CAN'T FIND.
THE SPOUSE OF ACTUALLY MY
NEIGHBOR.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE HE IS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MIS
COMMUNICATED IS INFORMATION.
TO THE SPOUSE AND SO.
AT FIRST SHE WAS TOLD THAT THEY
WERE IN.
BRAWLEY I THINK AND SHE WENT
THERE AND HE WASN'T THERE AND SO
TO ME IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE FIND.
AT LEAST TO IDENTIFY WITH THESE
FOLKS ARE SO THAT WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OR THAT THE
FAMILIES ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE THEY ARE YOU AT LEAST
WE KNOW WHERE THEY'RE. IF
THEY'RE THERE OR IF THEY'RE NOT
THERE BUT I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND NIGHT I SHARE YOUR CONCERN
BUT I THINK.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IT'S NOT LIKE WE
LOST THE CAR BROADLY TO IF WE
LOSE CHILDREN THAT'S A OF BIG
CONCERN TO US ARE TO ME. ANYWAY
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
AND.
.
ALSO THE THE YOU KNOW FOR PURE
FROM THE AUDITOR THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE TIME AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW TO DO THIS AND I THINK
IT'S OF THE ESSENCE THAT WE DO
THAT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
ANYONE THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE ANY OF FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SAYING NONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SARAH LARA AYE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE.
COMPLEMENTARY NATURE OF YOUR
REQUEST.
.
HAVING WORKED IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE I AM ACTUALLY
NOT SURE WHO. OR RAZA WHAT
RESOURCES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD HAVE IN TERMS OF COMPILING.
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE
SEEKING.
AND SO.
.
CHILDREN ARE MISSING.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
AND ARE SITTING COUNTY JAILS.
AND I FULLY SUPPORT YOUR IF YOU
REQUEST WHICH LIKE IT OUGHT TO
CLOSE THANK YOU AGAIN AND I I DO
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND AND
THE CLARIFICATION ON. THE WORK
THAT THE AG IS DOING THAT TO ME
YOU KNOW THAT TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU'RE AT ON
THE IMMIGRATION SPECTRUM.
YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE SO MUCH IN
IN CALIFORNIA CHIU NOT ONLY SHED
SOME LIGHT.
I'M THE SERVICES AND AND.
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING.
HIGHLIGHTED AS IMPORTANT FOR
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE AND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I UNDERSTAND YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
CAN DO THEIR JOBS. ARE IN THE
PRISONS AND IN THE JAILS BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THE DATA THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS. AND
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT IF THE MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ACTUALLY BEING PUT TO USE FOR
THESE.
FOR THESE FOLKS AND NOT BEING
USE JUST A PLANT OR THEN THE
IRONY OF THEM HAVING TO CREATE
MORE BADS. NOT GETTING ENOUGH
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEN COMING TO
THE STATE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
PRINT I'VE JOKERS PRISON
CONSTRUCTION MONEY OR JUMP
CONSTRUCTION MONEY. BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BEDS SO THIS
WOULD SHED SOME LIGHT GIVE US
SOME DATA AND ALLOW US TO MOVE
APPROPRIATELY IN AND AND AGAIN
IT IS COMPLEMENTARY. TO WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS DOING WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM.
SIDE BY SIDE ON THIS ISSUE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANKS VERY MUCH. CAN I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MS RUBIO.
MOVED BY MS RUBIO.
SECONDED BY ME.
.
MADAM SECRETARY IS CULTURAL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TASH ONE
ONE SEVEN CITY IN COUNTY JAILS
OUT CONTRACTS WITH YOU AS
IMMIGRATION CUSTOMER ENFORCEMENT.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AND
AYE VOTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY
CHANGE WHERE CG I ACOSTA.
BAKER.
BAKER I IS ARYAN.
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO AYE
RUBIO I WOULDN'T.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN BELL.
CANNELLA FULLER.
FULLER NO.
LARA AYE LARA AYE.
ALRIGHT THE REQUESTED ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT I BELIEVE SEVERAL GAINES
JUST BEAT OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA ON THE SIGN UP LIST AND
SO YES SORRY I MEAN SEVERAL
GALGIANI AT POLICIES.
THIS SERVES ITEM NUMBER TEN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
FIFTEEN.
ON A REQUEST BY SENATOR
GALGIANI.
ON.
.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT A
REQUEST TO AUDIT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND THE HEALTH PLAN OF
SAN JOAQUIN WHICH IS A PUBLICLY
SPONSORED NOT FOR PROFIT HEALTH
MAINTENANCE ORGANIZATION
ENROLLED AS A MEDIC HELP FIGHTER.
SPECIFICALLY I'M REQUESTING THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT INTO BONUS
PAYMENTS MADE TO PERSONNEL AT
THE HEALTH PLAN OF SAN JOAQUIN.
AND D. H. CS IS OVERSIGHT
INCLUDING OVERSIGHT OF SUCH
PAYMENTS OR PRACTICES.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THE HEALTH
PLANS SAM KEEN PROVIDES A VITAL
SERVICE TO MANY CHILDREN SENIORS
AND WORKING FAMILIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WITHOUT IT MANY LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
WOULD FURTHER STRUGGLE TO ACCESS
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. HOWEVER IS
COME TO MY ATTENTION THAT THE
HEALTH PLAN OF SAM KEEN HAS
REWARDED CERTAIN EXECUTIVES WITH
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
BONUSES ON TOP OF THEIR SALARIES.
AND I'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT AT
LEAST SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS HAS BEEN
AWARDED IN BONUS PAY TO
MANAGEMENT AND NON REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES. AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ALONE.
ONE EXECUTIVE IS SAID TO HAVE
RECEIVED A BONUS OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON TOP OF A THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ANNUAL SALARY.
GIVEN THAT THE MEDIUM AND CAN
MEDIAN INCOME IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY. IS.
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIVE DOLLARS A
CONCERNS ME WHEN NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL IS A WORDING AN
EXECUTIVE A BONUS WHICH IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF THE AVERAGE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES YEARLY SALARY.
WHY CAN APPRECIATE THE DIFFICULT
TASK THAT THE HEALTH PLAN OF
SOUND TEAM FACES AND PROVIDING
NEEDED CARE? I'M ALSO REMINDED
OF A LOS ANGELES TIMES ARTICLE
FROM NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THAT REPORTS THAT MEDI
CAL HEALTH PLANS IN GENERAL.
MADE FIVE POINT FOUR BILLION IN
PROFITS DURING THE MEDICAID
EXPANSION BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
AND ACCORDING TO D. H. CSS
DIRECTOR JENNIFER CAN AS QUOTED
IN THE LA TIMES ARTICLE. HEALTH
PLANS PROFITS WERE HIGHER THAN
ANTICIPATED DURING THE A CA
EXPANSION.
IT IS CLEAR THAT IT AUDIT IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH HEALTH PLANS
ARE COMPLYING WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL STANDARDS. AND THE
OVERSIGHT PROVIDED BY D. H. CS.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUES TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE STEWARD OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. I BELIEVE AND I WILL
PROVIDE INSIGHT INTO ALLEGATIONS
OF MISMANAGEMENT AND SPIKED PAY
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION FOR THE HEALTH PLAN OF
SAN JOAQUIN. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE APPROVE THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IDEA OF ANY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
REQUEST.
OKAY CENA US.
THE STATE AUDITOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS CENTER
GALGIANI INDICATED THIS WOULD BE
AN AUDIT OF THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AND THEIR OVERSIGHT ROLE WITH
RESPECT TO MEDI CAL MANAGED
HEALTHCARE PLANS SHE HAD
SPECIFIED THAT YOU'D LIKE US TO
LOOK AT THE.
HEALTH PLAN OF SAN JOAQUIN BUT
ALSO LOOK AT SOME OTHER PLANS AS
WELL AS FAR AS.
THE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
OVERSIGHT OVER THOSE PLANTS
LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF AREAS
WHAT WHAT TYPE OF OVERSIGHT IS
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PROVIDING
WITH RESPECT TO RATES ANY RATE
ADJUSTMENTS TO MEDI CAL.
PAYMENTS FOR MANAGED HEALTH
CARE PLANS.
THE QUALITY OF CARE MONITORING.
THE PLANS AS FAR AS THEIR
DELIVERY OF OF CARE AND
HOPEFULLY THE IMPROVEMENT OF THE
QUALITY OF CARE AT AT THE
VARIOUS FACILITIES. ARE AS THE
SENATOR INDICATED WE WOULD BE
EMPHASIZING.
THE ANALYSIS IN LOOKING AT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THEIR
OVERSIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
MEDICAL.
PLANS MEDICAL H. M. O.'S
INCLUDING THE HEALTH PLAN OF SAN
JOAQUIN AND MEETING BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO STANDARDS OF CARE.
I'M SHE SPECIFIED POSTPARTUM
CARE IN DIABETES CARE BUT WOULD
LOOK AT OTHERS AS WELL AND THEN
THE LAST TWO OR THREE OBJECTIVES
ARE REALLY LOOKING AT MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. OUT WHAT TYPE OF
OVERSIGHT IS HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PROVIDE WITH RESPECT TO
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
ANY BONUSES PAID TO EMPLOYEES
WHETHER OR NOT SOME OF THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE
APPROPRIATE AND ALLOWABLE.
AND THEN ALSO WHAT IS HEALTH
CARE SERVICES DOING IN PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH PLANS HOW TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE SUFFICIENT
CONTROLS. TO PREVENT WASTE ABUSE
ANY KIND OF MISMANAGEMENT A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
AND AND AND FOCUSING ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
THE BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT IS
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED HOURS
RELATIVELY SMALL THAT WOULD TAKE
US BETWEEN FIVE AND SIX MONTHS
TO COMPLETE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
TWO WE HAVE.
REPRESENTATIVES.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES OR THE HEALTH PLAN OF
SAN JOAQUIN.
IF WE DO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ALRIGHT WHY DON'T WE HEAR FROM A.
A DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
FIRST.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS DAN RONAN
LEGISLATIVE COORDINATOR WITH THE
H. CS AM UNFORTUNATELY GOT
DOUBLE BOOKED WITH A COUPLE
BUDGET HEARINGS TODAY SO IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE THOSE INTO COMBAT THAT
APARTMENT IN THE PROVIDE YOU
WITH.
WITH THE RESPONSE OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I CHAU WE HAVE A MISSION. NOW
WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL.
LEAGUE WHICH LIKE TO MAKE
STATEMENT.
YES GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MY NAME IS
AMY CHEN AND THE CEO OF HEALTH
PLAN THAT'S UNLOCKING IT.
HELP US AND I CANCERS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS. AND THAT ARE MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES IN SAN JOAQUIN
STANISLAUS COUNTIES.
AS A PUBLIC ENTITY WE ARE
GOVERNED BY A PUBLIC COMMISSION.
APPOINTED BY OUR LOCAL COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND THE
PUBLIC COMMISSION IS SUBJECT TO
BROWN ACTS OPEN MEETING RULES
AND OPERATE WITH COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY.
FIRST AND TO REQUEST A LARGE
STATEWIDE AUDIT AND IS PREDICATE
AND IT IT'S PREDICATED ON A
SINGLE. LOCAL LABOR CONTRACT
MATTER WITH A HEALTH PLAN.
AS PRIOR TO THE UNIONIZATION ALL
EMPLOYEES HAD AN INCENTIVE OR
BONUS PROGRAM.
AND AS PART OF THEIR TOTAL
COMPENSATION.
SECOND OUT WE THINK THIS AUDIT
IS A LITTLE PREMATURE.
WHAT WE LEARNED THAT HAVE
SENATORS AND TEND TO REQUEST NOT
IT WE MET WITH THE SENATOR? AND
WE ACTUALLY AGREED WITH HER THAT
EVERY DOLLAR MATTERS AND WE MUST
ENSURE. PROPER FISCAL MANAGEMENT
OF PUBLIC DOLLARS
WE FOLLOWED UP WITH THE
SENATOR'S OFFICE COUPLE TIMES
SINCE THAT MEETING TO ASK IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR THIS INFORMATION.
BOAT AB AND NO OTHER
INFORMATION WAS REQUESTED.
IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR WHETHER
SANDERS OFFICE HAS TRIED TO GET
ANSWERS BUT THESE ANSWERS.
FROM THE H. CS BEFORE
REQUESTING AN AUDIT.
ADDITIONALLY A NUMBER OF
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS REYES AND
AUDIT REQUEST HAS ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED. BY THE LEGISLATURE.
FOR EXAMPLE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES HELD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON NOVEMBER NINTH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH WEIGHS
LA TIMES ARTICLE REFERENCING
QUESTION NUMBER ONE. OF THE
AUDIT REQUEST.
I'M PREPARED TO.
ADDRESS ALL OTHER QUESTIONS
OUTLINED IN THE AUDIT BUT OF
COURSE GIVEN THE TIME LIMIT.
I CAN DEFER TO THAT.
COMMITTEES AND QUESTION PERIOD.
AND THAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR IN QUESTION I'M
EQUATED TO POINT OH SEVEN SIX
PERCENT OF OUR TOTAL BUDGET.
SO IT'S OBVIOUSLY A SMALL
AMOUNT LIKE TOTAL ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS WAS THREE POINT EIGHT
PERCENT OF FOR THAT HERE. AND
THAT IS.
AT COMPARED TO HEALTH NET WHICH
IS OR COMPETITION COMPETITOR
HEALTH PLAN AND THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IS THERE
THIRTEEN TO FIFTEEN PERCENT.
GIVEN AT WHATEVER FISCAL YEAR
YOU LOOK AT.
AND SO AND I. THINK AGAIN IT'S A
LITTLE PREMATURE AND AND AT
BASED ON A LOCAL ISSUE.
HOWEVER I WE ARE VERY OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT AND WE WANT TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO SANDERS REQUEST.
AND SO IF THE REQUEST IS
APPROVED WE WILL FULLY COOPERATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM EATING.
SAN MIGUEL JOHNNY THE.
THE YOUR LETTER AND TESTIMONY
IS THAT YOU HAVE HEARD OR. AYE
IS BEEN REPORTED TO YOU ABOUT
BONUSES.
AND I THINK EVEN IF IT IS A
SMALL AMOUNT OF THAT OVERALL
BUDGET THAT BONUS IS THE SIZE OF
THE AVERAGE INCOME OF SOME OF
THE REPRESENT IS WORTH. TAKING A
LOOK AT SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SENSITIVITY TO IT.
BUT WHAT WHAT ARE YOU ABLE TO
SHARE IT WAS A SOMETHING WAS
REPORTED IN NEWS MEDIA OR HOW
DID THAT INFORMATION COME FOR
THAT IS FOUND IN THE BASIS FOR
YOUR AUDIT.
IT WASN'T THERE WAS A REPORT
THAT WAS GIVEN TO ME IN AND HAD
A HAD LISTED.
ACTUAL BONUSES AND SALARIES SO
WAS A REPORT OF INFORMATION AND
THIS WAS WAS A SET PUBLIC REPORT.
WAS IT CONDUCTED BY.
.
I JUST AM SORT OF HIS IS ALREADY
IN YOUR MATERIALS I DIDN'T SEE
IT WHERE THE.
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'RE I'M?
IF THIS IS AN AUDIT THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE THE CAME UP
WITH THE REPORT.
OR WHERE BUT WAS THE BASIS FOR.
THAT.
AND SOME OF THE INFORMATION CAME
FROM THE NEWSPAPER AND WE ALSO
HAVE A WHISTLEBLOWER THAT CAME
TO OUR OFFICE.
WHO WAS NOT AN SEIU MEMBER THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND AGAIN
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU?
?
EVEN IF IT'S A SMALL PORTION OF
AN OVERALL BUDGET.
I THINK WHEN WHEN YOU SEE
BONUSES OF THE AMOUNT THAT HAS
BEEN INDICATED BY THE AUTHOR.
IT IS WORTH TAKING EIGHT
INDEPENDENT.
AND VERY TRANSPARENT LOOK
OUTSIDE PRESHEAF THERE WILL BE
COOPERATION WITH THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE.
BUT I THINK IT'S RIGHT THAT YOU
ARE LOOKING AT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THE AVERAGE INCOME
IS THE AMOUNT OF SOME OF THOSE
BONUSES SO THANK YOU I JUST
WONDER WHAT THE BASIS WAS FOR
AND SEND THE AUDITOR OFF TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT.
IN A RANDOM HEARSAY SAID THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS.
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS MATTER.
I HAVE A GO ONE QUICK QUESTION
FOR A MISSION.
SO.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
PATIENTS ARE UP OR OR YOUR?
MEMBERS FORTY PATIENTS ARE MEDI.
MEDI CAL PATIENTS
THE PROCESS UNDER PERCENT.
SO.
YEAH I I THINK A.
.
I WOULD AGREE WITH THEM AS BAKER
THAT.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
PUBLIC DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T GET ANY
BONUSES AND.
I I THINK OF NOR SHOULD WE.
WE WE WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
WE GET TO WORK.
THAT.
.
YOU KNOW IMPORTANT PUBLIC
PROGRAM I. I I'M I'M SURE.
.
YEAH ASSUMING THAT EVERY
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IS IS IS TRUE AND CORRECT.
PERHAPS THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT WILL EITHER CONFIRM OR
DENY. ESTIMATES CONCERNS RAISED.
.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THIS AUTUMN.
I WOULD BE WORTHWHILE UMF CENTER
GALGIANI WAS LIKE CLOSE.
AM I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE THAT
BILL MOTION BY MUCH RUBIO SECOND
BY CENTER FULLER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
ONE FIVE PART OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OVERSIGHT OF THE HEALTH
PLAN OF SAN JOAQUIN. THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AYE VOTES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY TEAM MERCY
T. AYE ACOSTA.
BAKER BAKER AYE IS ARYAN.
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I WOULD.
WOULD I.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN.
BELL.
CANNELLA. CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
ALRIGHT THIS.
REQUESTS HIS UNCLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING PATIENT.
.
THIS ITEM WAS ORIGINALLY ON
CONSENT BUT TO.
IT WAS PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
OUR CONNIE OF SAN DIEGO.
AND THE VICE CHAIR. CONVEYING
THAT REQUEST SO.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE SHOULD THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT OF THIS J.
LACK REQUEST LAST YEAR MANY OF
YOU MAY KNOW SAN DIEGO
EXPERIENCE ONE OF THE DEADLIEST
OUTBREAK OF HEPATITIS A. AYE IN
RECENT HISTORY AND CERTAINLY
SINCE THE CREATION OF A VACCINE
FOR THIS.
DISEASE AS THE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX.
IN FACT DECLARATIONS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES WERE MADE
BOTH BY THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
AND BY GOVERNOR BROWN AS THE
DISEASE SPREAD FROM SAN DIEGO TO
OTHER JURISDICTIONS LIKE SANTA
CRUZ. AND LOS ANGELES AS OF
MARCH TWENTY NINTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THEY REPORTEDLY FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN CASES
FOUR HUNDRED TWO
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND REGRETTABLY
TWENTY DEATHS IN THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO BECAUSE OF HEPATITIS A.
THIS AUDIT IS SO VERY NECESSARY
BECAUSE WE NEEDED INDEPENDENT
REVIEW OF HOW THIS OUTBREAK WAS
HANDLED BOTH BY THE CITY AND
COUNTY OFSAN DIEGO. FOR EXAMPLE
WE MUST UNDERSTAND WHAT CRITERIA
WAS USED TO DETERMINE THE
OUTBREAK THAT WAS NOW IN FACT A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IN IT
THAT DECLARATION WAS MADE AT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME.
IT.
IF THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS
A RESULT OF THAT DECLARATION A
BY THE COUNTY THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY. GRANTEDTHE LOCAL
THEM SAID THE TEMPORARY
AUTHORITY TO ALLOW PARAMEDICS TO
ADMINISTER DOSES OF VACCINE.
THAT DECLARATION CAME IN THE
EARLY FALL.
AFTER.
IT WAS FIRST IDENTIFIED IS NOW
BREAK IN MARCH THAT LENGTH OF
TIME BETWEEN THAT DECORATE THE
IDENTIFICATION AND DECLARATION
COULD HAVE BEEN.
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF LIMITING
THE LOSS OF LIFE AND SPECIALIST
DISEASE.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
MANY THINGS AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW COULD HELPUS TO
DETERMINE IF THE ACTIONS BY ALL
PARTIES WERE CONSISTENT WITH
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. AND BASS
PRACTICES OF THE MANAGEMENT OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE OUTBREAK
ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND OF THE VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES AT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE WERE SPENT IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS POSSIBLE.
DECISIONS THE POWER WATCH
SIDEWALKS ERECT TENTS NEED TO BE
REVIEWED WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
WHETHER OR NOT THESE
EXPENDITURES WERE WERE ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVE IN LIMITING THE.
SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE THE
COUNTY REPORT JUST LAST WEEK
THAT THEY HAVE NOW AT THIS POINT
SPENT OVER TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON IN RESPONDING TO THIS
OUTBREAK.
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
VIEWS OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
HAVE UNDER THEIR VIEWS OF THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY HAVE
UNDERGONE OF A CONTINUE TO
UNDERGO. BUT THIS OUTBREAK HAS
SPREAD TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE THE STATE DECLARED AS IN A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. AYE AND WE
NEED AN INDEPENDENT REVIEW
SEPARATE FROM THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED HERE. I'D HOW CAN BE
PREVENTED GOING FORWARD I
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION IS
REQUEST I DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES
ON THIS BOTTOMS CHEN.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
BUT RIGHT NOW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I'M NANCY WHETHER SOME PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE FOR THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO AND WAS.
ACTIVE IN THE NORTH COASTAL
OCEAN SIDE REGION FOR DOING THE
VACCINATION
AND.
ATTENDING TO THE OUTBREAK CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW. OKAY.
.
THE THE GREATEST CONCERN IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE WAS THAT OF
NO SAFETY PROTOCOL IN PLACE.
EVEN AS THE OUTBREAK CAME TO AN
END. IN MARCH OR APRIL.
GOING OUT INTO THE ENCAMPMENTS
UNACCOMPANIED BY ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR AGENCY TO PROTECT
THE NURSES WAS PIE THE MOST
GLARING OF.
HOME IMPROPRIETIES THERE WERE NO
SENTINEL EVENTS IN OUR OFFICE
I'M SURE THEIR STORIES THAT
COULD BE TOLD.
WE DID HAVE SOME SOME.
INTERESTING INTERACTIONS WITH
THEM.
THE NORTH COUNTY HOMELESS AND
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS.
VERY KIND TO INFORM US AS TO THE
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHIC OF THE
NORTH COUNTY HOMELESS POPULATION.
VERSES AND THE CENTER CITY
HOMELESS.
SOME OF THOSE CHARACTERISTICS
ARE BECAUSE OF THE.
PREVALENCE OF MATH HOUSES AND
GROWING. HOMES GROWING HOUSES IN
NORTH COUNTY MOST OF THE
HOMELESS ARE ARMED AND HOW.
FELONY RECORDS FOR EITHER ARM
PROPERTY ROBBERY OR ASSAULT.
THE A RATIO OF GROW HOUSES IN
NORTH COUNTY TO SAN DIEGO IS.
MARGINALLY HIGHER BUT THE
AMOUNT OF VIOLENT CRIMES AND
ROBBING OR.
CAUSING DISRUPTIONS TO THOSE TO
THOSE FACILITIES IS MUCH HIGHER.
NONE OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT WE WENT OUT WITH COULD
BELIEVE THAT WE WERE BEING SENT
OUT WITHOUT ANY KIND OF.
GUARD OR PRESENCE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE WENT OUT OF MANY TIMES WITH
ANCILLARY AGENCIES FOR MEDI CAL
TO. ENROLL THE HOMELESS IN
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ENTITLED TO.
AND EVEN THOSE ARE STAFF MEMBERS
WERE FITTED WITH SADDAM
BALLISTIC GARMENTS TO PROTECT
THEM IN CASE OF ANY KIND OF
VIOLENT INTERACTION. THE NURSES
WENT OUT AND ARE SCRUBS
CARRYING OUR KIDS FULL OF
SYRINGES AND.
MEDICAL SUPPLIES MA'AM I CAN
ASK YOU TO WRAP UP.
YES I AM I THINK SAFETY PROTOCOL
FOR THE COUNTY IS THE LEAST THAT
WE CAN EXPECT IN ORDER TO HAVE
SOME SURE A CERTAINTY AND
ASSURANCE THAT. ITEM WE WON'T BE.
PLACED IN HARM'S WAY REGARDLESS
OF THE OUTBREAK AND THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE HEPATITIS A
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JIM
GROW SOME HALF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO.
THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER THE COUNTY WANT TO THANK
YOU PERSONALLY FOR THE REQUEST
YOU MADE FOR THE COUNTY TO
APPEAR AND SPEAK ON THIS THANK
OKAY I OR ANSWER ANY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUDIT REQUEST.
NO AND I OKAY HE RESPONDING
TALKING. HOLD ON A MINUTE LET'S
OUR THANK YOU.
STATE AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA INDICATED
THIS WOULD BE LOOKING AT THE
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK IN IN THE
SAN DIEGO AREA. AND WE HAVE TWO
MAJOR OBJECTIVES ONE IS FOCUSING
ON THE COUNTY'S RESPONSE THE
OTHER ONE IS FOCUSING ON THE
CITY'S RESPONSE SIMILAR OUR
REQUIREMENTS I'M GONNA GO OVER
THOSE AS A WHOLE SO I DON'T.
TAKE UP TOO MUCH TIME.
CERTAINLY ASKING US.
WHETHER IT'S THE CITY OR THE
COUNTIES RESPONSE WHAT CRITERIA
DID THEY USE TO DETERMINE THE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CASES
HOW DID THEY IDENTIFY. BASICALLY
CONTAIN AND TREAT OUR
INDIVIDUALS A.
DURING THE OF HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK DID THEY FOLLOW
ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS AND ANY
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS AND AGAIN
WILL BE DOING THIS BOTH WITH
RESPECT TO THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY. THE OTHER TWO OBJECTIVES
AGAIN FOR BOTH IS COMMUNICATION
WITH LOCAL MEDICAL DIRECTORS ARE
WITH RESPECT TO LOCATION DATA
WHERE THESE CASES BEING
IDENTIFIED IN WHAT LOCATIONS.
POWER THEY COORDINATING WITH THE
MEDICAL DIRECTORS IN THE LOCAL
THE LOCAL REGIONS AND THEN WHAT
LESSONS HAVE THEY LEARNED FROM
THIS SITUATION.
WHAT PROTOCOLS HAVE THEY
PERHAPS MODIFIED OR STEPS THEY
PUT IN PLACE TO PREVENT A
SIMILAR TYPE OF OUTBREAK FROM
OCCURRING IN AN EXPANDING?
IN THE SAN DIEGO REGION AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE LAST
TWO OBJECTIVES.
AS AS THE MEMBER INDICATED IS
REALLY LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
EXPENDITURES ARE SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT CONTRACTS THAT WERE
APPROVED.
BY THE CITY TO RESPOND TO THIS
PARTICULAR EMERGENCY AND DID
THOSE PROCESSES DIFFER FROM
TYPICAL CONTRACTS THAT ARE
AWARDED BY THE CITY.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THOSE THE
CITY APPROVED THOSE FOLLOWING
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS AND SPECIFIC
POLICIES AND THEN THE LAST
OBJECTIVE IS REALLY AGAIN
ANOTHER LESSONS LEARNED AS FAR
AS.
WHETHER THE COUNTY.
COULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING
SOONER.
EARLIER IN MARCH AS AS THE
MEMBER INDICATED RATHER THAN.
THIS EMERGENCY BEING DECLARED
AND IN SEPTEMBER OF OF SEVENTEEN.
THE BUDGET FOR THE AUDIT
RELATIVELY SMALL TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED HOURS THAT WOULD TAKE MY
STAFF'S TIME ABOUT FIVE MONTHS
TO COMPLETE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW BEFORE
WE. PROCEED TO THE RESPONDING
AGENCIES LIKE I THOUGHT I HEARD
THAT.
THAT I REQUESTED THE YOU TO
TESTIFY I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT I DID NOT THAT. WE RISEN
HAVE THIS ON CONSENT OF BUT
THROUGH YOUR REQUEST THROUGH THE
VICE YEAR. WE HAVE PULLED FROM
THE CONSENT AND NOW YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND.
WELL I'M SORRY.
THE LETTER ACTUALLY.
COME FROM GLORIA.
AND IN TERMS OF HIS REQUEST AND
THEN A LETTER TO THE CHAU FROM.
THIS COMMITTEE ASKING
FOR ATTENDANCE.
BOB I THINK THAT. WE WERE
UNDERSTOOD THAT YOU WANTED A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COUNTY
HERE. UP THEREFORE WE WERE
SURPRISED WAS I CONSENT BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR ASSISTANCE AND.
HAVING THE MATTER HEARD.
IF THE COUNTY.
.
RESPONSE TO THE HAVE A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS QUICKLY BECAME ITS
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
WE BELIEVE WE WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN CONTAINING THE OUT BREAK
THROUGH A VARIETY OF
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES.
YEAH I INCLUDING IMMUNIZING OVER
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS BOTH COUNTY WORKERS
AND COUNTY RESIDENTS.
THAT BEING SAID.
AS I'M SURE MR GLORIA WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE.
ADDRESSING AN OUTBREAK OF THIS
TYPE.
AMONG THE HOMELESS POPULATION
IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT A SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT TO.
TODAY ABOUT.
THE POTENTIAL FOR VIOLENCE LIKE.
ARE LESS SURE OF THAT.
OBVIOUSLY THIS LEGISLATURE
STRUGGLING WITH THE GENERAL
ISSUE OF HOW DO WE ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES.
INCLUDING A HEALTH ISSUES AND
I'LL ADD HOUSING ISSUES IN THE
LIKE SO THIS IS NOTHING NEW THAT
THESE ARE NOT EASY ISSUES.
I'D TO GRAPPLE WITH.
.
I I THINK THAT.
THE COUNTY REALLY BELIEVES THAT
IT IS A LESSON TO LEARN. AYE IN
THAT THIS WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
SITUATION.
THEY'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
CITY.
THERE PROBABLY WAS SOME
DUPLICATION OF OF EFFORT BUT A
BOLT WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THE SITUATION AS QUICKLY AS THEY
COULD.
I THINK THAT THE AFTER ACTION
REPORT THAT ALL OF YOU RECEIVED
A LINK TO THAT WAS PREPARED BY
THE COUNTY ILLUSTRATES.
THEIR EFFORTS IN GREAT DETAIL
ILLUSTRATES THE PROGRESS.
AND ALSO RAISES ISSUES OF ITS
OWN ABOUT ITS PERFORMANCE AND
HOW IT CAN IMPROVE.
BOB BUT I THINK ALSO.
IT HAS TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT.
ARE.
THE COUNTY IS NOT THE ONLY ONE
PROVIDING A REPORT.
THE. AYE CIVIL GRAND JURY IN SAN
DIEGO IS ABOUT TO ISSUE ITS OWN
REPORT.
ON.
THIS CRISIS AND THE RESPONSE
THERE TOO. UP WE KNOW HOW
THOROUGH THE AUDITOR IS AND WE
ASSUME THE AUDITOR WILL IN FACT
LOOK AT BOTH ARE AFTER ACTION
REPORT. AND THE GRAND JURY
REPORT WHICH IS AN INDEPENDENT
REPORT.
AND FROM THAT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GLEAN ARE A LOT OF INFORMATION
WILL HELP ANSWER MISTER GLORIOUS
QUESTIONS.
AND PERHAPS REDUCE THE COST OF
THE AUDIT AND ASK YOU YABBA
FINALLY WE WE SENT SOME
SKEPTICISM REGARDING THE COUNTY
SPOTS A CRISIS.
THE FACT IS THE COUNTY HAS BEEN
LAUDED NATIONALLY FOR ITS
EFFORTS AS I SAID WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LEARN FROM THIS.
BUT WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO
ASSUME THAT THIS WASN'T THE MOST
ROBUST EFFORT TO COMPLY WITH ALL
OF ITS OBLIGATIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND WE
ALSO APPRECIATE.
THE TIME TO GET TO.
PROVIDERS LITTLE RESPONSE WE
JOIN OUR COUNTY PARTNER.
AND.
NOT OBJECTING TO THIS AUDIT
WHATSOEVER.
BUT ALSO NOTING.
NOT ONLY THE.
THE AFTER ACTION REPORT THAT
THE COUNTY PREPARED THAT WE
THINK IS A FAIR ASSESSMENT.
OF OF BOTH BY THE CITY AND
COUNTY ACTIONS AND AND ROOMS FOR
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
WE IT'S A TWO HUNDRED PAGE
REPORT IT'S IT'S A.
IT'S THOROUGH WE TOO ARE
PROVIDING OUR OWN OUR ASSESSMENT
THAT.
IS EXPECTED TO BE ABOUT
RELEASED.
DURING THE SUMMER SO WE WOULD
COMMAND THE AUTHOR OF THE
AUDITOR ONTO THAT REPORT AND
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH WITH
HER AND HER STAFF.
WHEN WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND THEN ALSO JUST TO ECHO THE
COUNTY'S COMMENTS.
I THINK THAT ANYONE WHO.
.
PRY NATIONWIDE KNEW HOW SERIOUS.
THE EPIDEMIC WAS IN SAN DIEGO
HOW SERIOUSLY WE TOOK IT.
.
CITIES DON'T TYPICALLY HAVE
HEALTH OFFICERS THAT'S NOT WHAT
THAT'S JUST NOT UP AT A CITY
FUNCTION THAT MOST CITIES HAVE.
AND SO WE DID WE IT TOOK US.
YOU KNOW A A HERCULEAN EFFORT
TO RAMP UP AND REALLY JOIN WITH
OUR PARTNERS NOT JUST AT THE
COUNTY BUT AT THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO REALLY
ADDRESS THIS SO WE FEEL QUITE
PROUD OF OF.
OF WHAT WE DID KNOWING FULL
WELL THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM IT
AND PROBABLY A WHOLE LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE CAN LEARN FROM IT.
BUT WE ABOUT WELCOME THE
AUDITOR TO SUNNY SAN DIEGO WITH
OUR CLEAN STREETS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER ON
THE ON IT THINKING HER THANKS
VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS BAKER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I M..
I HAVE THE.
FIRST OF ALL A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR AND THAT IS BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE SOUNDS LIKE NOW
THERE'S THIS THE AFTER ACTION
REPORT.
CITIES GOT ITS OWN ANALYSIS
THEY'RE DOING.
THE CIVIL GRAND JURY AND THEN
THERE IS I BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FOR THE COUNTY.
LATER THIS SUMMER THAT'S ISSUING
A REPORT.
AND.
AYE I'M GENTLE INCLINE TO
SUPPORT THE ODD BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY WANT THOUGH. THAT WATER
LESSONS LEARNED FOR ALL OF US TO
GET IN ITS.
FRANKLY SUMMIT ADMINISTRATIVELY
EASIER IF WE GET FROM ONE
INDEPENDENT SOURCE. BUT AND I'M
LOOKING AT THAT TOWARDS THE BAY
AREA WHERE THIS COULD HAVE
SPREAD A WE HAVE WE HAVE A
TRANSIT SYSTEM IN THE BAY AREA
THAT IS JUST.
REALLY A MAJOR SANITATION
PROBLEM AND TOP OF HOMELESSNESS
AND OTHER ISSUES SO I I'M I'M
INCLINED TO SUPPORT IT BUT WHEN
I HEAR THERE ARE FOUR OTHER
STUDIES AND REPORTS GOING ON.
BEFORE WE SET THE AUDITOR TO DO
IT AND WHEN THE AUDITOR GOES
INTO COUNTY AND CITY THEY ARE
GOING TO BE.
THE OFFICE IS GOING TO BE NEED
TO INTERACT WITH I WANNA SEE
DISTRACT LIKE IT'S A BAD THING
WHICH CAN TAKE. CITY AND COUNTY
TIME.
AS YOU PUT HAVE YOU PUT THOUGHT
TO.
THE TIMING OF THIS BEING
NECESSARY. MAY BE.
POSTPONING UNTIL THE OTHER FOUR
REPORTS COME OUT ADD TO SEE
WHAT'S THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO
UTILIZE OUR OUR RESOURCES ON
THIS.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION IS
BAKER AND I WOULD NOTE THAT BOTH
THE CITY AND COUNTY ARE NOT
OBJECTING TO THIS PARTICULAR
REQUEST TODAY.
AND I SHARE AND I'M APPRECIATE
YOU UNDERSTANDING THE NEED FOR
THE AUDIT BECAUSE YES THIS COULD
HAPPEN YOUR DISTRICT TO.
AND AS A CONSEQUENCE WE SHOULD
ARMY WAS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE YOU AMY KNEW I REQUEST
BY THE WAY FOR THE NEXT HEARING
WE HAVE SAID THANK YOU.
SO WITH REGARD TO TIMING OF
THIS PARTICULAR AUDIT A MISTAKE
I HAVE TO BE REALLY HONEST WITH
YOU DURING THE MIDST OF THIS
CRISIS THERE WAS A LOT OF FINGER
POINTING THAT HAPPENED. AND WE
ALL MADE AGREEMENT AT THE TIME
TO SORT OF SET THAT STUFF ASIDE
AND RESPOND TO THIS IS
GRASSLEY'S POSSIBLE. AND THEN
COME BACK TO IT AFTER THAT
MARKETS HE HAS PASSED
EMERGENCY HAS PASSED THE
DECLARATION HAS BEEN REMOVED.
AND AFTER ACTIONS ARE HAPPENING
BUT I THINK PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF WAS MISS A TOP WAS
MENTIONING THE CITY THE CITY
DOESN'T HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER.
THERE BEEN A MULTITUDE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT I THINK REALLY.
MAKE THE STATE'S AUDITING OF
THIS A VERY IMPORTANT UM THE IN
THE STATE IS A THIRD PARTY
INDEPENDENT REVIEWER OF THIS IT
IS NOT EITHER THE ACTORS THAT
WERE INVOLVED THE IMMEDIATE.
RESPONSE AND I THINK AS A RESULT
HAS ADDED A. HEIGHTENED
CREDIBILITY THAT CAN HELP REALLY
AGAIN BRING OUT THE LESSONS
LEARNED THAT ARE IMPORTANT FROM
THIS AND REALLY SPEAK.
FOR WHAT I THINK MAY BE A NEW
NORMAL GOING FORWARD BUT ANYWAY
I THINK THAT THE VALUE HERE IS A
THIRD PARTY THAT WAS NOT
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE DAY TO
DAY RESPONSE FOR WHICH FOR
QUESTIONING. AND I THINK THAT
KIND OF IMPARTIALITY.
IS VALUABLE THANK YOU AND THEN
IT DOES BRING ME TO MY NEXT
QUESTION THE OTTERS HIS HOW CAN
IT WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE BEING
ABLE TO STRUCTURE.
THAT HOW YOU DEPLOY YOUR
RESOURCES THE TIMING OF HOW YOU
DO THIS GIVEN THAT THERE ARE ME
I WOULD REALLY WANT YOU HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF ALL THESE OTHER
REPORTS RATHER THAN ON A
PARALLEL TRACK. KNOWING THAT ONE
IS EXPECTED OUT IN JULY JUST A
COUPLE MONTHS FROM NOW THINK THE
CITY MENTION THEY'RE DOING WIND
IT'S COMING SEPTEMBER. SUMMER
SKEWS ME AM.
IS IT WITHOUT WANTING TO DELAY
BECAUSE I DO WANT TO SEE THE
RESULTS OF THIS I I APPRECIATE
THE POINT MISTER COLOR MAKES
THAT THIS IS A. AN INDEPENDENT
THE DIDN'T HAVE A.
THE A FINGER POINTED OUT AT THE
STATE OR THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
BUT HOW WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE.
THE BEST WAY TO DEPLOY YOUR
RESOURCES GIVEN THE.
OTHER REPORTS ARE COMING OUT.
RIGHT THANK YOU MS BAKER UP WE
ABSOLUTELY WOULD WANT TO TIME
OUR WORK NOT BASED ON SOME OF
THESE REPORTS IT SOUNDS LIKE
THIS AFTER ACTION REPORTS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE THAT'S ALREADY OUT
THERE WHAT STAFF WOULD START
WITH. IS LOOKING AT THAT WE WE
ALSO HAVE AN AUDIT WE ARE
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING. OFFER
CENTER KOISO ON PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES AND THE STAFFING AND ONE
OF THE ELEMENTS HE ASKED US TO
LOOK AT WITH STAFFING RELATED TO
THE HAVE BAY OUTBREAK SO WE HAVE
SOME INFORMATION THAT WE'VE
CLEAN FROM THAT AUDIT.
BUT CERTAINLY AN AUDIT OR AT A
REPORT THAT'S COMING OUT IN JULY
THAT'S A COUPLE MONTHS FROM NOW
THAT IT IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT
ONCE IT COMES OUT. WE WOULD
CERTAINLY NOT WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT IF THERE'S
INFORMATION THAT'S IN DRAFT I
WOULD ASSUME WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT NOW.
THE CITY WOULD COOPERATE IN
HAVE.
I THINK WE'VE GOTTEN THE
ASSURANCE FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVES HERE SO WE WOULD
WANT TO LOOK AT THAT INFORMATION
LOOK AT THE SUPPORT BEHIND IT SO
THAT WE ARE DUPLICATING EFFORT
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE BUT
LOOK AT IT FROM WITH A CRITICAL
EYE. SO ABSOLUTELY ANY OF THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE VERY HELPFUL
TO US AND HOPEFULLY TO THE
EXTENT WE CANRELY ON THAT
INFORMATION IT'LL CUT BACK THE
NUMBER OF HOURS WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN HOW MUCH THIS AUDIT
WILL COST I HOPE SO AND I THINK.
EVEN HAVING A CIVIL GRAND JURY
LOOKING AT THIS MEAN THEY'RE
FAIRLY INDEPENDENT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE OF EARLY
INDEPENDENT ENTITY THAT CAN TAKE
A LOOK AT IT SO I DON'T KNOW
WHEN THAT. IS TIMES WHEN THAT'S
COMING OUT BUT THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO TO LOOK AT AS WELL
WITHOUT REINVENTING. THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING OF JUST TWO
MORE QUICK ONES BAKER CAN I JUST
LOOK TWO BITS OF INFORMATION MY
UNDERSTAND IS THE THE THE GRAND
JURY REPORT IS.
THURSDAY I'M AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THE GRAND JURY.
HIS FUNDED HOUSE WITHIN THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THE AUTHOR HAS.
AVAILABLE NOR SOME OF THAT
SUBPOENA POWER TO SUBMIT THAT
I'M ACCESSING OF OF MORE
CONFIDENTIAL DOT.
THAT THAT MAY BE THINKING THAT
MAYBE THE CASE I I KNOW I'M HOW
WE'RE ALL VERY GRATEFUL FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO BE A
CIVIL GRANGER IT'S A THANKLESS
TASK AND AND IT DOES.
HAVE TO DO A LOT OF
INVESTIGATIVE WORK. AM I DO
WANNA ALSO THIS I GUESS IS FOR
THE AUDITOR BUT ALL THIS TO BE
MINDFUL OF WHEN A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS HAPPENS.
AND IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO DO BOTH
AFTER ACTION AND WHAT CAN WE DO
BETTER TO PREVENT IT AGAIN AND.
AND HAVE A BETTER RESPONSE IF
FUTURE THERE'S ALSO THE QUESTION
OF HINDSIGHT.
AND I I KNOW YOU CAN'T
INCORPORATE THAT INTO YOUR
REPORT I KNOW THAT WHATEVER PART
YOU HAVE I FOR ONE WILL BE
LOOKING THAT WERE VERY CAREFUL
NOT TO BE HAVING THE BENEFIT OF
HINDSIGHT THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE
DONE A CONTRACT THIS WAY. YOU
SHOULD HAVE USED THAT THE
RESOURCES THAT WAY BUT THIS WAS
A VERY TENSE TIME AND A MAJOR
PUBLIC HEALTH. ISSUE.
I THINK IT'S MORE OF A
STATEMENT THAN ANYTHING ELSE A
CAUTION FOR US THAT WE ARE JUST
GOING TO BE MINDFUL OF WHAT
HAPPENS IN HINDSIGHT WHEN
THERE'S BEEN AN AN URGENCY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S A
QUESTION BUT I DO HAVE ONE FOR
YOU.
MANY OF THE ISSUES. THAT I OR
QUESTIONS ARE RAISED IN THE
AUDIT. OF ALL GOOD ONES.
TO ME LOOK VERY MUCH DIRECTED SO
MUCH WHERE THE COUNTY WOULD
TRADITIONALLY BE AN AUTHORITY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS YOU SEE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF. OF MANY
SOCIAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE FOR
EITHER FUNDED BY THE STATE OR
SEPARATELY. AND LESS SO THE CITY
AND YET THE AUDIT DOES SEEM TO
HAVE SORT OF EQUAL I WAS EQUAL
TIME BUT IT WILL FOCUS ON THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY.
.
I I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE WAY THE AUDITOR LOOKS
AT THIS KNOWING THAT MOST
COUNTIES ARE NOT. ARE ARE THAT
MORE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL FOR
REGION AND NOT SO MUCH A CITY.
.
I CAN GIVE YOU JUST SORT OF SAY
HOW YOU MIGHT ALLOCATE YOUR
RESOURCES ON THAT OR.
MAKING SURE THAT WERE FOCUSED ON
WHERE IT'S FAIR I MEAN FRANKLY
THE CITY DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME
PUBLIC HEALTH RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AS AS A LONG TERM.
ESTABLISHED PROGRAM.
TO RESPOND TO A CRISIS LIKE
THIS.
THANK YOU MS BAKER. AT WITH ANY
AUDIT WHEN WE GET IN THERE THE
FIRST FEW WEEKS OF THE AUDIT
FIRST TWO WEEKS ESSENTIALLY
STAFFER GOING OUT SO THEY WOULD
BE DOWN IN SAN DIEGO MEETING
WITH CITY OFFICIALS MEETING WITH
COUNTY OFFICIALS. AND THEN THEY
WOULD COME BACK TO US AND SAY
YOU KNOW MOST OF THE EFFORT A
RESPONSIBILITY IS THAT COUNTY
LEVEL SO WE REALLY NEED TO SPEND
MOST OF OUR TIME. ON THOSE
PARTICULAR QUESTIONS THAT THE
MEMBER ASKED WE'RE GONNA DO SOME
WORK AT THE CITY BUT NOT AS MUCH
WE'RE GONNA PARROT BACK SO WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO COURSE CORRECT
DURING THE COURSE OF THE AUDIT
USUALLY THE FIRST TWO OR THREE
WEEKS SEVEN ON IT. IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE STAFFER OUT IN
THE PARTICULAR ENTITY IN THIS
CASE DOWN IN SAN DIEGO ARE
TALKING TO OFFICIALS LOOKING AT
THE AFTER ACTION REPORT.
HOPEFULLY LOOKING AT SOME DRAFT
INFORMATION IF THE GRAND JURY
REPORT IS OUT A LOOKING AT THAT
MAY BE TALKING WITH SOME OF THE
YEAH.
MEMBERS WHO SERVED ON THE GRAND
JURY BUT WE ARE CERTAINLY ABLE
TO ADJUST THE AMOUNT OF EFFORT
WE PUT.
INTO SPECIFIC OBJECTIVES BASED
ON WHAT STAFF LEARNED DURING THE
FIRST FEW WEEKS OF AN AUDIT OKAY
AND THE BE VERY HELPFUL BECAUSE
I I KNOW THAT.
WE CAN DIRECT EVERY DETAIL THAT
HOW YOU DO THIS BUT JUST BE
MINDFUL AS YOU GO ALONG. WHERE
WHO WHO IS ULTIMATELY MORE
RESPONSIBLE WHO HAS THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT I WILL LOOK
FOR TO THE REPORT? KNOWING THAT
HINDSIGHT IS TWENTY TWENTY AND
AND HOPE THAT I WILL NEVER HAVE
TO ASK FOR AN AUDIT OF SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IN THE BAY AREA.
BECAUSE WILL LEARN FROM THIS TO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
SOME OF HER WORK JUST A COMMENT
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I THINK IT'S.
I I UNDERSTAND THAT WERE ON THE
SPEAKERS COMING FROM.
FOR HER PERSPECTIVE BUT I'LL
TELL YOU FROM SOMEONE WHO JUST
EXPERIENCED A PRETTY MAJOR
NATURAL DISASTER IN MY DISTRICT.
WE'RE LOOKING REALLY CLOSELY AT
EVERYTHING AT THE CITY LEVEL AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL AROUND
EMERGENCY WARNINGS AND AND
THINGS THAT HAPPEN THERE SO SO
WE'RE DOING THIS IN THE SPIRIT
OF HOW DO WE. ENSURE THAT IN THE
FUTURE WE DO THE VERY BEST WE
CAN FOR EVERYONE AND I KNOW
THAT'S THE SPIRIT IN WHICH YOU
BRING THIS FOR AND I THINK YOU
FOR THAT AND I LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING SADDAM.
TAKING IN THE FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM
ANYONE IN THE.
AUDIENCE LIKE TO COMMENT.
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA FOR.
THE REQUEST.
DIED.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE.
.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
ABOUT.
THE THE AFTER REPORT IN THE
GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION.
.
BUT.
WE ARE.
RESPECT YOU AND RESPECT THAT YOU
ARE FIGHTING FOR YEAR YOUR
DISTRICT IN MEAN AND ARE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS REQUEST DO YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS HUTTON
PROCEDURE SUPPORT AS CHAIRMAN
AND IT PUT IT ON CONSENT.
AND I WOULD JUST REMIND THE
COMMITTEE NEED TWENTY PEOPLE
DIED OF FROM THIS OUTBREAK.
AND WHILE I'M THEY WERE
HOMELESS.
THEIR LIVES ARE NO LESS
VALUABLE.
THAN ANYONE ELSE IN THE STATE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE EXTREME
HOUSE HOMELESS AND HOUSING
CRISIS WE HAVE IN THE STATE I
FEAR THAT THIS MAY HAPPEN AGAIN
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS STUDY
IT CLOSELY REPORT ON IT.
APPARENTLY I'M THE ONLY WAY I
CAN SEE IS DOING THAT WITH ANY
CREDIBILITY IS TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE OF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO HAVE A MOTION OKAY AND
MAKE THE MOTION.
MOTION BY RUBIO SECOND BY FULLER
THIRD BY THE WAY.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TASH ONE
ONE SIX OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO MANAGEMENT OF
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND
I VOTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY
CHANGE MERCY CHI AYE ACOSTA.
BAKER BAKER AYE NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I WEIGHED.
WOULD I.
SENATOR RAW.
ALLEN BELL CANNELLA. CANNELLA
AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
THE A RATE WE ARE SHORT TO
SENATE VOTES THE.
REQUESTED SOKOL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WOULD AND OR
SOME OF OUR WOULDN'T SARAH
CANNELLA. TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT.
OUR REQUESTS.
TO AUDIT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES RELATED TO
MEDI CAL CHILDREN'S ACCESS SOME
PREVENTIVE CARE.
DID YOU SAY THE COOL PEOPLE UP
THERE THAT SHE SAYS AND. HOW I
SEE IT?
ALRIGHT.
IT'S A VERY NICE MUG YOU HAVE
THERE ALTHOUGH IT WOULD ACTS OR
EQUAL TIME MISTER CHAIR FOR MY
TEAM.
THE UNIVERSITY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THAT PROUD TO PRESENT THIS
AUDIT ARTISTS ARE. ADDED TO
REQUEST BEFORE YOU.
MEDI CAL IS THE CORNERSTONE OF
HEALTH CARE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN WITH NEARLY THREE OUT
OF EVERY FIVE.
CHILDREN THE STATE BEING
COVERED UNDER MEDICARE.
MEDICARE PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE
BENEFITS TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE
INCLUDING REGULAR AND WELL CHILD
VISITS AND DEVELOPMENTAL AND
OTHER HEALTH SCREENINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY COMES ACCESS TO
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS CHILDREN
AND MEDI CAL PERFORM IN THE
LOWEST QUARTILE OF ALL STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAMS.
LIKEWISE IN REGARDS TO PERIODIC
CHILDHOOD SCREENINGS MEDICAL
PERFORMS BELOW THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR EACH AGE GROUP.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
VERIFYING ENFORCING AND
REPORTING THAT MEDI CAL DELIVERS
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES MOST MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
PROVIDE NON URGENT PRIMARY CARE
TO APPOINTMENTS WITHIN TEN DAYS.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
THAT THESE TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS ARE NOT BEING MET.
THE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
SECRET SHOPPER SURVEY OF MEDI
CAL PEDIATRIC APPOINTMENT
AVAILABILITY FOUND THAT ONLY ONE
THIRD OF ATTEMPTED CALLS FOR IN
PEDIATRIC WELL CHILD APPOINTMENT
RESULTED IN AN APPOINTMENT
WITHIN THE TEN DAY. TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARD INITIALLY ABOUT
FORTY PERCENT OF THE CALL
ATTEMPTS WERE UNABLE TO MAKE ANY
APPOINTMENT
DO TWO PROVIDERS.
TO TO KNOW PROVIDED FROM THE
PLAN'S PROVIDER LIST ACCEPTING
NEW MEDI CAL PATIENTS.
THE GOAL OF THIS PROPOSED AUDIT
IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW WELL THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS PROPELLING ITS
MANDATE AND EVALUATE HOW PLAY
HOW WELL PLANS ARE DOING IN
MEETING THE GOAL THAT CHILDREN
ENROLLED IN MEDICARE. RECEIVED A
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE AND
PREVENTIVE SERVICES SERVICES
THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR.
THROUGH THE AUDIT.
THROUGH THE SIDE IT WE CAN
OBTAIN VALUABLE INFORMATION
REGARDING CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE HEALTHCARE AND
IDENTITY. AND I DON'T.
AND IDENTIFY WHAT AREAS MAY
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FOCUS AND
INVESTMENT.
HERE TESTIFYING SUPPORT ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IS MICHAEL O'DAY A DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH POLICY FOR CHILDREN NOW.
EXACTLY WHAT GOOD MORNING GERMAN
HEART SURGEON MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE I'M MICHAEL DAY
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH POLICY
CHILDREN NOW AND ON BEHALF OF
SEVERAL OF OUR ADVOCACY PARTNERS
REPRESENTING HEALTH CONSUMERS.
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS I'M
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEDI CAL
CHILDREN'S ACCESS AUDIT.
MAKEUP PROVIDES COVERAGE FOR
ROUGHLY HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
KIDS MAKING IT THE KEY SOURCE OF
PREVENTIVE AND PRIMARY CARE FOR
UPWARDS OF FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION KIDS. AND MAKING IT THE
CORNERSTONE OF HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS IN THE STATE.
THIS OVERSIGHT AUDIT REQUESTED
BY DOCTOR WOULDN'T SENATOR
CANNELLA IS CRITICAL TO HELP
POLICY MAKERS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
UNDERSTAND HOW WELL CALIFORNIA
IS FULFILLING ITS MANDATE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN IN MEDI
CAL RECEIVE TIMELY ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE CARE WHICH THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO.
FOR FIFTY YEARS FEDERAL MEDICAID
LIES REQUIRED STATE MEDICAID
PROGRAMS TO ACTIVELY PROMOTE
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN UNDER
TWENTY ONE RECEIVED ALL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY CARE. UNDER
THE IMPORTANT EARLY PERIODIC DIE
SCREENING DIAGNOSTIC AND
TREATMENT BENEFIT EPS DUTY.
TODAY THESE INCLUDE THE
PEDIATRIC PREVENTIVE SERVICES
THAT ARE CLINICALLY RECOMMENDED
BY THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS BRIGHT FUTURES
PERIODICITY SCHEDULE AND
GUIDELINES.
THESE ROUTINE CHECKUPS AND WELL
CHILD VISITS WHICH INCLUDE
PREVENTIVE HEALTH SERVICES LIKE
IMMUNIZATIONS AND SCREENINGS OUR
KEEPER CHILDREN'S HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT AND ADD EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS.
AS THE LARGEST MEDICAID PROGRAM
IN THE COUNTRY MEDICAL SERVES
MORE CHILDREN THAN ANY OTHER
STATE BUT DATA SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND MOST
OTHER STATES IN TERMS OF
UTILIZATION. AND CHILD HEALTH
OUTCOMES
FOR EXAMPLE BASED ON TWENTY
SIXTEEN STANDARDIZED DATA
CALIFORNIA PERFORMS IN THE
LOWEST QUARTILE OF ALL STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAMS WHEN IT COMES
TO CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO PRIMARY
CARE.
MORE THINGS MAY BE MOVING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION THE RATE OF
YOUNG CHILDREN AGES THREE TO SIX
WITH A WELL CHILD VISIT HAS
CONSISTENTLY DECLINED OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS.
AND UNLIKE FORTY SIX OTHER
STATES THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES DOES NOT PUBLICLY
REPORT ON THE RATE OF WELL CHILD
VISITS FOR INFANTS OR FOR
ADOLESCENTS.
CHILDREN NEED TIMELY ACCESS TO
PEDIATRIC PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
TO RECEIVE THE SERVICES AND
SCREENINGS NEEDED FOR HEALTHY
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT IN LINE
WITH THE EP STT BENEFIT.
STATUTORY CONTRACTUAL STANDARDS
REQUIRE THAT CHILDREN MEDI CAL
CAN GET A NON URGENT PRIMARY
CARE POINT ME WITHIN TEN DAYS
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT NEW
FEDERAL MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
RULES WILL REQUIRE NEW TIMELY
ACCESS MONITORING PROCESS.
BEGINNING IN JULY OF THIS YEAR A
FUNCTION THAT IS NEW TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
HOWEVER IN THE ABSENCE OF ANY
CURRENT OFFICIALS STATED ON
COMPLIANCE WITH TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS. THE ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT MEDICAL
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES CAN AND DO
FACE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
FINING PEDIATRIC PAYMENTS WITHIN
TEN DAYS OR SOMETIMES AT ALL.
THE TROUBLING DATA OR LACK THERE
OF AROUND CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO
CARE RAISE QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA IS
FULFILLING ITS OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT MEDICAL CHILDREN ARE
RECEIVING TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE.
THIS AUDIT WILL HELP
STAKEHOLDERS A POLICYMAKERS
UNDERSTAND WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
DOING NOW AND SHOULD BE DOING TO
REMEDY THE REMEDY THESE
DEFICIENCIES TO IMPROVE
CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE
HEALTHCARE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF DR WOULDN'T
SENATOR CANNELLA IN REQUESTING
THIS AUDIT TO ENSURE CHILDREN'S
NEEDS ARE MET AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. CNN. STATE AUDITOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD INDICATED
THIS WOULD BE AN AUDIT
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
REALLY FOCUSING ON PREVENTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN.
FIRST LOOKING AT THE EFFORTS
THAT HEALTH CARE SERVICES AYE
HAS MADE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN ARE ARE BEING
PROVIDED A RECEIVING PREVENTIVE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. ARE WHETHER
OR NOT HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS
MONITORING AND ENFORCING THE
TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS OFF FOR
PEDIATRIC PREVENTIVE CARE
APPOINTMENTS ALSO LOOKING AT.
CONTRACT LANGUAGE AND MAKING
SURE THAT GUIDANCE THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS PROVIDING.
.
ENSURES THAT PLANS UNDERSTAND OR
PROVIDERS UNDERSTAND THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR TIMELY ACCESS.
AND DELIVERY OF PREVENTIVE CARE
SERVICES ALSO AGAIN WHAT IS
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DOING TO
OVERSEE AND MONITOR.
THAT PARTICULAR INFORMATION
ALSO THAT TWO MEMBERS OF CENTER
CANNELLA AS WELL HAVE ASKED US
TO LOOK AT INCENTIVES OR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT.
PROGRAMS THAT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OPERATES.
AND HOW DOES HAVE A LEAD TO ANY
ADDRESS ANY DEFICIENCIES WITH
RESPECT TO NOT ONLY ACCESS TO
CARE BUT UTILIZATION AS AS HIS
WITNESS INDICATED. ALSO A COUPLE
OF ISSUES THAT THEY'VE ASKED US
TO LOOK AT SPECIFICALLY OFFER
FAMILIES THAT.
SPEAK A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE THAN
ENGLISH OUT EITHER THE CHILD OR
THE PARENTS OUT WHAT POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES ARE THEY IN DOING
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE FAMILIES
ARE RECEIVING THE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES IN PARTICULAR FOR THE
CHILDREN. AND THEN.
WHAT HEALTH CARE SERVICES IS
DOING TO MODERN MITIGATE ANY
DISPARITIES WITH RESPECT TO
ETHNICITY AND RACE AGAIN WITH
RESPECT TO ACCESS TO CARE AND
UTILIZATION? AND THEN THE FINAL.
ISSUES ASKING US TO LOOK AT
BEST PRACTICES OUT THERE ARE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE THINGS THAT THE STATE CAN BE
DOING TO STRENGTHEN ACCESS TO
CARE AND UTILIZATION. AND THEN
FINALLY TO LOOK TO DETERMINE
WHAT HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS
DONE TO PREPARE FOR THE UPCOMING
CHANGES ARE IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM I WITH RESPECT AGAIN TO
P. ACTOR CARE ACCESS UTILIZATION.
THE AUDITS BUDGETED ABOUT TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED HOURS SO AN AUDIT OF
THAT SIZE WILL TAKE US A LITTLE
OVER SIX MONTHS TO COMPLETE
STAFF TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
FORGOT TO ASK THE SERVER
CANNELLA WHICH YOU WOULDN'T DO
YOU HAVE ANY STATEMENT IT HAS A
COVERT QUESTOR AB APPRECIATE
BEING A CO AUTHOR DOCTOR WHAT
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
AREA WITH THE DENTAL PROGRAM AND
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD LOOK.
THE PROGRAM IN ITS ENTIRETY MEAN
THESE KIDS RELY ON THIS AND I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE DOING THE BEST THEY
CANCEL. APPRECIATE UP TO SPEED
ALRIGHT THANK YOU A I SEE.
LIVE SECOND IRATE AG.
DON'T KNOW WHY THIS WASN'T ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR GIVEN THE.
BIPARTISAN REQUEST YOUR VITA.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE FROM THE
AFFECTED AGENCY HERE.
PLEASE COME FOR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS.
AS NOTED BEFORE ON THE AMERICAN
YES AND.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
XENA ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC.
PLEASE COME FOR.
HI I AM CHRISTIAN NO GOLDEN
TESTED WITH THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND WE STAND UP.
PARTNERSHIP HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE.
CHILDREN NOW IN THE COALITION
FOR CHILDREN'S COVERAGE AND
STAND STRONG SUPPORT AND THANK
THEM MEMBERS OF THE AUTHOR OF
THIS LETTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD WHICH
LIFE CLOSED YES A PROVIDE LIKE
THE SAM HONORED TO BE JOINED BY
SENATOR CANNELLA IN THIS AS A AS
MY JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS. A BIT
ALSO JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE YOU
KNOW THAT WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT WHEN I COME FROM OF A
PROFESSION THAT THAT IS FOCUSED
ON PREVENTION. VALUE YOU YOU
INTERVENE EARLY YOU PROVIDE
BASIC PREVENTIVE CARE SUCH YOU
KNOW HAVE MORE CATASTROPHIC MORE
EXPENSIVE COSTS INCURRED LATER
ON. IT'S REALLY DISTURBING THAT
FOR FOR WHATEVER REASON IT
APPEARS THAT CHILDREN ARE NOT
GETTING ACCESS TO THIS
PREVENTIVE CARE. AND THAT IS
GOING TO.
HAS TO LEAD TO HIGHER COSTS ON
THE OTHER AND SO WE'VE GOT TO
FIND A WAY TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THIS IS HAPPENING AND HOW WE CAN
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE SAKE
OF OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WAVE MOTION AND SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
ONE ONE THAT APARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES OVERSIGHT OF
CHILDREN AND MEDI CAL ACCESS TO
CARE AND PREVENTIVE SERVICES.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS IN
AYE VOTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY
TEAM PER CITY AYE ACOSTA AYE.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE IS
ARYAN.
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I. BLADE. WOULD I.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN BELL.
CANNELLA. CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
RIGHT THE WE TO SENATE VOTES.
SO THE ITEMS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT NOW WE ARE.
.
REACHING ARE HIGH RISK LOCAL
AUDIT.
REQUESTS.
LIKE TO START WITH THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO AS I SUSPECT THERE
MAY BE PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE.
ON THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO ITEM.
AND THAT IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
TWELVE AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH
EIGHT OH TO.
THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO.
STATE LIKE TO TURN OVER TO THE
STATE AUDITOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS.
WERE REQUESTING A THORNY TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO.
AS YOU ARE UNSURE WHERE WE HAVE
A LOCAL HIGH RISK PROGRAM WHERE
WE USE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION PRIMARILY
INFORMATION THAT'S REPORTED UP
TO THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
ALSO LOOKING AT GRAND JURY
REPORTS ANY OTHER UP.
PUBLIC OUR INFORMATION AND SOME
CASES IT'S MEDIA INFORMATION BUT
BASED ON THE ANALYSIS THAT MY
STAFF DID OF THE FINANCIAL OUR
RECORDS FOR THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO WE HAD SOME PRETTY
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR.
FINANCIAL CONDITION.
THEY'RE FORECASTING LOOKING AT
THEIR BUDGETING PRACTICES.
AND AND HAVING GONE THROUGH
THAT ANALYSIS.
WE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
BRING THIS AUDIT REQUEST
TO THE COMMITTEE SO I'LL QUICKLY
STEPPED THROUGH THE THE SCOPE
AND OBJECTIVES ARE AND LOOKING
AT THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO ONE
ISSUE THAT WE WANT. PICTURE.
OPERATION. OF THEIR VARIOUS
BUSINESS ACTIVITIES THAT.
SEVERAL ACTIVITY OF BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES ENTERPRISES. TRANSIT
AUTHORITY THEIR WATER.
.
DISTRICT AND THE COUGH COURSE
WHERE THEY'RE LOSING MONEY ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS IN HAVING TO BE.
USING FUNDS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND THE GENERAL FUND IS LOANING.
DOLLARS TO THESE PARTICULAR
ACTIVITIES IN THIS IS BEEN
HAPPENING OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL YEARS SO A ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE WANT TO TRY TO
ENGAGE WITH THE CITY IS. HOW ARE
THEY DEALING WITH THESE INTER
FUND DAHLE LOANS?
WHAT IS THEIR FUTURE PLANS TO
TRY TO MITIGATE OR REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF?
DOLLARS THAT NEED TO BE
BORROWED FROM THE GENERAL FUND
THEY ALSO HAVE SOME IN
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES RELATED TO
THEIR THEIR WATER UTILITY DO
THEY HAVE PLANS FOR ADDRESSING
THAT IN THE LONG TERM.
I AM LOOKING AT THEIR BUDGETING
PRACTICES.
WE REALLY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROJECTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO REVENUE THEY HAVE ONE
HOTEL WHERE THEY'VE HAD.
HIGH PROJECTIONS AS FAR AS
REVENUE BUT THOSE HAVE NOT BEEN
REALIZED NOW THEIR PROJECTIONS
FOR REVENUE.
HOTEL THAT'S UNDER CONSTRUCTION
ARE ALSO SIGNIFICANT BUT BASED
ON THE HISTORY OF THE EXISTING
HOTEL WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THAT REVENUE WILL
ACTUALLY BE REALIZED AND IF IT
ISN'T REALIZE WHAT WILL
MONTEBELLO INTENDED TO. A TO
ADDRESS THAT SITUATION.
UNDER OUR HIGH RISK PROGRAM WE
CURRENTLY CURRENTLY IN OUR
REGULATIONS HAVE OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT ASSESSING FINANCIAL
CONDITION AND THE CITY'S ABILITY
ANY CITY'S ABILITY TO PAY.
LOCATIONS BOTH ON A SHORT TERM
BASIS AND A LONG TERM BASIS WE
ALSO LOOK AT AUDITS THAT HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF AUTHORITY TO
GO INTO CITIES. THE LAST TIME
THEY WENT INTO THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN SO WE WOULD WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE MADE TO SEE
WHAT MONTEBELLO HAS DONE TO.
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE THERE WERE CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
INTERNAL PATROLS AT CETERA. AND
THEN THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS
ALSO REYES RELATED TO
CONTRACTING PRACTICES FATHER
PROCUREMENT POLICIES ARE THEY
GETTING THE BEST VALUE AGAIN ARE
THEY.
BEING FISCAL STEWARDS OF.
THE FINANCES FOR THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO WE BUDGETED THIS
AUDIT ABOUT SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS AS I SAID WE'VE ALREADY
DONE SOME PRELIMINARY WORK.
SO WE DON'T THINK THIS SIDE IT
WILL TAKE US MORE THAN OF ABOUT
THREE FOR THREE TO FOUR MONTHS
TO COMPLETE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE.
REPRESENT FOR THE CITY MODEL
MONTEBELLO TO COMPORT.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS A COMMITTEE. OF MY
NAME IS ANDREW PASS SPENT I AM
THE ACTING CITY MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF MONTEBELLO.
PUT THINGS SCHOOL BUT IN
PERSPECTIVE AS YOU MAY RECALL.
I SPOKE TO SOME OF YOU BACK IN
JANUARY. OF I WAS FAIRLY NEW TO
THE JOB ONLY BEEN THERE A COUPLE
DAYS AND IN FACT.
.
MY FIRST DAY ON THE JOB I
RECEIVED A MESSAGE.
TO RETURN A CALL TO THE AUDITS
OFFICE AUDITOR'S OFFICE SO. I
REALLY HADN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO.
YEAH I GET A SENSE OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON DELAYED LAND.
SO WE ASK FOR EXTRA TIME AND I
DO WANNA THANK YOU FOR THAT
EXTRA TIME THAT WE DID RECEIVE.
A TO.
HELP US GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE. FINANCES AND THE BUDGET
SITUATION THE PHYSICAL
CHALLENGES OF FACING THE CITY.
OUR POSITION IS THAT WE DO NOT
OBJECT TO THE AUDIT.
A IN FACT I THINK OF THE AUDIBLE
A COMPLEMENT THE ACTIONS THAT
WERE TAKEN.
I THINK WILL HELP THE.
A ADDRESS.
CITIZENS CONCERNS OVER INDIA
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY THE
COMMUNITY. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE STATE AUDITOR HER STAFF
OF MOVING FORWARD ON THIS
AND SOME HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. IRATE
MOVE THE AUDIT.
BUT SINCE BEEN MADE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
BUT COURSE AND SO YOU WHAT THE
AUDIT.
YEAH WE HAVE NO OBJECTIONS TO
THE ARCTIC WE'RE LOSING WEIGHT
WAS ADDITIONAL TIME BECAUSE I
HAD JUST ARRIVED IN THE JOBLESS
I SAID JUST A COUPLE DAYS.
AND.
WE DID HAVE SOME STAFFING
CHALLENGES BECAUSE WE WERE SHORT
OF THOSE ACT THEN BUT NOW YOU
WHAT THE OUT TODAY YES. THAT'S
CORRECT WHAT WHY DID YOU. GET
AT.
DO
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T UNDERSTAND
A LOT ACTUALLY THAT WAS THE CITY
OF THAT WATER THAT OPEN OKAY
ISN'T THIS WAS NOT CONSENT THIS
WAS NOT ON CAN OKAY MIGHT WELL
HAVE IS OKAY.
YEAH NO I WE HAVE.
.
BEEN HEARING FROM.
CITIZENS OF MONTEBELLO AND I
BELIEVE THEY'RE HERE WHICH IS
WHY AND THAT IS SOME ARE
CONSENSO PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH
LIKE TO. COME FORWARD.
LINDA STRONG LONG TIME RESIDENT
OF MONTEBELLO. UP FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE MONOPOLE
BUDGET HAS ESSENTIALLY BEEN
BALANCED WITH ONE TIME MONEY.
REPEATED REPEATED SALES OF CITY.
A LONG TERM LEASES WITH A LOT OF
MONEY UP FRONT TO MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE THE CITY WAS SOMEHOW
FUNCTIONING AS A REGULAR CITY.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE ISSUES WITH CONTRACTS
NUMEROUS CONTRACTS WITH OUT
REQUESTS FOR PROPOSALS OTHERS
VERY SHORTENED REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL TIME LIMITS
MYSTERIOUSLY OVER AND OVER WE
JUST ONE BIT IS BEING MADE.
SO THERE'S LIKE THEY DON'T THEN
THEY REFUSE TO REBUILD IT TO PUT
IT OUT AGAIN. WE'VE HAD CONTRACT
EXTENSIONS YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR INCLUDED IN ONE
CASE A CONTRACT EXTENDED A DAY
AFTER IT HAD ALREADY EXPIRED.
CONTRACTS ARE VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE IN THIS CITY THERE APPEARS
TO BE ALL SORTS OF INSTANCES OF
FAVORITISM AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT
THE AUDIT WILL ADDRESS CONTRACTS
THANK YOU.
Q..
GOOD MORNING A MY NAME IS LINDA
NICHOLAS AND WITH A GROUP CALLED
MATCH MONTEBELLO ACTIVISTS TO
CLEAN HOUSE.
WE HAD A FORMER CELLS BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR CITY.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF
SPEAKING BEFORE YOU ARE ABLE
CHAIR COMMITTEE.
AGAIN AYE AYE A CONCUR WITH A
FOR THE FOR THAT THE.
PREVIOUS SPEAKER CONTRACTS ARE A
HUGE ISSUE FAMILY AND FRIENDS
ARE FAVORED.
ARE GIVING EXAMPLE.
THE HOTEL THAT THE AUDITOR
MENTIONED.
H. TWO SUITES WAS AWARDED TO OUR
MAYOR SPREAD THIS EMPLOYER.
.
A COMPETITIVE BID A WAS NOT DONE.
IT WAS THAT GIVEN A THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT WAS
AWARDED INTENDED AS.
WHAT COMPETITORS WHAT CAN
COMPETENT?
BUSINESS CAN MAKE A BUSINESS
PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT IN TEN DAYS
THAT'S UNHEARD OF.
AND WE HAD AN INCIDENT WHERE A
TIRE COMPANY.
IT WAS GIVEN OUT IN HIS IT IS
CONTRACT HAD EXPIRED BE EXTENDED
IT. AND THEY GAVE HIM A THREE
PERCENT INTERESTS.
INCREASE
TO GIVE HIS EMPLOYEES A RAISE.
THAT'S UNHEARD OF BUT THEY
AWARDED IT. I'VE GIVEN YOU
COPIES OF INFRASTRUCTURE NOW
THAT COMPANY.
IS AN ENGINEERING THAT DOES ALL
OUR ENGINEERING WORK.
ON ONE OF THE FORMS OF SEE WHERE
IT SAYS OUR CITY IS WAVING. THE
BIDDING PRACTICE OF FROM FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
PROJECT AND YOU GOT IT WAS
HONORED JENDA.
THEY ALSO GONNA GIVE THEM. THEY
WANTED TO BELIEVE IN SPEAKING UP.
A CONTRACT TO REVIEW THE PARK
CULTIVATION APPLICATIONS.
SO WE HAVE FORTY PLUS
APPLICATIONS AT FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS THAT'S A FIRST ROUND.
THEY WERE GOING TO GIVE ALL THAT
MANY TO THIS COMPANY.
THERE ENGINEERS WHAT BUSINESS
THEY HAVE.
BUT THEN WE FOUND OUT ON THEIR
NEWSLETTER THEY'RE NOT PROMOTING
THEMSELVES AS THE GOLD RUSH AND
A STRIKE TEAM FOR POT
CULTIVATION.
SO HOW CAN YOU BE ON ONE HAND.
REVIEWING THE APPLICATIONS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN
YOUR CITY AND ON THE OTHER HAND
ST WE CAN SERVICE YOUR COMPANY
IS THAT INSIDER TRADING. HE'S
GONNA HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYBODY
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE A LICENSE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WE HAVE IN
MONTEBELLO.
PICK PRO PRO AND THIS MAN HAS
GIVEN DONATIONS STEP.
MEMBERS OF THE COUNCIL. AND I
PLEASE DEALING I ASK PLEASE GIVE
US A FULL FORENSIC AUDIT
INCLUDING CONTRACTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
YES.
YES WE DID SPEAK FOR HIM.
WE ARE CURRENTLY B. COLLIE THE
MAYOR AND THE MAYOR PRO TEM
MAYOR VANESSA DOT DARRO WHO
HAPPENS TO BE READY FOR THE
THIRTY SECOND A SENATE SEAT. SHE
APPOINTED HERSELF MAYOR TO LOOK
BETTER AS THE MAYOR WHICH IS
READY FOR THE SENATE SEAT.
THE MAYOR PRO TEM. ALSO THEY
BUMPED THE PERSON THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN THE MAYOR AND THE
MAYOR PRO TEM.
TO CONTROL THE VOTE AND THAT'S
ALL THEY DOING. AND THE PROBLEM
WE HAVE IS.
AGAIN FAVORITISM WITH CONTRACTS
AND.
MISS DELGADO SAID WRITER FRIEND
OF ON THE DIETS.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET A FULL
FORENSIC AUDIT THEY'RE NOT GONNA
LOOK AT CONTRACTS.
THAT'S RIGHT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
TO HAVE OF FULL FORENSIC GOT A.
PLEASE LOOK AT OUR CONTRACTS
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY AND I WILL
BE FORWARDING IT TO YOUR OFFICE
YOU. WE HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS
MARK OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A FURTHER YES PLEASE COME FOR.
T. LIKE AGO I AND RESIDENT OF
MINE ABOUT FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS.
OF MY CONCERN WITH THEIR CITY IS
THAT THEY HAVE FOUGHT ALLOW
COUNCILMEMBERS TO USE CITY
FACILITIES WITHOUT PAYING A
PENNY TO IT. PRIVATE TELEPHONE
LINES ELECTRICAL WE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR ALL
THIS THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS AND I HAD THIS
PASS OUT. THIS IS ONE OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THIS.
O. COUNCIL MEMBER IS SLOW
LEADER OF THIS BAND. AND SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES.
ALSO I'M VERY CONCERNED WITH OUR
CITY MANAGER THAT HAD BEEN UP
ALL. ON OF ADMINISTRATIVE LIVE
LEAVE FOR. ALL SIX MONTHS
WITH PAY.
AND DEL WE KEEP ON BRINGING THAT
UP WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO STOP
THAT.
AND DOT ONE OF OUR OLD DOGS THE
MAYORS FROM CITY JUST ADDRESS
THE FACT THAT. IT'S THREE MONTHS.
AND YOU CAN GET AN EXTENSION FOR
ALL NOTES ABOUT ONE MONTH AND
YOU CAN GET IN TOUCH WITH THREE
MONTHS.
BUT IT'S BEEN SIX MONTHS AND
THIS
PERSON IS STILL ON PAGE.
LEAF AND BENEFITS ACCUMULATING.
AND THE CITY HAS DONE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING. TO.
TAKE CARE OF THIS PROBLEM AND
THIS IS JUST A FEW OF THE ISSUES
THAT CORNER CITY. FAVORITISM AND
ALL IN OUR CONTRACTS ARE NOT OUT
TO BIT THIS ISN'T NINETEEN OF
BIDDERS COME MEANT WELL YOU KNOW
ONE FOR THAT THE MONEY ONE OF
CULTIVATION THE HAVE. FORTY
APPLICATIONS ALREADY HOW COME.
FOURTY APPLICATIONS FOR THAT AND
NO BITS FOR THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE INNER CITY.
THERE IS SOMETHING VERY VERY
WRONG IN OUR COMMUNITY AND IT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR A VERY LONG
TIME AND THIS IS ALL. A
TAXPAYERS SAW MANY ITS PUBLIC
FUNDS ABUSE OF PUBLIC FUNDS
SO WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL GOING
HELPLESS WE REDEEM THE CHAIR
HELP THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW OUR STATE AUDITOR.
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE CITIZENS
OF MONTEBELLO THAT THEY CAME ALL
THE WAY UP HERE TO TESTIFY THAT
COULD YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF.
WHETHER YOU'LL BE REVIEWING THE
CONTRACTING PROCEDURES.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE DO HAVE A SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVE LOOKING AT.
MEN MONTEBELLO'S COMPLIANCE
WITH BEST PRACTICES WITH RESPECT
TO.
.
SECURING GOODS AND SERVICES THAT
WE WE CONTEMPLATED THAT STEP
THAT OBJECTIVE WOULD BE
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT THEIR
CONTRACTING PRACTICES BECAUSE WE
HAD HEARD. SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS ARE. FROM.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE OF THE
CITY OF MONTEBELLO AS WELL AS
AWESOME CITIZENS OF THE CITY OF
MY BILL THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE CITIZENS OF
MONTEBELLO YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE
BEING HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR.
I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL BE.
APPROVING THIS AUDIT REQUESTS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
UP.
MS AUDITOR WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
AFFECT.
BUSH HAS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
TO THE MOTION WAS MADE BY MS
RUBIO.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TASH EIGHT
ZERO TWO REQUESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR. THE SUBJECT CITY OF
MONTEBELLO UNDER THE LOCAL HIGH
RISK PROGRAM THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I A VOTE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY ITCHY.
PURSUIT SHE AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE IS
ARYAN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WEIGHED.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN.
CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER.
I. SORRY CENTER BAO.
THOUGH I.
OKAY WE ARE SHORT ONE SENATE
VOTE AND SO.
WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN.
I AT THIS TIME I LIKE TO.
.
ASK FOR.
ROLL CALL ON ALL OF THE
PREVIOUS.
ITEMS THAT HAVE NOT ALREADY BEEN
PASSED.
I WILL CALL THE NAME OF THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT VOTED IN.
AN ALL STAR FROM THE BEGINNING.
ROLL CALL TO PROVE.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TASH ONE ONE THREE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION IN PRISON.
REHABILITATION PROGRAM REQUESTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JONES SAWYER
IN CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY MAY AND THE CHAIRS ARE
COMMENDATIONS AN AIBO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
BAKER I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WOULD.
SENATOR ROTH.
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BELL.
BELL AYE CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE.
SENATOR FULLER WHICH LIKE TO
VOTE ON THIS.
THERE FULLER NOT VOTING.
LARA.
TARA RIGHT WE ARE SHORT ONE
SENATE VOTE. ON THAT ITEM.
.
YES.
AUDIT NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE WINE TEN
REQUESTED BY SENATOR TEENS THE
CITY OF WING CAN ADMINISTRATION
OF PUBLIC FINDS. THAT SHARES
RECOMMENDATIONS AN AYE VOTE.
THE ITS OUR ALL A PREVIOUSLY.
MOVED AND SECONDED WITH AND
VOTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. RUBIO I
WOULD.
SENATOR BELL.
BELL AYE CANNELLA.
I.
LARA.
ALRIGHT THE AUDIT FOR THE CITY
OF LINCOLN IS APPROVED.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
ONE SEVEN. REQUESTED BY SENATOR
LARA AT THE CITY IN COUNTY JAILS
CONTRACTS WITH US IMMIGRATION
CUSTOM ENFORCEMENT THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AYE VOTES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA.
COSTS ARE NOT VOTING.
MS ARYAN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO.
WADE.
SENATOR RAW.
SENATOR ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BELL.
BELL.
I.
IN THEY SAW THAT IF THEIR
INTERESTS AND THIS IS ONLY MY IS
THERE TO STOP IN WHICH LIGHTS A
VOTE ON THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE ONE SEVEN
REQUEST BY SENATOR LARA AT THE
CITY AND COUNTY JAILS CONTRACT
WITH ICED. THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AYE VOTES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN.
THE SYRIAN I.
ALRIGHT WE ARE SHORT ONE
SENATE VOTE.
pARMS AND I THE TYPICAL AYE I DID
NOT CALL YOU I APOLOGIZE SENATOR
CANNELLA. CANNELLA AYE.
ALRIGHT THAT REQUEST.
NOW IT
.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TASH ONE
ONE FIVE REQUESTED BY CENTER
COLLEGE YANNI OF THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES OVERSIGHT OF
THE HEALTH PLAN OF SAN JOAQUIN.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS AN
AYE VOTES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE NAZARIAN.
THIS IS THE ONE FIFTEEN.
NO THERE AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I SENATOR ROTH I'M
SENATOR ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I FELL.
WELL I.
LARA.
THAT THE MOTION PASSES.
ROLL CALL FOR I REQUEST NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TASH ONE
ONE SIX
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA AT
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO'S. MANAGEMENT OF THE
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK.
THE TEARS RECOMMENDATIONS AN
AIBO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I.
SENATOR RAW.
ROTH AYE ALLEN. ALLEN I FELL.
WELL I.
LARA.
THAT MOTION PASSES.
BROKAW SUPREME AUDIT NUMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE ONE
ONE REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WAITING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WADE AND CENTER CANNELLA OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. CHILDREN AND MEDICAL
ACCESS TO CARE AND PREVENTIVE
SERVICES THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS AND I.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS ARYAN.
NAZARIAN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE CENTER ROTH.
SENATOR ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I FELL.
BELLE I. AM LARA.
IT THAT REQUEST PASSES.
WE'LL CALL TO PROVE AUDIT NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH EIGHT
OH TO REQUESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR OF THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO UNDER THE LOCAL HIGH
RISK PROGRAM.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AN
AYE VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMAN REYES ARYAN.
AND THEREIN I WEIGHED.
WOULD I.
SENATOR RAW AYE AYE ROTH AYE
ALLEN.
ALLEN I.
LARA AYE LARA AYE.
SENATOR BAO.
BELL I.
ALL RIGHT THEIR REQUEST IS OUT
WE ARE ONE VOTE ONE CENT OF A
SHORT ON ITEM NUMBER NINE.
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS.
.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AGAIN.
ROLL CALL FOR APPROVAL OF ITEM
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE ONE THREE AGAIN THAT
YEAR'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND AYE
VOTES AND THIS IS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PARK FRACTIONS AND
REHABILITATION IN PRISON
REHABILITATION PROGRAM.
REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JONES SAWYER AND CALDERON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAYNE.
WOULD I.
LARA.
LARA I.
ALL RIGHT THAT REQUEST PASSES.
IT WAS MOVED Y. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MISSOURIAN AND SECOND ABOUT
MYSELF.
SENATE VOTED.
THERE.
YEAH WHEN WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
ATWATER.
.
BEFORE WE.
YELL LET'S LET'S HEAR THE NEXT
ITEM THAN.
WHICH IS THE LAST ITEM.
THE HIGH RISK AUDIT REQUESTS
FOR THE CITY OF ATWATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
WE'RE REQUESTING APPROVAL TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF THE CITY OF
ATWATER OH BASED ON SOME OF OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENT WORK WE DID
AND LOOKING AT NOT ONLY.
INFORMATION THAT'S REPORTED TO
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
BUT IN AUDIT THAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER CONDUCTED A BACK IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN SO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE SIMILAR TO TO
WHAT I REFERRED TO IN MY PRIOR
PRESENTATION. WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE FINANCIAL CONDITION OF THE
CITY OF ATWATER AND WE'VE NOTED
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF
THE ATWATER GENERAL FUND BALANCE.
HAS DROPPED FROM A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR.
RESERVE TO ADD THEIR IN A
DEFICIT SITUATION.
HAVE ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE GENERAL FUND HAS.
BASICALLY THERE RESERVE HAS BEEN
DEPLETED IN ADDITION TO THAT AND
THE COMPTROLLER'S REPORT THAT
WAS ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR THE CONTROLLER IDENTIFIED
ISSUES WHERE THEY WERE USING
GENERAL FUND MONEY ARTS UP MONEY
FROM OTHER FUNDS. TO COVER
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES.
THEY'VE CONTROLLER RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THOSE
PROCESSES.
WORKED ATWATER RETRO LACK
RETROACTIVELY APPROVED SOME
LOANS TO THE GENERAL TO THE
GENERAL FUND FROM THE WATER AND
SANITATION FINES BUT IT WAS
UNCLEAR AS TO.
THE REPAYMENT TERMS AND AND
WHETHER OR NOT THAT WOULD BE
ADDRESSED BUT A BIGGER ISSUE IS
LOOKING OUT THE FINANCIAL
FORECASTING THEIR GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES ARE TYPICALLY
EXCEEDING THEIR REVENUE. AND THE
LAST TEN OUT OF ELEVEN YEARS
THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT THERE WAS
AN EXCESS OF EXPENDITURES OVER
ANOTHER REVENUE COMING IN. AS
MANY CITIES ARE FACING OUR
RETIREMENT.
COSTS FOR RETIREMENT BENEFITS
OUGHT BOTH A REGULAR RETIREMENT
BENEFITS AND A POST EMPLOYMENT
WHICH IS YOUR MAN HEALTH AND
MEDICAL.
WE'RE ALSO INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT WHAT THE CITY OF THAT
WATER IS DOING TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT PARTICULAR CONCERN. THEY
HAVE WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEY
HAVE MADE SOME ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR DEFICITS UP BUT
AGAIN WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
TREND. OF THE EXPENDITURES ARE
CONSISTENTLY EXCEEDING THEIR
THEIR REVENUES THEY HAVE HAD
SIGNIFICANT TURNOVER IN THEIR
MANAGEMENT GROUP THEY'VE HAD
SEVEN CITY MANAGERS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
SOME INTERIM CITY MANAGERS.
.
SO WITH THAT WITH ALL OF THOSE
CONCERNS WE PUT TOGETHER A SCOPE
AND OBJECTIVES SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS REALLY WANTING TO LOOK AT
THEIR FINANCIAL POSITION. THEIR
ABILITY TO MEET NOT ONLY THEIR
SHORT TERM OBLIGATIONS BUT LONG
TERM FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS A
WHAT ARE THEY DOING TO REPAY THE
CENTER FUND LOANS WHAT'S THEIR
PROCESS WHAT'S THEIR INTENT TO
DO THAT. POWER THEY ADDRESSING
SOME OF THEIR PENSION
OBLIGATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
THEIR PROCESS FOR SETTING
UTILITY RATES WE HAD SOME
CONCERNS WITH THAT AGAIN LOOKING
AT THE COMPTROLLER'S REPORT WHAT
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS HAVE THEY
TAKEN. IN RESPONSE TO THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN REPORT ISSUED BY THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND THEN
ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT EFFORTS
THEY'VE TAKEN TO FILL SOME OF
THESE KEY MANAGEMENT POSITIONS.
THE LEADERSHIP POSITIONS THAT
THEY NEED TO TO ESTABLISH SOME
KIND OF CONTINUITY ON THEIR
OPERATIONS AYE AYES AYE
INDICATED THE BUDGET FOR THIS
AUDIT IS ABOUT A LITTLE OVER
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS. THAT
WOULD TAKE US.
BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR MONTHS
TO COMPLETE THE WORK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE REP
CENTER FROM THE CITY OF ATWATER.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
LAURIE WATERMAN CITY MANAGER
ATWATER I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AYE
REGARDING OUR ITEM THIS MORNING
AND I'LL DEFER MY TIME TO
ATTORNEY LIKE.
I WAS CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS DOUG WHITE I'M WITH
THE LAW FIRM OF CHURCH WHAT
WHITE IN THE CONTRACT CITY
ATTORNEY FOR. THE CITY ABOUT
WATER I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
AREA WE REPRESENT FIVE OR SIX
OTHER CITIES AS WELL SPECIAL
JURISDICTIONS US. OUR SPECIAL IN
THEM. AGENCIES OVER THERE.
IN IN THE AREA AND.
RECENTLY CAME ON BOARD THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF TURNOVER IN
THE CITY OF ATWATER TO MOSTLY
BEEN DUE TO THE USE OF RETIRED
ANNUITANTS.
AND OTHER REASONS BUT WE HAVE
PUT INTO PLACE WITH THE.
PLAN THAT GENTLEMAN WHO ARE
JUST PREVIOUSLY WORKED WITH THIS
WASN'T A NEW ONE.
TO GET TO TAKE REALLY PROACTIVE
MEASURE SO THE THREAT OF THE
AUDIT HAS DONE ITS INTENDED
EFFECT WHICH IS TO HAVE OF THE
CITY. TAKE MEASURES IN PROACTIVE
STEPS TO GET ITS HOUSE IN ORDER.
AND THE FIRST THING THAT IS DOES
THE CITY'S LIQUIDATING ITS ON
SURPLUS PROPERTY WE ALREADY HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
UNDER CONTRACT.
AND WE EXPECT TO HAVE.
IN TOTAL SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWO
AND THREE MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF.
CITY PROPERTY SURPLUS AND SOLD
WHICH WOULD PAY OFF ANY DEBT
THAT IS VOTE UP WITH LAKE PLUS
ONE.
TOO THAT THE SEWER FUND WHICH
IS TO ENTER FUND LOAN THAT HAS
BEEN TAKEN CARE OF. IN ADDITION
TO THAT I WE PRINT WE PROJECTED
OR IN THE PROCESS OF ENTERING
INTO AGREEMENTS.
TO UP FOR ANOTHER ONE AND A HALF
TO TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS A WITH OTHER BUSINESSES
THAT WE'VE ENTERED INTO SIMILAR
ARRANGEMENTS BY WITHIN THE AREA.
AND WE THINK THAT'S VERY
DEPENDABLE AND INCOME
PARTICULARLY IN THE SHORT TERM.
WELL.
SOME THE THIRD MEASURES WE'VE
TAKEN IS WELL WE DONE RECLASSED
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING A
REORGANIZATION AND REACT THREE
CLASSIFICATION OF THE CITY. AND
ELIMINATING THOSE PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO MAKE SOME
RECREATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT UP WE
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP FOR THE CITY
BUT. CITIES BUT FINANCIAL
SITUATION WE'RE LOOKING AT AND
IMPLEMENT WHAT I CALL KIND OF AN
AUSTERITY MEASURES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS IT CITIES HOUSES OF
FINANCIAL ORDER. AND WE'RE
CHANGING THE WAY THAT WE DO
BUDGETING AND PLANNING SO WE'RE
DOING IT NOW REVERSED THE FACT
WE'VE ENTERED INTO AGREEMENTS
WITH PARS WE'RE SETTING ASIDE
OUR OPEC OBLIGATIONS ARE CALPERS
OBLIGATIONS. AS WELL SETTING UP
THE BUDGET GENERAL FUND RESERVE
IN ADVANCE OF ALL THOSE ARE THE
THINGS OF THE CITY'S OPERATING
ON ON WHAT ON WHAT IT CAN AFFORD
AND NOT WHAT I CAN'T AFFORD WHAT
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. WERE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING IT AS YOU DO RAPPER
YEP SKIP WITHOUT A STRICT BUDGET
MEASURES WE HIRED RGS TO TO HELP
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS THREE
MONTHS. TO BE ABLE TO REPORT
BACK TO YOU UP ON THE PROGRESS
THAT WE MADE KNOWING THAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE ABOUT SIX MONTHS.
TO SEE THE TRUE FACTS OF IT WE
WOULD JUST LIKE SOMETIME BEFORE
THIS KIND OF NEXTSTEP COMES
BECAUSE OF THE LABEL THAT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AND THAT
THE INABILITY OF OUR. WHAT WE
HAVE TO DISCLOSE TO THE BOND
WORLD?
AS WELL AS.
WHAT THAT MIGHT DO FOR FUTURE
RECRUITMENT OF HIGH CALIBER TELL
SO THINK EATER?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SARAH CANAL. I JUST JUST A
COMMENT.
WITHOUT WATERS IN MY DISTRICT
AND I HAVE WORKED VERY CLOSE TO
THAT WATER FOR SOMETIME AND AND
OTHERS HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR FINANCES.
THIS AUDIT GROUP INITIALLY CAME
UP IN JANUARY. WHERE?
YOU KNOW DIDN'T COME UP FOR
WHATEVER REASON AND NOW I'M I'M
VERY CONFIDENT THIS TEAM THAT'S
WORKING ON THIS SIDE YOU KNOW
GOV BINDER HAVE BEEN GOING
THROUGH THEIR PROGRAM.
I THINK WE'RE ASKING FOR SYSTEM
THREE MONTHS AWAY. BUT SCHEDULED
FOR AUGUST I MEAN I I'VE BEEN
THE FODDER CAN TELL ME WHAT'S
THE WORST CASE THERE'S GONNA
HAPPEN IN THREE MONTHS BUT. IF
THEY HAVE NOT DEMONSTRATED TO
THE AUDITOR THEY'VE GOT THEIR
FINANCES AND CONTROL THAT I WILL
SUPPORT THE OUT OF BUT IF WE YOU
KNOW SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS TO
THE STATE AUDITOR'S LIKE TEN
THOUSAND HOURS TO THE CITY ABOUT
WATER. I THINK IT'S BETTER IF
THEY USE THAT TIME IN THE NEXT
THREE MONTHS TO GET THEIR
FINANCIAL HOUSE IN ORDER IF IT
DOESN'T IF IT'S DOESN'T OUTERS.
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL DO NOT
AND SO I WOULD JUST ASK FOR A
THREE MONTH.
THANK YOU.
STATE AUGER WHICH LIKE TO
RESPOND COM CERTAINLY AYE AYE
THEM IT'S DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY
WHAT THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
WOULD BE THE CONCERN WE HAVE IS.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS THEY HAVE
RUN A SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT THEY
HAD BUT THE CITY OF WHAT THAT
WATER HAD A RESERVE AMOUNT OF
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS AGO. THE LAST FIVE SIX
YEARS THEY'VE RUN A DEFICIT IN
THEIR GENERAL FUND WHAT THEY'VE
HAD TO DO IS CUT BACK ON VARIOUS
SERVICES SO IF THAT CONTINUES.
WHERE ELSE ARE THEY GOING TO
LOOK TO CUT SO THE CONCERN WE
WOULD HAVE AND AND WE CERTAINLY
WILL DEFERRED OF THEIR? THAT THE
COMMITTEE.
S WE FELT THAT THIS WAS A VERY
HIGH RISK CITY BECAUSE OF NOT
JUST THE GENERAL FUND DEFICIT
BUT THE INNER LOW ENTER. ENTER
FIND LOANS.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
COMPTROLLER'S JUST LAST WEEK WE STAFFER JUST
BEGINNING TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO GET INTO THE CITY OF ATWATER
NOW BUT CERTAINLY WILL DEFER TO
THE DESIRE OF THE COMMITTEE IF
THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO DELAY.
AND WAIT UNTIL THE AUGUST
HEARING. WE WILL RESPECT THAT.
WE JUST FELT THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO GET AND I
GET THIS WORK DONE IMMEDIATELY
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO WORK
NOW SARAH CANNELLA IT JUST
JUSTICE BUT I DON'T WANT TO
DEBATE OUR HONOR BECAUSE I WOULD
LOSE.
BUT HAS A AS A LOCAL A MAYOR YOU
KNOW WE WE WENT THROUGH WE HAD A
VERY IS A SUBSTANTIAL.
GENERAL FUND BALANCE AS WELL
AND THE RECESSION TOOK ALMOST
ALL OF THAT SO ALL THE CITIES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ARE DOING
THEIR VERY BEST TO GET ON TOP OF
THIS.
GET OUT WATER DO WE WILL SEE I'M
JUST ASKING FOR A THREE MONTH
DELAY I I CAN'T IMAGINE THINGS
FALLING APART WITHIN THREE.
SURE.
SOME LIVER RUBIO.
SENATOR ALAN CENTER LARA.
IN.
I THINK IN.
AND.
I I KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S
HARD TO PUT PREDICT WHAT THE
WORST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN BUT
I THINK WE DID A FROM MONTEBELLO
AND WE'D WE GIVE THEM THE
COURTESY OF. OF OUR ALLOWING
THEM TO TRY AND GET THEIR HOUSE
IN ORDER. AND.
IF THE COMMITTEE SO WHICH IS I
THINK IT WOULD BE A APPROPRIATE
TO GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY NOW.
IF WE DO THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO EAT MY WORDS
LATER AND SOMETHING TRAGIC
HAPPENS SO IF YOU CAN ASSURE ME
THAT THIS IS BEING DONE THEN I
WILL SUPPORT THE EXTENSION OR
THE. THE PAS IF YOU WELL UNTIL
AUGUST BUT I DON'T WANT TO PUT
IT. ON THE RESIDENTS OF ATWATER
AT RISK BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY IN SEOUL YOU KNOW
THIS IS A DIFFICULT DECISION FOR
US BUT I KNOW WE DID IT FOR THE
CITY OF MONTEBELLO ALSO THAT
BECAUSE THERE CITY MANAGER WHO
HAD BEEN ON THE JOB ONLY FOR ONE
DAY. BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
ASSURANCES I CAN GET BUT PLEASE
DON'T MAKE US EAT OUR WORDS
LATER.
YOU HAVE OUR OUR OUR EXECUTIVE
TEAMS PROFESSIONAL COMMITMENTS.
ALRIGHT BUT YOU JUST BEFORE WE
GO TO CENTER ALLEN DESCENDANTS
ARE LARA ME WE COULD CONSIDER. A
MOTION THAT IT DID TO TO APPROVE
THEIR AUDIT.
UPON SOME CONDITION.
AND THE AND THE AND I'M OPEN TO
IDEAS SENATOR ALAN.
WELL. IT MIGHT MY TENDENCIES TO
WANT TO DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES
WHO I THINK DOWN.
NO. CERTAINLY WANTS TO SEE.
THINGS MADE RIGHT IN THE CITY
ITEM I GUESS IF IF WE'RE GOING
TO SUPPORT A DELAY I THINK WE
WOULD ALL ASK YOU PERSONALLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THERE'S
GOOD PROGRESS BEING MADE IN.
BUT I I WOULD.
MATT.
YEAH CON THOUGH THEN AND THEN A
FIRE IF AYE WELL AS IF YOU WILL
I WILL MAKE A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE AUDIT BUT FOR IT TO BEGIN IN
AUGUST HOUSE THAT. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT IT'S OUR GOAL IN AUGUST
THAT THERE'S NOT ONE REQUIRED SO
FEW PROVE THE AUDIT STARTING IN
AUGUST AND THEY'VE MADE
SUBSTANTIAL. IMPROVEMENT THEN
THEN AUDIT GOES FORWARD I I
THINK OUR GOAL IS FOR THEM TO TO
GET THEIR HOUSE OVER SO THAT IT
OUGHT IS NOT NECESSARY AGAIN IF
IT IS. THEN THEY START AUGUST WE
HAVE A MEETING IN AUGUST WE CAN
APPROVE AND I WILL I WILL
SUPPORT OUT AT THAT TIME
DIFFERENT SENATOR LARA THEN BY
SARAH.
I THINK YOU I'M INTRIGUED ABOUT.
CHAIRMAN YOUR YOUR MOTION OF.
OUR OR.
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT APPROVING
NODDED WITH CONDITIONS IF THEY
HAVE AN MATT.
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS ON WHAT
THAT WOULD BE.
BUT CERTAIN ALLOWS US SOMETHING.
THAT'S CONSIDERED THAT WE WE
DON'T.
YOU KNOW IT BELIEVE.
IT GIVES YOU THE INSURANCE THAT
YOU KNOW NOT THAT. TO YOU KNOW.
CUP POLICE ANY BLAME GIVEN THAT
DOESN'T AN EXECUTIVE TEAM
LOOKING AT I MEAN THAT THEY
PROTEST TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS
RIGHT SO THAT.
ON IT WILL KICK IN.
I I MEAN I I THINK THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING WORTHY OF LOOKING OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOW THE THE.
THAT MAY NOT A THREAT BUT YOU
KNOW THE ASSURANCE THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT IT LOOMING IF
WE DON'T GET THIS RIGHT I MEAN I
THINK. THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
HIGH RISK ON IT.
PROGRAM IS ABOUT TO BE EVER
CATCHES AND I DON'T SEE THIS AS
A FAULT. THAT TO KERN FOLKS BUT
AN ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THE CITIZENS OF THAT WATER WHICH
IS ALSO EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT SO
ARE IS WHAT IT'S ABOUT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF I MAY I GUESS IT
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER RIGHT SO
IF WE APPROVE THAT THE OTHER
STARTS IN AUGUST IN LEICESTER
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENT. AND THE
AUDITOR AT THAT TIME SAYS WE
DON'T NEED TO DO A LOT OF THINGS
ARE REAT THAT WE COULD JUST I'M
ASSUMING CANCEL AT THE AUGUST
MEETING. SO I THINK IT'S SIX OF
WHAT HAPPENED AS THE OTHER AYE
AYE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT RIGHT IF I
COULD WE WOULD WOULD JUST WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THE CRITERIA WOULD
BE BECAUSE I'M WHAT WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE CAN HAVE A A
BUDGET GOING FORWARD. AND WE CAN
SHOW WHEN DEMONSTRATE HOW WE
WOULD SET ASIDE RESERVE FUND IS
WEALTH COMMITMENTS TO. OPEC
REQUIREMENTS CALPERS
REQUIREMENTS THE IDEA THAT ALL
OF US AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A TWO
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
RESERVE IT'S PROBABLY NOT
REALISTIC APPOINTS WHAT I CAN DO
IS READ IT REVERSED SHOW THAT
WERE REVERSING THE TREND. AND I
WOULD JUST ASK THAT THAT MAY NOT
BE AT THE AUDITOR'S DISCRETION
BUT IT BE AT THIS COMMITTEES
DISCRETION WELL BECAUSE WHILE
THE OTHER PERSON WHETHER OR NOT
IT WOULD MAKE DIRECTLY I.
THE AUDITOR.
IT WOULD BE INCLUDED.
AGAIN WE KNOW WE'RE NOT A I'M
SORRY I'M SPEAKING OUT OF OUT OF
MY BED TO THE CHAIR. OF COURSE
WE'RE NOT EXPECTING I WOULDN'T
EXPECT YOU TO ALICE HAVING COME
UP WITH AS MONEY BECAUSE THEN
YOU WOULD REALLY NEED ABOUT IT.
A LOT THAT.
AYE SHOWING THAT WHERE YOU WERE
REVERSING THE TREND ISN'T AS
IMPORTANT.
BEFORE WE CALL ON THE VICE CHAIR
AYE IT.
CLARIFICATION TO THE AUDITOR
CAN.
I I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO TERMINATE ON YOUR
OWN A JUDGMENT THE INITIAL
ASSESSMENTS.
BUT THAT DOES NOT APPLYING FOR.
AND AUDIT APPROVED BY BUDGET IN
JAIL LIKE IS THAT CORRECT WELL I
I THINK MISTER CHAIR IF THE
COMMITTEE DECIDES TO APPROVE AN
AUDIT WITH CERTAIN CONDITIONS
THAT I WOULD REPORT BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE. AT OUR AUGUST HEARING
THEM ASSUMING WE WILL HAVE IN
AUGUST
HEARING TO CONSIDER I REQUEST WE
COULD CERTAINLY REPORT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND SAY WE'VE
LOOKED AT MATERIALS THAT THE
CITY OF ATWATER. HAS PROVIDED TO
US RECENTLY WE'VE ALSO ENGAGED
WITH IF THE CITY'S WILLING TO DO
THAT ENGAGE WITH THEM OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DO WITH TENNIS INITIAL
ASSESSMENT WHEN WE CONDUCT OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENTS. WE ARE
ENGAGING WITH LOCALS.
IT AND NOW IT'S VOLUNTARY IT'S
PUBLIC INFORMATION HIS WAY ON
ABSTRACT STORY AUTHORITY TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT BORE CERTAINLY
LOOKING TO SEE. YOU MAY BE IN A
DEFICIT SITUATION RIGHT NOW BUT
DO YOU HAVE PLANS AND DO THOSE
PLANS LOOK REASONABLE AND THAT'S
THE CRITERIA THAT WE WOULD BE
USING. DURING THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS IN WORKING WITH
THE CITY OF ATWATER. ARM IN
PREPARATION TO COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SAY YOU KNOW THE
COMMITTEE COULD RESEND THE AUDIT
IN AUGUST
SAYING THAT BASED ON THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE'VE DONE IN. THE
ABILITY ENGAGE WITH THE CITY
THAT. THE RISKS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED MAY STILL BE THERE
BUT THE PLANS AND PROTOCOLS THAT
THE CITY HAS PUT IN PLACE WE
THINK ARE REASONABLE SO WHAT WE
WOULD IN ALL LIKELIHOOD DO. IN
THAT SITUATION IF WE DON'T
CONDUCT AN AUDIT WE WOULD STAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE CITY OF THAT WATER
AND IF WE FELT THERE WERE
CONCERNS WE MIGHT COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE NEXT YEAR.
AND AND REQUEST AN AUDIT AGAIN
SO I THINK WE CERTAINLY COULD DO
THAT I DON'T KNOW IF MY GENERAL
COUNSEL. YOU AGREE WITH ME.
MIGHT NOT SO MY I'M DEFERRING TO
MY CHIEF COUNSEL HAS UNDERSTANDS
OUR REGULATORY. AUTHORITY S.
THINK IF THE COMMITTEE MAKES A
DECISION TO BASICALLY
CONDITIONALLY APPROVED THE AUDIT.
AND EXPECT THAT MY OFFICE
REPORT BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE IN
AUGUST I THINK WE CAN DO THAT.
BY SARAH.
WELL.
LET ME.
IF WE WERE GOING TO HAVE A
MEETING IN AUGUST IN MY POSITION
ON THIS WOULD CHANGE.
BUT I WOULD NOTE THAT THE ART
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO HOURS
WHICH IS WHAT THE ESTIMATE IS SO
I WON'T BE DONE TOMORROW ANYWAY.
IT PROBABLY CAN'T START TOMORROW
SO THERE'S SOME SPOOL UP TIME
FOR THIS THING.
BUT APPROVAL OF AN AUDITS HAS
CONSEQUENCES
SO IF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS TO GIVE.
THE CITY THAT'S ATTEMPTING TO
RIGHT THE SHIP IN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SO BEFORE WE LAUNCH AN AUDIT
TEAM IN THERE THEN.
CONDITIONALLY APPROVING AN AUDIT
HAS CONSEQUENCES THAT.
MAY NOT BE REVERSIBLE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE GET THIS ON
THIS DIRE AS CAN SET SPECIFIC
ENOUGH CONDITIONS ON A LOT OF
APPROVAL TO MAKE ANY SENSE OF IT.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO BE BACK
HERE WITH THIS ITEM AGENDA IT
ANYWAY IN AUGUST WOULD BE MY
GUESS EITHER BECAUSE. THE
AUDITOR DECIDES IT OR NOT IT'S
NOT REQUIRED WITH THE CITY
DISPUTES THE AUDITOR'S POSITION
ON WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
SO I GUESS WHAT I WOULD
SUGGESTIVE IS IF THE INTENT.
AND THE SPIRIT IN THE INTEREST
OF THOSE OF US ON THE DYESS IS
TO GIVE THIS THIS YOUR LOCAL
JURISDICTION AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THE WATER OUT OF THE BOAT
BEFORE WE CAN MEN.
AS A STATE THEN LET'S GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE WATER
OUT OF THE BOAT.
GEN DID IN AUGUST IS NECESSARY
AND THAT THE AUDITOR STOPPED
START THE ON IF YOU CAN'T FIX IT.
THAT WOULD BE MY SUGGESTION
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'RE GONNA BE
TRYING TO.
DESIGN CONDITIONS ON AUDIT
APPROVAL HERE THAT ARE GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO DESIGN.
ANYWAY.
THAT'S MY COMMENT MISTER CHAIR
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
SO. I'M I'M REVIEWING THE THE
RULES OF A.
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND.
AS PART OF THE RULES RULE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE FOR COMMITTEE
ACTIONS HAS APPROVED THE REQUEST
DENIED THE REQUEST OR.
THE THIRD OPTION RETAIN THE
REQUEST FOR FUTURE CONSIDERATION
SENECA WELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION TO THAT EFFECT.
YEAH MOVES FOR A FUTURE
CONSIDERATION.
OKAY.
IS OUR SECOND MS CHAIR BEFORE
WE TAKE OF I'M SORRY TO SOMEONE
UP TO CLARIFY BEFORE I VOTE.
WOULD IT IF THIS BAR MOTION
PASSES WOULD PRECLUDE. THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE FROM WORKING
WITH THE CITY OF ATWATER.
CLIMATE LET ME ASK THE HORRIFIC.
IF THE OUR.
IS THAT I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO. TO HAVE FIXED THE
THE PROBLEMS
IF.
AS WELL AS HERE ARE HOW LIMITED
YOU ARE YOU A BULL AGAIN I'LL
I'LL DEFER TO MY GENERAL COUNSEL
BUT I WOULD I WOULD HOPE AND
ASSUME UNDER OUR STATUTORY
AUTHORITY. AND OUR REGULATORY
AUTHORITY WE BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
ENTITIES SO BEFORE WE WOULD COME
BACK AND TAKE UP THIS
COMMITTEE'S TIME. I WOULD WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
CONSIDERING AND AS I INDICATED
THE CITY AND JUST RECENTLY LAST
WEEK SENT US I THINK IT'S THIS
BINDER MATERIALS MY STAFF HAVE
JUST STARTED LOOKING AT IT. SO I
WOULD I WOULD EXPECT THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO COULD CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE WITH THE CITY SO THAT
WHEN WE COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE. WERE COMING BACK WITH
AN INFORMED. A.
PROPOSAL AS TO WHETHER OR NOT WE
NEED TO TO CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF
THE CITY OF ATWATER I'LL SECOND
THAT CAN NARRATE WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION A SECOND FROM HIS
RUBIO. I SORT OF A POINT OUT
SEVERAL LORD THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE NEED TO
CLARIFY WHAT THE AUDITOR CAN. I
DO BEFORE A TAIL AND WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT YES WE HAVE HAD
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT MOST HAS BEEN MADE AND
SECONDED ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
SEEING NONE.
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE KALRA.
ROLL CALL TWO EIGHTEEN RETAINED
CONSIDERATION.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS
AND I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY
TI MERCY CHEAT AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I WOULD.
WOULD I SENATOR RAW.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BELL.
CANNELLA CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
LARA.
LARA I.
ALRIGHT THAT MOTION IS APPROVED.
WE WILL NOW.
ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD ON FOR ANY
PREVIOUS ITEM.
THAT WAS PASSED ALL ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PASSED
OR MOTIONS BEEN APPROVED.
YES EVERYTHING INCLUDING.
.
WE WILL LEAVE THEY'LL ROLL OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES.
YES BUT.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
MOVING THEIR LAND RIGHT NOW I
DON'T HAVE
ALRIGHT.
MY FELLOW I BELIEVED DEAD BUT
LET ME DOUBLE CHECK.
PLATO YOUR STORY AND. I DON'T
KNOW YOU MEDIA PRODUCT.
LYNN WOULD PLACE HIGHER.
LARA MISATTRIBUTED TO STAY.
SHE IS. ONE OF THE THINGS SHE.
YEAH.
NO.
CITY OF LINCOLN.
THERE ARE OTHERS.
SIMPLY CAN NO ITSELF IT
ALRIGHT THIS SUMMIT MEETING IS
ADJOURNED